SENATE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCE IN WATER -- WE ARE
GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT SEEING AS SENATOR
DODD IS HERE WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO COME PRESENT YES -- APOLOGIES
FOR THE DELAY SIR.
YOU'VE GOT A FEW MEASURES BEFORE
US HERE TODAY -- ONE OF WHICH IS
ON PROPOSED CONSENT.
THAT'S ITEM SIX OF THIS BEFORE
FOR TWO BUT THEN YOU'VE ALSO GOT
TO FORTY SEVEN IN.
TWO FIFTY THREE AT YOUR
DISCRETION PICK WHICH EITHER ONE
YOU WANT TO START WITH.
WE'LL START IF IT'S OKAY WITH
YOU MISS CHAIRED SB.
TWO FORTY SEVEN OKAY MADESS
CHAIR MEMBERS LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
OUT AS WE ALL KNOW EXTREME
WEATHER IS INCREASE THE NUMBER
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
LENGTH OF THE WILDFIRE SEASON.
YEARS OF DROUGHT RESULTING IN
MILLIONS OF DEAD TREES FOLLOWED
BY SUBSTANTIAL VEGETATION GROWTH.
DURING A RECORDSETTING WHAT
WINNER BECAME WILDFIRE FUEL
DURING RECORD SETTING HEAT VERY
LOW HUMIDITY AND VERY HIGH WINDS.
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE TWELVE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES IN
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WERE CAUSED BY ELECTRIC POWER
AND DISTRIBUTION LINES.
CONDUCTORS AND POWER POLES.
CALIFORNIA -- CITED TREES ARE
PART OF TREES FALLING ON THE
POWER LINES AS SPECIFIC CLAUSES
OF THESE FIRES.
ADEQUATE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IS CRITICAL TO REDUCING THE RISK
OF TREES AND BRUSH CONTACT THE
ELECTRICAL LINES AND EQUIPMENT.
PART OF CAL FIRES MISSION IS TO
PREVENT FIRES CAL FIRES FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM INCLUDES WILD
LAND.
IN PRE FIRE -- ENGINEERING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FIRE
PLANNING EDUCATION AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUELY SITUATED
DETERMINE WHAT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS NECESSARY TO
REDUCE THE LEVEL WILDFIRE RISKS.
FROM CONTACT WITH ELECTRIC
LIGHTS AND EQUIPMENT. TO ENSURE
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS
SUFFICIENTLY IMPLEMENTED.
UNDER CURRENT LAW INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES MUST PROVIDE THE CPUC
WITH THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PLAN.
AS PART OF THE I. O. U. WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
FURTHER AS PART OF THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN SKEWS ME FURTHER
THE CPC MUST CONSULT WITH CAL
FIRE WHEN REVIEWING AND
APPROVING EACH WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
HAS TO BE AMENDED SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE CAL FIRE TO
AUDIT EACH ELECT SCHOOL
CORPORATIONS VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK. TO ENSURE THAT
THE UILITY HAS SATISFACTORILY
CARRY THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WORK SET FORTH IN ITS WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLAN.
WELL THIS IS MORE WORK FOR CAL
FIRE CAL FIRE WOULD BE
REIMBURSED BY THE UTILITY FOR
ALL ITS COST INCLUDING ANY NEW
RESOURCES NEEDED.
SO IT'S ABILITY TO PERFORMANCE
OTHER DUTIES WILL NOT.
BE IMPAIRED.
FINALLY BECAUSE VEGETATION
MANAGER WORK IS SO IT IS VERY
DANGEROUS SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
ALSO REQUIRES THE BED THAT THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK BE
PERFORMED.
BY QUALIFIED LIKE CLEARANCE TREE
TRIMMERS OR QUALIFIED LYING
CLEARANCE TREE TRIMMER TRAINEES.
RECENTLY JUDGE ALSO OVERSEEING
P. GENIES PROBATION IN THE SAN
BRUNO CASE SAID P. JEANNIE
HASN'T CUT THE RIGHT TREES IN
MANAGING VEGETATION IN AND NEAR
ITS POWER LINES.
IN RESPONSE P. JEANNIE SAID AND
I QUOTE.
THERE'S A LOT OF TREES OUT THERE
AND WE DON'T HAVE HIGHS ON ALL
OF THEM.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I SUBMIT
LET'S GIVE THE ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES EYES THEY NEED TO
ADEQUATELY MANAGE EDUCATION AND
CUT THE RIGHT TREES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY -- ARE
REPRESENTED THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH IN
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK.
SENATOR DODD FOR INTRODUCING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ADDRESSES TO
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS.
THE FIRST PROBLEMS TO CHAIR IS
THAT.
WELL THE THE LAW CURRENTLY AS IT
IS IT STATES IS A VERY
SUBJECTIVE.
AS TO THE EXTENT OF THE TRIMMING
ENTRY CLEARING THAT UTILITY MUST
DO.
IT STATES YOU HAVE TO CLEAR
TWELVE FEET AROUND.
A PIECE OF OF A LINE.
BUT THEN IT GOES ON TO SAY THAT
YOU MUST ALSO CLEAR.
ANY TREE ON ADJACENT PROPERTY.
POTENTIALLY COULD POSE A RISK.
DURING CERTAIN HIGH EVENT
INCIDENTS THAT'S VERY SUBJECTIVE
AND WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
GOING ON TO PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
PROPERTY.
IN CUTTING TREES THAT TO THE
NAKED EYES SEEM TO BE.
WELL OUTSIDE OF THE EASEMENT FOR
THE TRANSMISSION OR DISTRIBUTION
LINE.
COMES VERY DIFFICULT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE HAVING
CAL FIRE COME IN AFTER WE DO.
OUR DUE DILIGENCE AND CLEAR THAT
VEGETATION. TO COME THROUGH AND
SAY YOU CAN DO BETTER JOB HERE.
THAT TREE SEEMS TO BE A PROBLEM
USING THEIR EXPERTISE IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED.
ESPECIALLY THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA.
NOW LET ME STATE THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT I CAN NEVER
REMEMBER COMING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADVOCATING FOR
JOBS TO BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
I. B. W..
AND GIVEN TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
CURRENTLY THE CONTRACTORS THAT
ARE HIRED TO DO THIS POST.
TRIMMING INSPECTION.
DO SO WITH THE WORKERS THAT ARE
MEMBERS OF MY UNION.
WE SIMPLY DON'T THINK THAT THOSE
CONTRACTORS AND THOSE WORKERS.
I HAVE THE TOTAL COMPREHENSIVE
CAPACITY TO DO THE VERY BEST FOR
CALIFORNIANSIF YOU LOOK AT THE
SEVENTEEN FIRES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA OUTSIDE OF THE TUBS
FIRE THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN OF THOSE FIRES.
CAL FIRE DETERMINED THAT THOSE
WERE BECAUSE BECAUSE OF TREES
ADJACENT TO POWER LINES.
THEY WERE NOT CUT.
IN THEIR OPINION TO SUFFICIENT
[inaudible]
SPECIFICATIONS.
AT THIS BILL BUT IN PLACE WE
THINK THAT THAT MANY OF THOSE --
INCIDENTS COULD HAVE AND WOULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED.
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
THE WORK FORCE TO BE REPRESENTED
DO DO DO ALL THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND AND LYING TREE
CLEARING.
IS A PRIMARILY A MIGRANT
WORKFORCE. TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA
OF THE SCOPE OF HOW THIS WORK
FORCES BEEN RAMPED UP.
IN JUST THE LAST YEAR WE'VE GONE
FROM APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
WORKING UNDER.
CONTRACTORS WORKING FOR P.
JEANNIE TO OVER.
THREE THOUSAND WE HAVE
CONTRACTORS LITERALLY DRIVING IN
FROM OTHER STATES.
WOULD TWENTY AND TWENTY FIVE
TRUCKS AND NO EMPLOYEES.
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
THE SHOW UP WITH EMPLOYEES WHO
THEN BECOME OUR MEMBERS.
THEY FIND THEM WHEREVER THEY CAN
FIND THEM HOME DEPOT WHEREVER
THEY CAN.
THE FEAR THAT WE HAVE IS THAT
THE SITUATION HAS BECOME
PARALLEL TO THE SITUATION WITH
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS.
WHERE YOU HAVE?
SUBCONTRACTORS TO SUBCONTRACTORS
TO SUBCONTRACTORS.
AND THIS WORKFORCE IS NOT BEING
TRAINED.
THE LEVEL THE NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS OF SERIOUS ACCIDENTS.
THE SHOCKING.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE MOST
UPDATED NUMBERS FROM CAL OSHA.
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU FOR THE
NUMBERS AVAILABLE FROM OCTOBER
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE TO
SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN SO.
FOR LESS THAN TWO YEARS.
THERE WERE SEVENTY FOUR SERIOUS
ACCIDENTS. FIFTY FOUR RESULTING
IN HOSPITALIZATION.
AND ELEVEN DEATHS.
WE THINK THE NUMBER LEVEL OF
ACCIDENTS IN JUST THE LAST YEAR.
ARE FAR GREATER THAN THOSE
NUMBERS.
AND THESE ACCIDENTS GO
UNREPORTED.
BECAUSE A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THIS WORKFORCE.
EITHER UNDOCUMENTED OR HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED.
WHEN THEY'RE INJURED?
THEY WALK AWAY THEY DON'T REPORT
IT.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS THESE
CONTRACTORS.
NOT THE PRIME SUBCONTRACTORS BUT
TYPICALLY THE SUBCONTRACTORS AND
THIRD TIER SUBCONTRACTORS.
THEY'LL HIRE SOMEBODY OFF THE
STREET TO BE A VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT TECHNICIAN.
WHOSE JOB IS TO CUT BRUSH. TO
CLEAR BRUSH.
BUT WHEN THEY GET HIM BACK INTO
THE WOODS.
THE HAND OF A CHAIN SAW UNTIL
MISTER CUTTING TREES.
WE HAD A POOR FELLOW JUST ABOUT
A MONTH AND A HALF AGO. TO PASS
AWAY BECAUSE HE PULLED A TREE ON
HIMSELF BECAUSE HE NOT BEEN
TRAINED ON HOW TO PROPERLY FALL
A TREE.
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED.
WE PROPOSE IN THIS LEGISLATION.
TO REQUIRE THE UTILITIES. TO
REQUIRE THAT THEIR
SUBCONTRACTORS.
TRAIN AND CERTIFY ALL OF THESE
WORKERS WITH.
AT LEAST MINIMUM SAFETY TRAINING.
BEFORE THEY PUT HIM OUT INTO THE
FIELD AND THAT THE TILITIES
PROVIDE THE FINANCING. FOR THAT
TRAINING.
MY LAST POINT MISTER CHAIR IS
WHY THIS IS A VERY COMBUSTIBLE
SITUATION.
IS BECAUSE THE UTILITIES PAY THE
CONTRACTORS BY THE NUMBER OF
TREES.
THE WORKERS ARE PAID A VERY LOW
VERY LOW HOURLY WAGE THAT IS A
DANGEROUS COM -- COMBINATION
BECAUSE HE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
FOR THAT THIRD TIER
SUBCONTRACTOR HIS DETAILS CREW
CUT DOWN AS MANY TREES AS FAST
AS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT IS EIGHT IS
ANTITHETICAL TO SAFETY.
SO WE URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THE
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HI ORIGINAL COST HERE IN BEHALF
OF COALITION FOR CALIFORNIA
UNTIL THE EMPLOYEES -- COUNCIL
AND HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE THANK YOU.
OTHERS.
THERE'S A MOTION -- ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
YEAH I CAN'T RECOGNIZE YOUR
MOTION CANCER CENTER -- YES SIR
GOOD MORNING JOHN KENNEDY WITH
THE RURAL COUNTIES WE HADN'T
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION -- IT LOOKS LIKE
THE COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS MOST OF
OUR CONCERNS AND THAT YOU'RE
ADOPTING THOSE.
SO WE LOOK FOR TO LOOKING AT THE
BILL AND REEVALUATING OUR
POSITION AS IT MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU.
MISTER CANNON.
YES KAREN MILLS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION WE SUBMITTED AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION --
ON THE BILL I WELL WE CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH SENATOR DODD'S
OFFIE WHICH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE WITH HIS
OFFICE -- WE WERE CONCERNED THAT
THE BILL WAS.
BROADER THAN IT NEEDED TO BE
BASED ON THE CLEAR AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
FARM BUREAU WILL BE ABLE TO
REMOVE IT SO OPPOSITION AND GO
TO A NEUTRAL POSITION AND WILL
BE ABLE TO CONFIRM THAT WHEN
THAT BILL IS IN PRETTY GOOD
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU
APPRECIATE.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OR
REMOVING OPPOSITION [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS YES CENTER
MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ADVANCING
THIS.
FROM.
IN.
THE PARTICIPANTS IN SUPPORT.
A QUESTION AND THE CAL FIRE.
INTO ENGAGEMENT WOULD THAT JUST
BE AN S. STARRING AREAS.
HER CAL FIRE CURRENTLY PROTECTS
FORCED OR WOULD IT GO INTO OTHER
AREAS WHERE.
P. JEANNIE OR THE UTILITIES
MIGHT HAVE THIS RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S POST AUDIT ROLL
IT WOULD COVER ALL AREAS AS
SARIS AND ALLERGIES THANK YOU
AND THEN.
WHAT IS THE CAPACITY OF CAL FIRE
TO TAKE ON?
THIS.
ADDED OBLIGATION.
WHAT [inaudible]
CEREMONY.
A DIALOGUE WITH CAL FIRE BUT THE
WAY THE WAY THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED.
IS THAT THE RATE PAYER DOLLARS
THE TODAY GO TO THE UTILITIES TO
PAY FOR THE SERVICES WOULD BE A
PASS THROUGH TO PAY FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL PIECEWISE THE
CALIFORNIA READ NEED. TO ADDRESS
THIS NEED TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
GOAL.
IN THIS CURRENT SYSTEM OF THE HE
COMPARED IT TO THE FARM LABOR
CONTRACTOR.
WITH THAT.
THAT WOULDN'T BE ABOLISHED YOU
DESCRIBED THERE WOULD BE A
TRAINING REQUIREMENT FOR THOSE
SUBCONTRACTORS SO THERE'D STILL
BE.
THESE RECRUITED SUBCONTRACTORS
WORKING AT LOW HOURLY WAGE.
THE THE THE THE WAGE SCALE WOULD
STILL BE THE UNION SCALE WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY.
IS NOT WHAT WE WOULD LIKE IT TO
BE.
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORY OF THIS PARTICULAR
WORKFORCE BEING ON ORGANIZED.
WHAT WE HOPE IS A BY
INSTITUTIONALIZING THIS TRAINING
PROGRAM WHICH THE UNION WOULD BE
INVOLVED WITH?
THE WILL PROVIDE US WITH A WAY
TO BETTER.
REGULATE AND AND AND WHO IS
BEING HIRED WHO ARE BECOMING OUR
MEMBERS.
SO WE CAN EDUCATE THEM IN THAT
PROCESS AND ALSO MONITOR THEM.
AND THIS MAY BE A LITTLE
TANGENTIAL THAT YOU REFERRED TO
THE INJURIES AND THE DEATHS.
PRESUMABLY THEY'RE EMPLOYED BY
SOMEBODY IN SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION.
ARE SOME OF THESE SUBCONTRACTORS
SO ROGUES THAT THEY'RE NOT
CARRYING WORKERS COMP.
YEAH THAT IS A CONCERN IN FACT
AT THE LAST CONTRACTOR STATE
LICENSING BOARD MEETING IN SAN
DIEGO ABOUT A MONTH AGO.
WITHOUT.
US EVEN BRING IN THIS TO THEIR
ATTENTION.
THEY IT CHEN DIES.
A ITEM WHERE THE LICENSING BOARD
IS GOING TO START IT IS
INSTITUTING A PROCESS TO IT.
TOO DRASTICALLY INCREASE THE
REQUIREMENTS ON VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT CONTRACTORS LICENSEES
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH INCIDENCE OF
NOT JUST INJURIES BUT ALSO THE
LACK OF WORKERS COMPENSATION.
IT MEANS THAT SIR CRIME IN THIS
STATE I THOUGHT IT IS%
[inaudible]
Q..
COM THANK FEDERAL FOR CLOSE TO A
QUORUM.
MANY ONE MORE OKAY THANK YOU IN
THEM ON ME WELL I THINK YOU
ALREADY TRIED TO MOVE IT WILL
ONE OF A SOME OF THEM WHEN WE
GET A QUORUM.
YEAH.
GET INTO YOUR MIND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION THE THE AMENDMENTS
TO WILL INTEGRATE THAT THAT TRIM
LIST INTO THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
THAT THEN WE'LL GO.
BEYOND THOSE S. R. AREAS BUT
THROUGH THOSE UTILITY PLANS AS
IT IS SO THERE'S THERE'S GONNA
BE INTEGRATION IT'S NOT THAT CAL
FIRES GOING TO SORT OF BE ACTING
ON ITS OWN.
DIPPING INTO ALL THESE DIFFERENT
TERRITORIES THAT THE THE AMENDS
WE'RE GONNA BE PASS AND A AND A
GREAT THAT YEAH COURSE -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS -- WE'RE GOING
TO LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
FOR WHEN WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
QUORUM OUR MISTER I'VE JUST TO
CLOSE I DESPERATELY WANT TO
THANK YOU AND AND YOUR STAFF --
FOR YEAH WORKING -- ON THIS BILL
AND OBVIOUSLY TAKING THE
OPPOSITION -- AWAY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE BEEN HELD.
THANK YOU SIR -- DO YOU WANT TO
PRESENT TO US I I THINK IT'S
FILE AND FOR TWO FIFTY THREE YES
SIR.
OKAY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SB TWO
FIFTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO ESTABLISH AND
ADMINISTER AN INCENTIVE BASED
CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE
THE PROGRAM TO OPTIMIZE WILDLIFE
HABITAT BENEFITS WHILE
SUPPORTING THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE BY PROVIDING
INCENTIVES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS.
AGRICULTURE IS A MAJOR INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO VALUABLE OPEN
SPACE AND WILDLIFE HABITAT.
THE MANAGEMENT DECISIONS AND
CONSERVATION PRACTICES OF
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ALSO
ENHANCE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY PROVIDE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND OFFER OTHER
SOCIAL BENEFITS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE DELIVERY OF
ON FARM CONSERVATION PRACTICES
AS THE CLIENT.
THIS DCLINE IS DRIVEN BY THE
RISING COSTS OF AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION INCLUDING WATER AND
ENERGY COSTS.
MORE RESOURCES AND TOOLS ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE A PROVIDE MULTIPLE
CONSERVATION BENEFITS TO ON FARM
PRACTICES.
THE PURPOSE OF INCENTIVE BASED
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS ARE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
AGRICULTURE PRODUCERS WHO WANT
TO VOLUNTARILY MAKE WILDLIFE
FRIENDLY IMPROVEMENTS ON THEIR
LAND.
THE PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
FINANCIAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS TO CREATE FISH AND
WILDLIFE HABITAT IT PROVIDED DID
ADDED ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
SUCH AS IMPROVED WATER QUALITY
EROSION CONTROL.
AND CONSERVE GROUNDWATER.
OPERATION OF THE PROGRAM WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION OF
FUNDS BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE IS SUPPORTED
BY THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WHICH
IS HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ
FORCED BURKE AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR POLICY FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WE ARE
HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL.
TWO FIFTY THREE A CALIFORNIA'S
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED MILLION
ACRES FORTY THREE MILLION ACRES
ARE USED FOR AGRICULTURE AND
HE'S WORKING FARMS AND RANCHES
PRODUCE MUCH OF THE COUNTRY'S
FOOD AND FIBER.
THESE WORKING LANCE ALSO PROVIDE
MUCH OF OUR STATES OPEN SPACE
AND HABITAT THAT WILDLIFE NEEDS.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A NEW PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE AGRICULTURE
PRODUCERS WHO WANT TO
VOLUNTARILY MAKE CONSERVATION
PREVENTS TO THEIR LAND.
WITH THE HELP FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM CREATED AN SP TWO FIFTY
THREE PRODUCERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT ON FARM PRACTICES THAT
LIVER ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
SUCH AS IMPROVED WATER AND AIR
QUALITY CONSERVE GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER.
OR CREATED WILDLIFE HABITAT.
SOME OF THESE HABITAT PROJECTS
COULD INCLUDE WILDLIFE FAMILY
FARMING THAT ALLOWS FOR SAFE
WILDLIFE MOVEMENT.
AND FLOODING RICE FIELDS FOR
MIGRATORY BIRD HABITAT.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD SUPPORT
SCIENCE DRIVEN INVESTMENTS TO
DELIVER BENEFITS THE PUBLIC
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT CAN BE
REDUCED REASONABLY EXPECTED THAT
LANDOWNERS CONFIDE IN THEIR OWN.
CALIFORNIA IS THE COUNTRY'S
LEADING AGRICULTURAL PRODUCER
AND THE STATE SHOULD DO MORE TO
INCENTIVIZE INNOVATIVE
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS THAT WILL
HAVE TANGIBLE BENEFITS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND HELP IMPROVE OUR FARM AND
RANCH LANDS WE ARE AT YOUR
SUPPORT.
THEY HI MY NAME IS KAREN BERMAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS --
THE NINETY SIX OR CITIES IN THE
STATE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO MAKE
AGRICULTURE PART OF THE
CONSERVATION SOLUTION FOR SINCE
THE DUST BOWL.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
CONSERVATION FROM THE PRACTICES
ON FARMS AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY -- MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
WHAT HAGLUND IS ABLE TO PRODUCE.
AND MOST OF US WERE COULDN'T BE
DONE THOUGH WITHOUT OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES CONSERVATION SERVICE.
AND NOT ONLY DO THEY PROVIDE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT FOR THE
PROVIDE A GOOD DEAL OF FUNDING
THAT HELPS TO IMPROVE FARMLAND.
AND DO THINGS A LIKE REDUCE NON
POINT SOURCE POLLUTION POLLUTION.
PROTECT REDUCE SOIL EROSION AND
SEDIMENTATION AND CONSERVING
GROUND WATER AND THEN ALSO
PROVIDING HABITAT FOR AT RISK
SPECIES.
HAVING A STATE ANALOGUES AND RCS
IS THIS BILL.
WOULD CREATE I WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AND TOOLS
FOR THE OUR CITIES AND FOR
OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THESE PRACTICES ON FARMLAND --
IN PARTICULAR WE BE ABLE TO TO
LEVERAGE THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING THAT THEN -- CS PUTS IN
THREE QUICK PROGRAMS AND AND
THROUGH THEIR FUNDING TO BE ABLE
TO FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA'S PACIFIC
PROJECTS THAT ARE DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT THE FEDERAL PRIORITIES ARE.
SO GIVE US A CHANCE TO REALLY
LEVERAGE FUNDING AND AND REALLY
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
BECAUSE OF THIS SO WE THINK
SENATOR DODD FOR LEADING ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
NOLAN AGENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST AN OLD
FIELD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION OFTEN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR. ONE
OF THE MEAT ON A WITH AUDUBON
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MARK FENCER MAKER WITH
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE OF POVERTY AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THERESA BURKE RICH
ON BEHALF OF CERES AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
DENNIS I'LL BE ON A BEHALF OF
THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE A CALIFORNIA
GREEN FEET COVERS HE
DISSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIR.
THING OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK.
SING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DICE COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SENATE CAREER.
THANKS VERY MUCH -- MISTER CHAIR --
SENATOR [inaudible]
EIGHTY AS THE AS SIGMA.
STARTS TO BE IMPLEMENTED -- AT
LEAST PRELIMINARILY IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY
THAT.
BOMB.
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED IN
PARTICULAR IN MY DISTRICT --
WHETHER IT'S A COMMUNITY THAT IS
SURROUNDED BY FARMLAND OR THAT
IS DEPENDENT BECAUSE IT HOLE
ECONOMY IS IS A IS CONNECTED TO
FARMING IT IS THERE THE
POSSIBILITY OF OF OF OF THE YOUR
BILL AND AND HOW YOU STRUCTURED
IT TO BE ABLE TO COME IN WITH
RESOURCES -- TO DETERMINE WHAT
WOULD BE A GOOD TRANSITION FOR
THAT COMMUNITY AND I'M I'M
THINKING IN PARTICULAR -- IN
MUCH OF MY DISTRICT USED THE
WETLANDS AND BUT YOU DON'T JUST
FELLOW LANDING YOU GET WITH THE
HANDS -- AND I'M WONDERING IF
THERE'S IF THERE ARE.
IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY.
IN YOUR BILL TO CREATE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY OR AT LEAST
TO START TO IDENTIFY THE
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE -- GOOD
TO PUT TOWARDS SUSTAINABILITY --
SO WE DON'T END UP WITH DUST
BOWL AREAS AND WE REALLY YOU CAN
LOOK AT ENHANCING THE ECONOMY OF
THE REGION RATHER THAN
DESTROYING IT AND I AM I AM I IT
APPEARS TO ME THAT THAT'S THE
CASE BUT I WANTED TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL AND
AND YOU KNOW THE GIVING THE R.
C. D. THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE.
TO COME AND GIVE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUNITIES. TO
FARMERS -- IT GOES A LONG WAY IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW SAVING WATER
IN MAKING SURE THAT -- THE
PRACTICES ARE SUSTAINABLE FOR
THE FUTURE THAT'S EXCELLENT I
APPRECIATE THAT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS -- LOVE THE
BILL.
IT REALLY GETTING AHEAD OF THIS
AND TAKE A MORE INTEGRATED
APPROACH.
WE'VE GOT A FEW OTHER
INTERESTING CDFA PROGRAMS WHICH
WE KNOW CURRENTLY ON THE BOOKS
BUT I NOTED.
THAT JUST FEEL THE GAS WOULD
HAVE AN INTEGRATED APPROACH
THERE I I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
IT AND I I SECOND.
TO THE CONCERNS FROM CENTER HAVE
A YEAR IN TERMS OF SPECIAL IN A
WAY HERE LIKE THIS TRYING TO GET
AHEAD OF WHAT WILL BE EVENTUALLY
A DROUGHT AGAIN.
AND LOOKING AT GROUND WATER
RECHARGE BENEFITS -- SOMEBODY TO
THE CONSERVATION MEMBERS IS A
VERY EXCITING COALITION SAT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I DON'T
KNOW WHEN IT'LL BE BUT I'D LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON AND I DIDN'T WANT
TO GET A SENSE THOUGH JUST WELL
WE HAD A QUICK SECOND FROM IS
FORSBERG.
NATURAL COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION PLANS
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANS.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU PICTURE
THIS INTEGRATING IN SORT OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS DO YOU SEE
THOSE BEING?
RELATED YEAH ABSOLUTELY THIS IS
A OUR GOAL TO PROVIDE MORE TOOLS
TO OUR LAND AND SO I CAN LAND
AND RANCH PRODUCERS TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE HABITAT ON BAG LAND.
AND SO BUT BY PROVIDING
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AND MORE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS WE CAN REALLY
INCORPORATING COORDINATE WITH
EXISTING PLANNING PROCESS IS OUT
THERE.
I I WOULD JUST LOVE TO SEE AS WE
GO FORWARD A NOD TO SORT OF
TRYING.
TO MAKE THOSE H. C. P.'S OF THE
NCC PEAS REALLY WORK AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE SORT OF REPAIRING
THE INCENTIVES WITH.
THE EITHER ESA COMPLIANCE OR
CIGNA COMPLIANCE RIGHT TO REALLY
MAKE THIS SOMETHING THAT. TO
MAKE OUR REGULATION SIDE WORKS
AT THANKS FOR THAT ALL NOT
BELABOR THIS FURTHER ACTUALLY
VIEWED HOLD ON WE ACTUALLY OF A
QUORUM NOW -- WAIT WE LOSE ONE
NO.
NOW WE WERE GOOD -- SO PARTNERS
FOR SECOND WOULD YOU MIND CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR STERN HERE
STERN HERE JONES ALAN.
BURGESS BURGESS PRESIDENT
CABALLERO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO HERE JACKSON MONEY MONNING
HERE.
OKAY FORMS ESTABLISHED WITH THAT.
PLAYED A CLOSE ONCE AGAIN I LIKE
THANK YOU STAFF FOR THE GREAT
WORK AND HELP ON ON THIS BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
VERY GOOD -- MOTIONS CENTER
BOARD USE -- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTERS STERN AYE AYES
STERN HI JONES.
ALLEN BUSH'S.
BUSH'S SIDE CABALLERO.
WE ARE AYE HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONNING.
MONEY AND I WE WILL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL THAT AS FIVE
VOTES AT THE CENTER DOT.
I YES YES SO NOW WE'VE GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR MINING ON SB.
TWO FORTY SEVEN THIS WAS
PRESENTED JUST A MOMENT AGO
CENTER HUESO -- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTERS STERN STERN AYE
JONES ALLEN FORGES.
PORTICI CUP EURO CAREER AYE
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY.
NINE WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE
CALL THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN NUMBERS LOOK AT
THEIR GALGIANI.
STEP RIGHT UP.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AS WILD FIRES HAVE BECOME LARGER
AND MORE FREQUENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE EFFORTS TO NOTIFY AND
ALERT THE PUBLIC IN A TIMELY
MANNER HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT.
SB ONE THIRTY ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY DIRECTING CAL FIRE TO
CREATE A PERMANENT GRANT PROGRAM
TO INSTALL AND IMPLEMENT AN
EMERGENCY FIRE SIREN WARNING
SYSTEM. FOR CITIES THAT ARE
DEEMED BY CAL FIRE TO BE IN VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY SOUNDS.
THESE INSTALLATIONS COULD
INCLUDE A VOICE WARNING SYSTEM
SUPPORTED BY LOCATION BASED
MESSAGING.
THAT ENABLES THE BROADCAST OF
SPECIFIC INFORMATION REGARDING
EVACUATION.
THE SPEED EVERYTHING CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES IS FORCING US TOWARDS
A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH TO
NOTIFY PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY.
THIS BILL ADDS ANOTHER LAYER OF
PROTECTION TO IMPROVE CURRENT
ALERT SSTEMS BY FINDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FIRE WARNING
SYSTEM WHERE OTHER TECHNOLOGY
MIGHT FAIL.
THE COST PER SYSTEM WOULD BE IN
THE RANGE OF TEN TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SIREN.
SIRENS CAN USUALLY BE HEARD FOR
ONE MILE IN EACH DIRECTION AND
CAN EASILY BE INCORPORATED INTO
OUR EXISTING WARNING SYSTEMS
WITH ME TODAY IS CHRIS WALLER
FROM L. BRAD CORPORATION TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
REGARDING SPEAKERS AND SIREN
IMPLEMENTATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS CHRIS
ROLLER ON THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
L. READ CORPORATION WE ARE --
SAN DIEGO.
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANY -- IN
RESPONSE -- TO THAT WE SUPPORT
THE BILL -- SB -- ONE THIRTY IN
RESPONSE TO THE OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND ATTACK ON THE USS COLE
WE DEVELOP A LONG RANGE ACOUSTIC
DEVICE.
AND ESTABLISH THE ACOUSTIC
HAILING DEVICE INDUSTRY SELLING
SOLUTIONS FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND
COMMERCIAL MARKETS -- WE'VE BEEN
IN BUSINESS FOR THIRTY NINE
YEARS.
IN OUR SYSTEMS WITH OUR SOFTWARE
HAS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY MASS
CERTIFICATION HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED
AND OVER SEVENTY TWO COUNTRIES.
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD -- L. READ
CORPORATION CREATES A CRYSTAL
CLEAR SPEAKER TECHNOLOGY.
THAT CAN ALLOW A PERSON TO
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND A MESSAGE AT
EXTREMELY FAR DISTANCES SUCH AS
A MILE RADIUS -- IN ADDITION TO
THIS THE SPEAKER TECHNOLOGY IS
AN IP BASED SOLUTION THAT CAN
LAYER APPROACH WITH THE CELL
PHONE CALL OUT.
AND ALSO -- SEISMIC DETECTION
FLOOD ALERT -- WARNINGS -- SO
THAT YOU CAN CAN FIND THE WHOLE
SOLUTION TOGETHER.
SO IF YOU IMAGINE NUMBER TO SEE
MANAGER BEING ABLE TO CREATE ON
THE FLY FROM HIS HOME.
USING A HAND PHONE OR COMPUTER
THEY CAN BASICALLY CREATE A POLY
GONE ALL THAT IT OF THE SPECIFIC
AREA AND PROVIDED NOTIFICATION
TO A SPEAKER OR TO A CELL PHONE.
AND BE ABLE TO CALL THAT SAYING
THAT THERE'S A FIRE IN THE SOUTH
THAT YOU WANT TO EVACUATE TO THE
NORTH AND YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE.
CRYSTAL CLEAR MESSAGES THROUGH
THIS SOLUTION THROUGHOUT IN A
VENT -- L. REDS -- FROM THE
LESSONS LEARNED WE FOUND OUT
THAT -- L. READ SOLUTION CAN BE
A SATELLITE COMMUNICATION A
SOLAR POWER -- SOLUTION AND IT'S
A CLOUD BASED SOFTWARE SO IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO RELY ON THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IF THAT
WERE TO FAIL BY BY FIRES.
THE READ ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY.
IS AVAILABLE FOR CALIFORNIANS
TODAY AND WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH FEMALE WHO FULLY SUPPORT
OUR SOLUTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE --
FOR THE HI TOURISM AREA WHERE
THEY'VE INSTALLED OUR SPEAKERS
AND THEY HAVE A MULTI LET LEVEL
APPROACH WHERE THEY CAN CALL OUT
WITH CELL PHONES.
AND YOU SPEAKERS TO COMMUNICATE
TO THE PUBLIC.
EMERGENCY MANAGERS ARE LOOKING
FOR THIS TYPE SO SOLUTIONS --
MENLO PARK TRYING TO TIE INTO
THE SIZE MAKE -- THE BILL VALLEY
IN MARIN COUNTY TRYING.
TO REPLACE SOME OF THE OUTDATED
SPEAKER FIRE SIRENS THAT THEY
HAD WITH SOLUTIONS LIKE OURS.
SINCE THE MANAGERS WANT THE
SOLUTIONS THEY WANT TO HAVE A
MULTI LAYERED APPROACH BUT
FUNDING IS ALWAYS AN ISSUE.
SO SUPPORTING THE SP ONE THIRTY
IS A GOOD FIRST STEP TOWARDS
SOLVING THIS ISSUE.
CREATED THANK THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NOT YOUR MOM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MA'AM.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS BRING IT
BACK CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR ADVANCING THIS BUT I DO HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS -- HELLO DO
CITIES GET PRIORITIZED.
FOR BEING ELIGIBLE FOR THIS.
TIME WERE ASKING THAT CAL FIRE
COME UP WITH THE GRANT PROGRAM
AND WHEN WE WOULD DEFER TO HOW
THEY MAKE THE DETERMINATION BUT
THEY WOULD HAVE TO THE CITIES
WOULD HAVE TO BE WITHIN.
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES
PRESUMABLY THERE ARE A LOT OF
CITIES IN OUR STATE.
THE MEET THAT THRESHOLD OF BEING
IN A HI FIRESTONE -- ONE OF OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS IS REVERSE.
NINE ONE ONE THERE'S BEEN SOME
CHALLENGES IMPLEMENTING THAT --
IMPLEMENTING THAT WITH PEOPLE
WITH CELL PHONES I COULD SEE HOW
THIS MIGHT PLUG THAT GAP.
BUT TEN MILLION SOUNDS LIKE A
LOT OF MONEY BUT YOU SPREAD IT
AMONG [inaudible] HUNDRED CITIES.
MORE. FIVE HUNDRED CITIES
POTENTIALLY AT RISK YES I KNOW
THIS ISN'T THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE THE THINKING IN
THE MATH OF HOW THIS.
WOULD GET DEPLOYED YES --
SENATOR THIS THIS WAS AN IDEA
THAT I HAD THAT I HAVE BROUGHT
FORWARD AND I AM NOT -- ADAMANT
ABOUT EXACTLY HOW THAT SHOULD
WORK IN EXACTLY -- HOW MUCH
SHOULD BE GIVEN TO EACH CITY I'M
HOPING RATHER THAT THEY THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WILL HELP US?
HONE IN ON SOME OF THOSE DETAILS
AND CERTAINLY CAL FIRE HAS THE
EXPERTISE AND THEY HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE AND AND WHERE WITH ALL
TO MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON WHICH
WHICH CITIES.
THIS COULD WORK BASS STAND AND
WHICH CITIES ARE LACKING AND AND
SOME OF THE DIFFERENT TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY.
SO AGAIN I'M HELPING.
TO FLESH THIS OUT AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE PROCESS
ANY ANY SUGGESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE CERTAINLY I
WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT BECAUSE
AGAIN IT'S AUTHOR SPONSOR AGAIN
THANK YOU.
NINE I WOULD THINK THAT.
CAL FIRE IN.
MUNICIPAL FIRE -- DISTRICT FIRE
UNITS AS WELL MAY HAVE AN
INTEREST SO.
YOUR WITNESS SOME.
IS APPARENTLY WOULD BE ONE OF
THE VENDORS ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMPANIES OR IS THIS A SINGLE
VENDOR BILL THERE ARE SEVERAL
COMPANIES -- THAT PROVIDE THIS
TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY.
THERE ARE SOME WHERE THEY'RE
STRICTLY SIRENS THERE OTHERS
WHERE THE VOICE MESSAGING CAN BE
INCORPORATED -- WE PUT THE BILL
OUT THERE AND AND ONCE IT WAS
PUT INTO PRINT -- MISS THE ROD
CORPORATION CAME FORWARD AND
OFFERED TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BETTER THEIR COMPANY
IS ONE OF SEVERAL COMPANIES.
THAT PROVIDE. FOR THE SIREN
TECHNOLOGY SIN JUST AS IT MOVES
FORWARD I WOULD EXPECT THAT IT.
IT WOULD BE.
OPEN TO SOME FORM OF OPEN
BIDDING.
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY AND ONCE
AGAIN WE'RE DEFERRING TO CAL
FIRE TO COME UP WITH THE CAMP
GRANT PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THERE WERE JUST.
THANK YOU I THINK -- MEMBER DODD --
TO MEET MONNING -- HAD TO HONE
IN ON MY QUESTION TO TO YOU THAT
THIS IS GOING TO GO THROUGH A
NATURAL PROCESS -- FOR IN OPEN
BIDDING -- SITUATION.
AND AGAIN NOT NARROWLY TAILORED
TO USE SPECIFICALLY SATISFIED.
ONE COMPANY.
ABSOLUTELY NOT ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT WAS VERY GENERIC ONLY STARTED
WITH THIS -- WITH SIMPLY FIRE
SIRENS AND WHAT I'VE LEARNED AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS IS
THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT.
CAN BE INCORPORATED WITH THE
FIRE SIRENS BUT AGAIN.
MY BILL PROPOSES TO LEAVE THE
DETAILS TO TO CAL FIRE AND LESS
THROUGH THIS PROCESS -- WE
DETERMINE THAT WE SHOULD BE MORE
SPECIFIC WELL I I THOROUGHLY
SUPPORT YOUR AMENDMENT TO LIMIT
THIS TO STANISLAUS MADERA AND
FRESNO COUNTIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GET OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANKS FOR BEING BRING IN IS FOR
I'M A LITTLE BIASED BECAUSE I'M
A CO AUTHOR AND SOCIETY -- DON'T
OFTEN DO THAT WITH BILLS COMING
FOR HIS COMMITTEE BUT WE JUST
WENT THROUGH.
HELL -- DOWN AND WE'LL SEE AND
LOT OF PEOPLE MISS THE SIGNAL --
SO ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE CELL
PHONE GAPS OR CELL PHONE
EQUIPMENT GOES DOWN WAS
APPRECIATED TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALITY THIS AND WITH THE
AMENDMENT JUST.
FY I MEMBERS THIS ALSO IS IT
AGAIN NOT LIMóN STRICTLY THE
SIRENS IT'S ALSO OTHER VOICE
WARNING SYSTEMS LOCATION BASED
MESSAGING ETCETERA SO -- I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A CLOSE AND EMOTION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME -- THANK
YOU FOR ENTERTAINING.
QUESTIONS AND I AGAIN WOULD BE
OPEN TO ANY SUGGESTIONS EVEN
LATER ON IN THE PROCESS IS WE
ALL.
BECOME MORE LEARNED ABOUT THIS
TOPIC SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS.
LOS FOR CENTER BOARD IS IS DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE NEWS STERN
STERN AYE JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES BARGES AYE
CABALLERO CAREER -- I HERTZBERG
HUESO.
SO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
I MEAN I THAT HAS SUFFICIENT
VOTES.
SO WE WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON
CALL.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT.
COMING UP.
ON DECK SENATOR MOORE Là
[inaudible]
FROM DOWN [inaudible]
UNDER.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR HOW
ARE YOU.
IT IS A WELL SIR IT IS GOING TO
BE A FUN DAY IT SURE IS. FOR
MOVING RIGHT ALONG.
MISTER CHAIR IN HER TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL -- FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
FIRST OF ALL WHEN I THINK -- YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK YOU'RE DOING ON TRYING
TO REDUCE.
FUTURE WILD FIRES -- NOPE YOU
HAVE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND
WE'VE GOT CERTAINLY THE LA TIMES
CAME OUT WITH A PRETTY
INTERESTING -- FIRE MAPPER --
THIS IS THE REGISTERS DAILY
TIMES CAME OUT TO GET INTO THIS
JUST CAME OUT THE OTHER DAY BUT
SOME OF THESE AREAS AND OUR OUR
ERROR ARE PART OF THE STATE THAT
ARE.
SUBJECT TO WILDFIRE -- IN SO -
WE HAVE THEM COULD BEING CAUSED
BY SPARKING ELECTRIC LINES.
SO COLLEAGUES WITH THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES ALREADY HAVING
SPECIAL FUNDS FOR ADDRESSING
OVERHEAD POWER LINES FOR
PURPOSES OF BUTTE BEAUTIFICATION.
KNOWN AS RULE TWENTY A OR B. AND
C..
THE GOAL OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
FORCED TO BETTER UTILIZE THESE
FUNDS FOR THE AREAS WITH THE
HIGHEST FIRE RISK TIER. THREE TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS ON PEOPLE
AND PROPERTY FROM UTILITY
ASSOCIATED WILDFIRES.
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
PROVIDE FOR MATCHING FUND
OPPORTUNITIES ALLOWING THE I. O.
USED TO PARTNER WITH WILLING
COMMUNITIES FOR CONVERSION
PROGRAM TO UNDERGROUND CERTAIN
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
FUNDING WOULD ALSO BE MADE
AVAILABLE FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND THE G. G. R.
F..
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES A
PROFESSIONAL FRAMEWORK.
OF COOPERATION BETWEEN A CLIENT
TO COMMUNITY AND AN ELECTRIC
UTILITY PROVIDER IT PROVIDES
ACCESS TO EXISTING TOOLS AND
REVENUES FOR A WIN WIN
OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE UTILITIES WHO LEARNED
HARD LESSONS TWO DECADES AGO
THEY HAVE BEEN HARDENING ASSETS
METHODICALLY OVER THE PAST
TWENTY PLUS YEARS AND SB FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR CONTINUES THIS
EFFORT WITH A METHOD TO EXPEDITE
SMART TRANSMISSION OF POWER.
IN THE SAFEST COLLABORATIVE
MANNER AND I HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANKS A LOT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S COREY
WILLIAMS ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
SPONSORED THE CITY OF LAGUNA
BEACH.
THE CITY OF LAGUNA BEACH IS A
SMALL COMMUNITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH ABOUT TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND RESIDENTS WE ARE
SURROUNDED BY OCEANS HELL'S
CANYON SENT OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF WILD SPACE.
ARE ALMOST NINE SQUARE MILES
pTOURISTS A YEAR.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN A
CHASING COMMUNITIES THAT BORDER
OUR OPEN SPACE APPROXIMATELY 85%
OF THE CITY IS LOCATED IN A VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE.
WITH APPROXIMATELY 55% WITHIN
THE TIER THREE SOUND.
THE RESIDENTS AND TOURISTS
ACCESS THE CITY THROUGH TO STATE
HIGHWAYS PACIFIC COAST HIGHWAY
IN STATE ROUTE.
ONE THIRTY THREE BETTER KNOWN AS
LAGUNA CANYON ROAD.
THESE ARE THE ONLY TWO WAYS IN
OR OUT OF THE CITY.
GONNA CANYON ROAD IS A TWO LANE
AT WIND THE ROAD THROUGH TRY
WILDERNESS BORDERED BY ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE UTILITY
POLES.
THESE POLLS ARE CLEAR PUBLIC
SAFETY RISK FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THERE
HAVE BEEN OVER SIXTY VEHICLE
VERSUS POLL ACCIDENTS ON LAGUNA
CANYON ROAD.
SHUTTING DOWN THE ROAD DOZENS OF
TIMES IN SOME CASES FOR DAYS DUE
TO FALLING POWER LINES WHICH
BLOCK OFF ACCESS POINTS IN AND
OUT OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND THE LAST TWELVE YEARS THERE
HAVE BEEN AT LEAST FOUR FIRES IN
THE OPEN SPACE IN THE CITY THAT
HAVE BEEN SPARKED BY JOHN
UTILITY LINES AND POLES.
AS MANY HAVE DONE THE CITY OF
LAGUNA BEACH VISITED PARADISE IN
JANUARY TO SEE WHAT LESSONS WE
CAN LEARN FROM THE DISASTER
THERE AND APPLY THEM TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE LEARNED ABOUT LIKE LAGUNA
PARADISE SUFFERED FROM LIMITED
INGRESS AND EGRESS ROUTES AND
DURING THE CRUCIAL EARLY HOURS
OF THE FIRE A DOCU ATION ROUTES
WERE BLOCKED BY DOWNED.
POLES IN LINES.
AS ONE OF THE CAL FIRE INCIDENT
COMMANDERS TOLD THE CITY.
THE DOWNED POWER POLES WERE HUGE
PROBLEM DURING THE EVACUATION
PROCESS.
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WILL CREATE
A MEANS OF CREATING SAFE
EVACUATION ROUTES AND HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE
SEASON WAS THE DEADLIEST AND
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE SEASON
ON RECORD IN CALIFORNIA WITH A
TOTAL OF EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN FIRES
WHICH BURN THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF
ACREAGE RECORDED IN A FIRE
SEASON.
QUALIFIER HAS DETERMINED THAT AT
LEAST NINETEEN WILD FIRES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WERE CAUSED BY
UTILITY LINES AND EQUIPMENTS.
THE EASY PUSH BACK ON UNDER
GROUNDING IS THAT IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE.
BUT THIS IS A SHORT SIGHTED
ANALYSIS THAT FOCUSES ONLY ON
THE UP FRONT COST WHEN YOU
FACTOR IN THE HUMAN LOSS THE
PROPERTY DAMAGE THE HEALTH
HAZARDS IN COSTS.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE TO
WATER RESOURCES FOREST'S IN OPEN
SPACE THE MOUNTAINS OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE CREATED AND THAT
GREENHOUSE GASES EMITTED FROM
ONE MAJOR WILDFIRE.
OFFSETS AN ENTIRE YEAR OF
SAVINGS FROM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU BEGIN TO REALIZE THE TRUE
COSTS OF UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES.
LOCATING THE HAZARDOUS UTILITY
POLES BELOW GROUND AND TIER
THREE FIRE ZONES WE ARE
INVESTING IN SMART
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT LOOKS TO THE
FUTURE.
THE FINANCIAL TOLL FOR
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS BUSINESSES
AND THE STATE IN THE PAST TO
FIRE SEASONS HAS TOP TEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND INSURED LOSSES EACH
YEAR.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED WITH REDUCE
TAX REVENUES IN ADDED EXPENSES
IN THE STATE HAS HAD TO SHOULDER
THE FIRE FIGHTING COSTS OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO SEE
THESE FIRES UNDERMINE KEY
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
IT'S TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT WILL HOLD
UTILIIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
EXPEDITE UNDERGROUND IN PROJECTS.
ASK IMPACTED JURISDICTIONS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COST OF THESE
PROJECTS AND PROVIDE A FAIR
FUNDING MECHANISM THROUGH THE
STATE TO SUPPORT THESE PROJECTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I DO OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IT SAID OKAY.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION EITHER HERE TODAY.
CORRECT VERY GOOD FOR ME TO HAVE
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MOTIONS.
VARIOUS MOTIONS WE'LL GO WITH
SENATOR FOR JUST AS THE MOTION --
MY OWN CITY ALSO IN SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS FORD
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS WE KNOW
THIS THERE WAS ROADS AND MANY
OTHERS.
THE AMOUNT YOU'VE YOU HAD IN
HERE EVEN THEN OUTSTRIPS THE THE
TOTAL AVAILABLE -- I MEAN WE'RE
JUST GOING TO BE UNDER THE GUN
THIS IS GONNA HAVE TO BE ONE
IMPORTANT PART OF THE SOLUTION
SAID.
IT'S GOING TO BE A HARD ONE TO
SOLVE ALL IN ONE YOU KNOW EVEN
ONE COMMUNITY IT'S TIME THAT I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND BUT CERTAINLY
ENTERED THE YEAH WE HAVE A
MOTION BUT ONE HELP YOU MOVING
THIS FORWARD.
WE GOT TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IS
TWENTY EIGHT BACKLOGSA MESS WE
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO
THANKS FOR THANKS FOR WORKING
WITH US.
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE THE PROPERTY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
VIGOROUS DEBATE [inaudible]
I YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN MEETING NOW
THAT I'M I'M ON ENERGY WITH THE
WORLD FAMOUS CENTER HUESO AS
CHAIR AND AND I'VE BEEN GETTING
A LOT OF VISITS FROM A LOT OF
UTILITIES A LOT OF CITIES.
AND ANAHEIM HAS ITS OWN ELECTRIC
UTILITY AND THEY HAVE FOR THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS BEEN
METHODICALLY SLOWLY BUT STEADILY.
REDUCING AND MOVING THEIR LINES
UNDERGROUND IN 98% OF THEIR WILD
FIRES ON SIX TAKEN IN THE TWO
DECADES BUT THEY'VE.
MADE A A METHODICAL EFFORT ON IT
AND WE KNOW THAT.
A SIMPLE AS DOING THE SAME AND
THE SAN DIEGO AREA JUST
METHODICALLY WORKING AND AND SO
HERE WE HAVE A PARTNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITY I THINK.
IT'S NOT GOING TO FIX IT
OVERNIGHT BUT IF WE CAN JUST
START METHODICALLY WORKING AT
THIS -- OVER TIME WE WILL SAVE
LIVES AND PROPERTY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE --
MOTIONS CENTER BORDERS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTERS STERN STERN AYE JONES
JONES I ALAN.
ALLEN ON A BOARD JUST. FOR JUST
AYE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE AYE HERTZBERG
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON.
EARNING.
MONEY AND I SEVEN IT IS SEVEN
WILL BE THE MEASURE OF CALL
THANK CENTER THANK YOU MISTER.
HE'S NOW WITH THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
SINCE WE HAVE KNOWN NON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WAITING.
WE'LL GO FIRST ON THE LIST.
THEIR MONEY ARE YOU ARE YOU
READY DO YOU WANT OR DO YOU WANT
TO WE CAN DO FOR WE CAN SKIP YOU
AND MOVE TO A OKAY.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT -- SO DO WE
WANT TO DO.
I KNOW ANALYST'S RARING TO GO
BUT CAVALIERS TECHNICALLY FILE
ITEM.
SEVEN SO I'LL -- YOU DIFFERENCE
HERE.
MOVE ON GOOD DEFERRED TO THE
DEFERRAL GOOD DOUBLE THE FOR ALL --
I DID I SKIP FOR JUST.
CENTER BOARD IS HE READY. 21%
FILE ITEM.
FIVE IT WAS CENTER AND YOU OF
COMPLICATIONS WITH THIS OKAY.
I DON'T HAVE A BILL THAT OFFERS
AND JUST WATCH THIS CODE CO
PRESENT.
IT'S A LOT OF DIFFERENCE HERE
TODAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO NOW BE
HEARING FILE ITEM FIVE SP.
FOUR ZERO TWO VEHICLES OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE REFORMATION IN
THE COUNTY OF INYO.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING IT IS A PLEASURE
ESPECIALLY FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE
I'M A SAY -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT -- THIS
BILL TODAY -- SP FOUR ZERO TWO
HE IS A FIVE YEAR EXTENSION TO
IN YOUR COUNTIES ADVENTURE TRAIL
PILOT PROGRAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AB SIX TO
EIGHT ESTABLISH THIS PILOT
PROGRAM.
WHICH ALLOWED INYO COUNTY TO
DESIGNATE SPECIFIC COUNTY ROADS
AS COMBINED USE ROUTES FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE USE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
DUE TO PROGRAM DELAYS BECAUSE OF
SIGNIFICANT COURT -- ACTION
THERE'S NOT BEEN ENOUGH TIME FOR
A COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION OF
THE PILOT PROGRAM.
THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM OF THE
GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM ARE TO
INCREASE TRAFFIC SAFETY.
OF NATURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION.
REDUCE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
TRESPASS ON PRIVATE LAND.
AND MINIMIZE IMPACTS ON COUNTY
RESIDENTS.
NEITHER THIS BILL NOR THE
EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM CREATE A
SINGLE NEW TRAIL OR ROAD.
IT DOES HOWEVER CREATE A BETTER
NETWORK OF TRAILS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY A LEGAL MEANS.
A LEGAL AND REGULATED MEANS TO
ACCESS EXISTING MAINTAIN TRAILS.
THIS PROGRAM PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PROTECTING TRAILS AND
LANDS FROM TRUCKS AND TRAILERS.
UNLOADING IN STAGING ATV
VEHICLES BECAUSE NOW PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE TRAILS FROM
EXISTING PARKING LOTS CLOSER TO
TOWN.
ADDITIONALLY BY HAVING THE LINKS
TRAIL SYSTEM LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
THE TOOLS TO PROPERLY DIRECT --
HV USERS TO APPROVED ROUTES AND
REDUCE THE NEED TO PULL POLICE
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THIS PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT TO THE
LOCAL ECONOMY INYO COUNTY WHICH
CONSISTS PRIMARILY OF HIGH
DESERT WITH LESS THAN 2%
PRIVATELY OWNED LAND.
HAS A ROBUST ATV -- H. B.
COMMUNITY AND RELIES EXTENSIVELY%
ON TOURISM DOLLARS.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN INYO
RECENTLY VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS EXTENSION.
THIS -- THIS BILL WAS PUT
FORWARD IN TRANSPORTATION WHERE
IT WAS -- SUCCESSFULLY PASSED IN
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR BY
VOTE ON S. B..
FOUR ZERO TWO MEMBERS I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO INTRODUCE -- INYO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR MATT KINGSLEY
WHO'S HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME.
THANK YOU SENATOR VOYAGES -- I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWO WHICH IS AN EXTENSION
OF THE PILOT PROJECT -- CALLED --
ADVENTURE TRAILS A COUPLE POINTS
I'D LIKE TO MAKE -- THE EIGHTY
THE ADVENTURE PROGRAM HAS BROAD
PUBLIC SUPPORT THE PUBLIC HAS
BEEN IN FACT PUBLIC INPUT HAS
BEEN THE HALLMARK OF THE OF THIS
PROGRAM SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WE'VE HAD
TEN FORMAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC TO GIVE TESTIMONY AND
INTERACT WITH OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS WELL AS OUR
PLANNING COMMISSION.
BUT HAD NO COMPLAINTS THERE'S NO
TRAIL CORPORATION NO ACCIDENTS
NO LAW ENFORCEMENT INCIDENTS
NONE OF THE PREDICTED OUTCOMES --
DESCRIBED BY OPPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM HAS TAKEN PLACE REPORTS
OF VIOLATIONS AVOID BY ONLY TWO
USERS LIKE MANY COMMUNITIES.
PRIMARILY OUR OWN USE -- DRIVING
ON THE STREET CUTTING THROUGH
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY KNOW BETTER
OR NOT OBEYING LAWS BUT
UNRELATED TO THE ADVENTURE TALES
PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS -- TO USERS
USE EXISTING MAINTAINED.
ROADS TO ACCESS CAMPGROUNDS
POETRY TRAILS OR SERVICES TO
PROTECT OUR NATURAL RESOURCES BY
EDUCATING.
AND ENCOURAGING -- IT'S V. USERS
TO RESPECT OUR DISTINCTIVE
LANDSCAPE.
BY UTILIZING EXISTING ROADS
TRAIL PERFORATION AND ROSEN IS
IS REDUCED.
AND WE ENCOURAGE OUR LOCAL WHICH
WE USE IS -- TO PARTICIPATE IN
SEARCH OF PROJECTS.
PLANNING AN EMPTY IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE EIGHTY PROGRAM HAD BEEN
SOLELY FUNDED.
BY GREEN STICKER MONEY -- NO
CURRENT NO GENERAL FUND MONEY
HAS BEEN USED.
IN FACT THE COUNTY IS ABLE TO
ACTUALLY -- SAVE MONEY BY USING
THIS PROGRAM.
THE SMALL SCALE OF THE PROJECTS
SEVEN ROUTES HAS LIMITED THE
ECONOMIC -- BENEFIT BUT WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE AN INCREASE IN
USE -- PARTICULARLY IN ONE CAMP
GROUND IT'S NEW -- BISHOP
CALIFORNIA.
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO SAY -- A
PRIORITY FOR THIS PROGRAM HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO INFORM ENGAGE THE
PUBLIC IN THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS EFFORT USE ENJOYMENT
OF THE DENTURE TRAILS PROGRAM.
MORE TIME IS NEEDED -- TO BOTH
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND EVALUATE
THE PROGRAM.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AS
BEFORE -- TO TO CONTINUE THE
ADVENTURE TRAILS PILOT PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THANKS TO RESIDENT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION THE PROGRAM THE
HIS THANK YOU. TO APPRECIATE
THAT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DAM WITH RURAL COUNTIES
ON BEHALF OF FROM OUR SEE OUR
OURS SEE -- INYO COUNTY IS ONE
OF OUR MEMBER COUNTIES AND WE'RE
PLACES TO SUPPORT ONE OF OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO TRY TO FIND THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN.
NATURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION AND
ARE ENCOURAGING TOURISM WHICH IS
ONE OF THE ECONOMIC LIFEBLOOD
SAID THERE COUNTY SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION THANK YEAH
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
HI AMY GRANT IN A BEHALF TO THE
OFF ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THE BALANCE IF
THEY'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
I'M GOING SECONDS SO.
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL DO --
TO TWO MINUTES EACH -- AND THEN
OTHERS WHO WANT TO JUST ADD
THEIR THEIR NAME IN SUPPORT
THAT'LL BE FINE.
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY IN
OPPOSITION YES GOD GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JONATHAN I'M A THIRTY
FIVE YEAR RESIDENT OF BISHOP
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY RETIRED FROM
IT. TWENTY FIVE YEAR CAREER WITH
THE FOR SERVICE HAVE BEEN
WORKING FIRE MANAGEMENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFERED VEHICLE
MANAGEMENT AND VISITOR SERVICES.
MY WIFE AND I LIVE IN BISHOP
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT AFFORDS US
CLEAN AIR LITTLE CRIME AND A
DRAMATIC SCENERY -- IT'S TRULY A
PARADISE IS REAR FREQUENTLY
REMINDED OF I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON EXTENDING THE TRIAL PERIOD
FOR THE ADVENTURE TRAILS PROGRAM.
BUT WITH THE STATE LEGISLATURE
ENCOURAGE AN ALTERNATIVE THAT
EMPHASIZES INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE FUEL USE POLLUTION AND
DEBT THE LAND DEGRADATION.
ALL THE SAME TIME PURSUING A
POLICY.
THE REDUCES OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
THE VENTURE CHILLS PROGRAM IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARDS TURNING
INYO COUNTY INTO A DESTINATION
MECCA -- FOR EACH VISA SPECIALLY
MOTORCYCLES IN THEORY THE
ADVENTURE TROLLS PROGRAM DOES
HAVE MERITS BUT IN REALITY
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH.
ALL THE ADVENTURE PROGRAM -- THE
ADVENTURE TRAILS PROGRAM TELLS
WRITING INTO TOWNS FOR AMENITIES
WHAT IT DOES IN REALITY IS TO
MAKE IT CONVENIENT FOR WRITERS
TO GO WHEREVER THEY WANT.
CAUGHT TRESPASS IF YOU WANT.
THE VENTURE TRAILS PROGRAM IS A
TROJAN HORSE AND REPRESENTS THE
FIRST STEP IN A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
IF SB FOUR TWO WAS PASSED IN A
PERMANENT ROAD IS ESTABLISHED ON
COUNTY AND STATE ROADS.
AS STATED BY A PROPONENTS WOULD
BE JUST THE FIRST STEP TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL ROUTES WITH THE
STATED GOAL OF MAKING INYO
COUNTY A DESIGNATED -- EACH BE
PLAYGROUND.
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BEFORE -- TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU SIR.
I THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THIS
BEFORE -- TO MY NAME IS MARGARET
MARSHALL AND I'M A RETIRED CAL
FIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
DEALING WITH A FIRE PREVENTION
ISSUES THAT REALLY.
MAKES ME FEEL WONDERFUL.
IN YOUR COUNTY IS A SPECIAL
PRAYER PLACE AND ARE RECREATION
ECONOMY THRIVES.
BECAUSE OF THE BEAUTIFUL
MOUNTAIN AND DESERT PANORAMA AS
CLEAN AIR AND YOU NEED.
HIKING BACKPACKING FISHING IN
ROCK CLIMBING AND PHOTOGRAPHY
BRING TOURISTS FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
NOT ONE OF THOSE FORMS OF
RECREATION HAS REQUIRED A CHANGE
THE CALIFORNIA LAW.
SB FOUR OH TWO CHANGES THE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE.
AND IT MAKES IT EASIER FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES TO TRAVEL
BETWEEN SELECTED BUSINESSES.
AND THE PUBLIC LANDS.
I'M JUST HERE TO MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT
OVERWHELMINGLY POPULAR IN THE
COUNTY.
WE A LOT OF US ARE WONDERING WHY
YOU WOULD SUPPORT.
A CODE CHANGE THAT FAVORS ONE
FORM OF RECREATION OVER THE
OTHERS.
WERE WONDERING WHY WE WOULD VOTE
FOR A CODE CHANGE.
THAT ENCOURAGES A FORM OF
RECREATION THAT POLLUTES THE AIR
WITH NOISE AND DICED IN
GREENHOUSE GASES.
AND WE'RE WONDERING WHY YOU
WOULD VOTE FOR A CODE CHANGE.
THAT MAKES IT EASIER -- FOR
HGTV'S TO ACCESS TO PUBLIC LANDS
WHEN THOSE VEHICLES HAVE ALREADY
DONE SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE TO SITES
IN DEATH VALLEY NATIONAL PARK.
AND TO THE TRAILS AROUND MY HOME.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THE PROTECTION OF NATURAL
RESOURCES IN INYO COUNTY MAY BE
VERY RURAL AND VERY RED.
BUT IT'S STILL PART OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I HOPE YOU'LL KEEP THAT IN
MIND WHEN YOU CAST YOUR VOTE --
SO PLEASE VOTE NO ONE'S FOR A
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION.
DONALD REPRESENTING INYO THREE
FIFTY OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BRIAN A WIKI WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO ME ONE SENTENCE OR
ONE THAT IS -- THAT THE COUNTY
OF INYO HAS PROVIDED A REPORT
AND ON THE ON THE PILOT PROJECTS
OF FIRE IN THAT REPORT DID NOT
INCLUDE.
ANY JUSTIFICATION -- BASIS FOR
EXTENDING OUR EXPANDING THIS
PROGRAM WITH ONLY SEVEN OF THOSE
TRAILS OPENS UP MYSELF THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU.
BRENNAN DAWSON OF THE OFFICE
HERE CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS MISTER VICE CHAIR.
MR BORDERS WOULD YOU COULD YOU --
I'LL JUST LEAVE THAT TO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE THANK YOU COMMENTS.
OF THE WITNESSES AND YOU KNOW
JUST TO KIND OF PREFACE THIS --
I CARED A SIMILAR BILL.
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY --
ALLOWING ATVS ACCESS -- TO
PUBLIC ROADS SIMILAR TO THE
ENTIRE STATE OF ARIZONA -- YOU
KNOW THE THE THAT'S A STABLE
IT'S A STATEWIDE LAW FOR THEM
AND I THINK SEVERAL OTHER --
STATES COLORADO UTAH.
THAT SOME OF THEIR MOUNTAIN
TOWNS.
RELY ON THIS TYPE OF TOURISM FOR
THEIR ECONOMY -- BUT I WANT TO A
GIVEN OPTION A TO RESPOND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS WE
HAVE AN ON FOR FILLED.
PILOT PROGRAM.
IN THE REASON IT'S BEEN ON FOR
FILLED IS BECAUSE THERE WAS
LITIGATION AND COURT RELATED
ACTION.
THAT CHALLENGE THIS.
DIRECTLY.
AND SO WHEN WE HEAR FROM -- FROM
FOLKS WHO HAVE STRONG OPINIONS
ON THIS -- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE PART
OF THE EFFORTS TO NOT HAVE IT
PASSED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
I'M A I'M STRONGLY OF THE
OPINION THAT IF WE CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM.
IT NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT TO
FRUITION WHAT'S THE POINT OF
STARTING SOMETHING.
IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE -- TO IT
YIELDS RESULTS IN LEARN FROM
THEM.
SO WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A IN A
NEED FOR AN EXTENSION BROUGHT
ABOUT BY DELAYS BY THE VERY
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM EARLIER.
NOW LET'S NOT CONFUSE SOME OF
THE ISSUES -- WITH SOME OF THE
SENSATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
DISCUSSIONS THAT OCCUR ELSEWHERE
IN THE STATE IN AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL. THIRTY NINE OF THE FORTY
FOUR ROADS ARE PAVED.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF THIS IS TO
MAKE CERTAIN.
THAT INDIVIDUALS DO NOT DEGRADE
THE ENVIRONMENT BY GOING OFF
ROAD.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THESE DUAL
USE -- OPPORTUNITIES SO IF IF
INDIVIDUALS ARE PROPONENTS OF
THE ENVIRONMENT IT WHICH IS
BAFFLED THE IMAGINATION AT THE
HELLO THIS IS NOT ACTUALLY.
IMPROVING THE ENVIRONMENT -- AND
I THINK.
THE I'D PROBABLY LEAVE OPEN IN
THE COMMENTS FURTHER WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM -- FROM THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS BUT THE LAST TIME
WE WERE HERE BOB BEFORE THE
TRANSPORTATION -- I COMMITTEE --
THE SHERIFF FOR MENU COUNTY WHO
EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS.
LOOKED UPON IT FROM A PUBLIC
SAFETY STANDPOINT -- IN ADDITION
TO FIRE SAFETY -- IN I THINK
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUALS
IN THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT THAT
WANT TO DO SOMETHING RESPONSIBLY
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE -- THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO TO TO BRING THIS
PILOT PROGRAM TO FRUITION
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU CENTER.
IN A SUPERVISOR WOULD YOU MIND
COMMENTING ON ON THE THE THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE THE THE PLAN
THOUGH THE AT YOUR VALUATION
REPORT.
BECAUSE NOT NOT.
SO WE WERE REQUIRED -- TO IN
AGREED IN THE LEGISLATION TO DO
AN EVALUATION REPORT NEAR THE
END OF THE ONE YEAR LEFT ON THE
PILOT PROJECT OUR VALUATION
REPORT BASICALLY JUST -- LAYS
OUT THAT WE HAVE NOT HAD THE
ISSUES BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAVELER INFORMATION ALL OF
THOSE THINGS AND THEN --
SEPARATE FROM THAT OUR BOARD
VOTED TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION -- THE THE
EVALUATION REPORT.
WHICH WE DIDN'T TRY TO GO INTO --
EXTENSION NECESSARILY WE IT WAS
REQUIRED THAT WE GIVE THE
INFORMATION ON WHAT HAD HAPPENED
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID
UNDERSTOOD AND I KNOW IN IN THE
ANALYSIS THERE'D BEEN.
I GUESS IN.
THE MOST RECENT REPORT BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE SAID THAT THERE
WERE THIRTY EIGHT SEPARATE
APPLICATIONS TO THE COUNTY.
TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM GIVE US A
STATUS UPDATE ON THERE THAT
THAT'S NOT QUITE ACCURATE AND
REGIONALLY THERE WAS -- THIRTY
EIGHT ADVENTURE TRAILS PROPOSED
WHEN WE HELD A HEARING AND
NEGOTIATED ON ON IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PROGRAM WE HONED IT DOWN --
TO SEVEN ADVENTURE TRAILS AND
FORTY FOUR MILES OF ROADS THAT'S
WHAT WE ENDED UP AGREEING TO AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH AND ANALYZING FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING.
TO EXPAND FOR THE NEXT.
FIVE SO THE THE BILL IT AS IT'S
WRITTEN DOZEN EGGS EXPAND DOES
NOT AN ADVANTAGE PROGRAM IT
EXTENDS THE THE PILOT PERIOD BUT
BUT WITHIN THAT THE THE THE
CONFINES OF THAT -- THAT ADOPTED
FRAMEWORK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
OKAY. TWO OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS YES CENTER ON JUST FOR
THE SUPERVISOR WHAT WHAT WAS THE
JUST FOR ME UNDERSTAND LOCAL
DYNAMICS WAS OF THE VOTE COUNT
AND THE ON THE BOARD WAS IT.
UNANIMOUS THREE TWO MINUTES AT
UNANIMOUS YOU KNOW IT'S OKAY --
AND THEN I SIDE YOU ARE CHOMPING
AT THE BIT ON A COUPLE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND SOME OF
THE CONCERNS I THINK IT'S BEGIN
THE MIKE.
A COUPLE OF THINGS I THINK BUT I
KNOW A LOT OF THESE PROJECTS GET
SEPARATED INTO KIND OF LOOKING
AT A NARAL PART OF IT.
AND WHILE DRIVING ON THE PAVED
ROADS IS GONNA REDUCE DICED.
IT'S GIVING ACT.
THE PEOPLE TO BE IN THE DESERT
WHERE THEY CAN MAKE LOTS OF DUST.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE LARGER
PICTURE IF -- FIFTEEN NO PATIENT
ACTUALLY OUT THERE SAYING THAT
THAT THAT HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING
SO FAR.
RIGHT IS AS EFFECTIVELY AS THEY
HAVEN'T ACTUALLY LOOKED AT THAT
IN ANY OF THE VALUATIONS.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS IS THE
SECOND EXTENSION. FOR THE SAME
REASONS.
IT WAS EXTENDED AND THAT.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND THIS IS THEIR
ASKING FOR ANOTHER X. WHEN YOU
SAY THE SAME REASONS THAT THEY
GAVE THE REASON THEIR REASON IS
THAT.
AND THEY'RE SAYING IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN TIED UP IN LITIGATION.
WITH OVER A TWENTY FIFTEEN STILL
IT'S STILL TOOK A COUPLE OF
YEARS TO GET THE PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING HAD -- DESIGNATE THE
ROADS YOU KNOW -- SIGNAGE AND
ALL OF THAT SO -- IF IT'S TRUE
THAT THAT WE HAVE HAD IT BUT IT
IT HAS TAKEN AWHILE TO GET IT
AND WE HAVE ONLY HAD.
REALLY THREE YEARS OF THE FULL
USE OF IT TO TO EVALUATE.
OKAY MAY MAYBE THERE ISN'T A
KIND OF FORMAL CONCLUSION TO
THIS REPORT BUT YOU. THREE FOUR
YEARS WHEN WILL YOU GUYS ALL
LIVE OUT THERE I MEAN YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S HAPPENING OR NOT
AND I'M.
JUST BECAUSE THE REPORT HASN'T
DOCUMENTED EVERY INCIDENT.
WE HAVE IF YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT
TRAIL DELIBERATION OR PROBLEMS.
WE DO MONITOR THAT CLOSELY IN
FACT WE DO IT WITH -- AERIAL MY
AERIAL UP TIGER FEE AND WE ARE
NOT GETTING A PLAYER FRICTION OF
TRAILS WE ARE GETTING SOME USE
AND THE USE HAS INCREASED.
WE WHAT WE TRIED TO DO AND WE
IMPLEMENTED THE PROGRAM WAS PUT
A COUPLE OF TRAILS IN EACH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
SOME OF THOSE TRAILS ARE NOT AS
USEFUL OR BEING USED AS MUCH AS
OTHERS BUT THE ONES NEAR BISHOP
ONE LEADS TO A NO IT'S V. AREA
ONE LEADS TO LAWS MUSEUM ONE
LEASE TO JUST -- IT FROM A
CAMPGROUND AND THAT AND THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE JUST TO PARK AT
THE CAMPGROUND.
IS THAT -- THAT ARE ARE OPEN --
FOR EACH VIEWS ARE STILL OPEN --
FOR EXCUSE IN AREAS THAT AREN'T
ARE NOT PEOPLE CAN ALL THIS DOES
IS CHANGE PEOPLE.
PUTTING THEIR IT'S FREE ON A
TRAILER AND GOING AND PARKING
SOMEWHERE AND USING THE AREA AS
OPPOSED TO IN THE OF VERY
LIMITED AREA DRIVING FROM THE
CAMPGROUND TO THE SAME PLACE.
WHAT WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THE
FINAL REPORT?
FROM COME IN AT NIGHT.
WE WOULD IT.
WOULD THAT I HAVE COMMITTED THAT
I'M NOT GONNA ASK FOR ANOTHER
EXTENSION FOR THIS PROGRAM WE
WOULD EITHER ASKED TO IMPLEMENT
IT AT THE END OF FOUR YEARS
BECAUSE WILL NEED.
TO BE WORKING ON IT A YEAR EARLY
FOR WILL ABANDON THAT'S AND I
MEAN.
I HAVE AN ELECTION COMING UPSO.
I'LL HAVE TO SEE IF I'M.
STILL SUPERVISOR BUT I I BELIEVE
THAT THE COUNTY WILL NOT SUPPORT
TRYING TO GO FOR ANOTHER
EXTENSION I DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
THE IDEA WOULD BE TO SEE --
WHERE WE'RE AT THE END OF THE
NEXT IN THE NEXT FOUR YEARS FIVE
YEARS?
GIVE THE KID.
I DON'T KNOW I I I IT'S IT'S
LIKE WE'RE IS A BIT OF YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES HERE OF
FOLKS ON THE GROUND SO IT'S A
LITTLE TOUGH TO HAVE A GOOD
SENSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING I
GUESS ONE THING AS THE COMMITTEE
ASKING.
FOR A DETAILED ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS -- ON IMPACTS IS AS
PART OF THIS BILL WHAT.
YEAH SO YOU CAN REPORT THAT WE
REQUIRE -- AT THE V<c.cyan>IN THE</c>
VERY LAST SECTION AND CHEAT.
G..
ONE I BELIEVE THAT REPORT ALSO
INCLUDES AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS BUT THAT'S THAT'S A
THAT'S A WAYS OFF I WOULD JUST
ASK.
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR HERE WE
ARE GOING TO SEE THIS BILL FOR
TODAY THE STATE -- THIS KEEP THE
COMMITTEE APPRISED -- EVEN GOING
FORWARD IF WE COULD.
BE LOOKING AT SERVE ON A
CONTINUOUS BASIS JUST TO MAKE
SURE THERE AREN'T SOME ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE HAVE AN
ANTICIPATED OR SOME
PROLIFERATION OF OF OF TRAILS
THAT ARE THAT ARE HAVING
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT -- MICE I MEAN JUST
TO BE CLEAR THIS IS ABOUT THIS
IS A BILL ABOUT THE USE OF THE
ROADS.
NOT THE ACTUAL -- HV ACCESS TO
BEGIN WITH BUT BUT I THINK THAT --
THAT SENT THERE'S A LOT OF
SENSITIVE LAND AT THEIR LOOK AT
WHAT IS THE I FORGET IT'S ONE
POINT LIKE NINETY NINE ALMOST
99% IS FEDERAL IN THE AREA.
TO YOU KNOW SLEEP PUBLIC LANDS
MOST MOSTLY PUBLIC IN FACT I
THINK THE VALUE -- AND
APPROPRIATELY SEIZED ON I THINK
MAYBE A WAY FORWARD WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE SUPERVISOR THAT THERE
WILL NOT BE -- IN EXTENSION
BEYOND THIS PURSUIT AND I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT WE WE GOT TO SEE
WHERE THE THE DATA TAKES US.
IN IF IT MEETS WITH YOUR
APPROVAL -- I'M WONDERING IF WE
MIGHT HAVE AN INTERIM --
ENVIRONMENTAL REPORT THAT MIGHT
BE HELPFUL.
AND IF YOU'VE BEEN SUPPORT OF A
WE WILL.
BE HAPPY TO DO THAT AT THE SAY
THE TWO YEAR TO TWO OR THREE
YEAR MARK -- DO AN INTERMEDIATE
WORK AND SUBMIT THAT THAT WOULD
ALSO HELP US -- YOU KNOW FORCE
US TO LOOK AT THE PROGRAM --
PART WAY THROUGH YEAH.
IN AN BOB.
I I I LIKE THE IDEA OKAY BUT ALL
I UNDERSTAND THAT AMEND THE
NOISE IMPACTS IN ANDERSON SOME
OF THE OTHER SORT OF COMMUNITY
LEVEL CONCERNS -- BUT AT LEAST
ON THIS ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE I I
WOULD BE GREAT IF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL.
REVIEW LOOK AT THE AREAS.
OUTSIDE OF THE COMBINED USE
ROADS THAT ARE IMPACTED.
RIGHT I MEAN IT I'VE I HAVE
PICTURES OF DAMAGE TO THE MORE
AGGREGATE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
TO THE READER.
BE A LAND IS REQUESTED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS
YEAR FOR RESTORATION WORK.
AND I WILL COME FROM -- H. FEES
THAT RE OUT THERE DAMAGING
THINGS THAT I'M VERY I I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE HER
SENSITIVITIES EXPRESSED -- I
THINK EVERYONE THAT LIVES IN
THIS AREA THAT'S A GORGEOUS HERE
AND IF YOU'RE A BEEN THERE.
IT'S AS THE FANTASTIC INYO MONO
COUNTY THERE ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
AREAS.
AND I THINK PART OF THE THE THE
PASSION THAT UNDERLIE IT -- THIS
PILOT PROGRAM IS MAKING CERTAIN
THAT PEOPLE DON'T DEGRADE THE
ENVIRONMENT BY NOT HAVING ACCESS.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IF ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU.
YOU CUT OFF THE DUAL USE.
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE ARE GOING
TO GO ELSEWHERE.
IN THE WE'RE TRYING TO STEER
THEM IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION JUST
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
SELECT WITH THIS CONVERSATIONS
HEADED.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MOVE ALL YOUR OPPOSITION BECAUSE
A YOU KNOW ALL THESE.
LOCAL ISSUES TO GET CONTENTIOUS
BUT I I'M I'M GAME TO WORK WITH
YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND EVEN ENGAGE SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE FOLKS WHO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS TO SCOPE SOME KIND OF
INTERIM REPORTS THAT WE CAN --
DEAL WITH SOME OF THESE
ANXIETIES OUT THERE WITHOUT
UNNECESSARILY -- IMPEDING THE
EXTENSION A PILOT.
AND I WOULD JUST ASK THAT -- THE
COUNTY OR MYSELF GET IS INCLUDED
IN THOSE DEAR GRADUATES YOU CAN
ARRIVE AT I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT YOUR WITH
YOUR WITH THIS AUTHOR HERE SO --
BUT I BUT I WOULD JUST SAY TO TO
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH THE FOLKS
WITH CONCERNS AND LET'S LET'S
GET SOME TRANSPARENCY AROUND
THIS AND SEE IF WE CAN'T.
SURE LOOK AT THAT BROADER
IMPACTED THE SENATOR MENTIONED
AND MAKE SURE WE KEEP THIS
REGION.
PRISTINE.
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO IT HERE WE
CAN WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE I
THINK BETWEEN NOW AND
APPROPRIATIONS IF THAT'S
AMENABLE.
THAT THAT WORK IN A PROCEDURALLY
TELL ME IF I'M.
IF THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE I
WOULD BE TOTALLY FRIENDLY TO ADD
TO THE AMENDMENT -- THAT'D
INTERMENT PORT -- BE
INCORPORATED INTO THIS PILOT.
EXTENSION.
MISTER PLEASE INVENT VETERANS
ARE PREPARED TO MAKE THE MOTION
AND THEN.
YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY RATHER THAN.
GET TO THE SPECIFIC SERVER MA'AM
IN TODAY WORK WITH THAT AS THE
CHAIRS.
COMMENTING FROM THE DíAS WORK
WITH HIM AND HIS STAFF BETWEEN
NOW AND APPROPRIATIONS TO WORK
OUT THE DETAILS OF THAT
AMENDMENT.
OKAY WORLD I'M OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- WITH THAT
COMMITMENT -- WAS SUPPORTED AND
THERE IS A MOTION APPRECIATE THE
THE FLEXIBILITY AND OPENNESS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
TO AND WITH THAT.
ASK -- YOU I'M SORRY ASK YOU TO
CLOSER.
THAT NIGHT I A I WANT TO THANK --
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS THAT CAME
OUT -- TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR
EVEN THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO
THINK EVERYONE HAS THE SAME --
MINDSET THEY WANT TO PROTECT THE
AREA BUT DO SO IN A BALANCED
RESPONSIBLE WAY THAT ALLOWS FOR
A TOURISM -- AND THOSE THAT
RECORD EIGHT BUT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE AYE VOTE -- BECAUSE
THE PURPOSE OF A PILOT PROGRAM
IS TO ACTUALLY BE A PILOT
PROGRAM AND ALLOW ITSELF TO
COMPLETE SO THAT WE CAN --
INTERPRET THE DATA AND SEE WHERE
THE MERITS REVEAL THEMSELVES
VERY GOOD -- THANK YOU SO THE
MOTION IS -- DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR STERN AYE STERN
AYE JONES JONES I ALLEN.
FORGES HI GORGEOUS I CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO.
JACKSON MONEY.
HAS THREE WILL BE ON CALL.
WITH A SALES CALL -- THAT AS
THREE WE WILL LEAVE THAT MEASUR
ON CALL THING CENTER THANK YOU
SUPERVISOR -- THE PERSON.
WHO WAS WITH YOU?
I MIGHT I'M UP YOU CAN BE A TO
NOMINATE MYSELF HERE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR YOU WANT THE
GAVEL HERE WILL PRESENT TO YOU I
THINK I THINK WE GOT A LITTLE
STALL -- ALL RIGHT.
GO CRAZY.
THERE YOU GO THANKS -- SURE YEAH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AS BEFORE
SIXTY TWO SENATOR STERN.
OKAY [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING.
MY OWN AMENDMENTS -- THE WE
HEARD EARLIER TODAY ABOUT THE
GAPS IN CALIFORNIA'S WORK FORCE
TO DEAL WITH THIS ON GOING WILD
FIRE RISK.
AND THIS IS ONE IMPORTANT PIECE
WE THINK. TO TO HELP FILL THAT
GAP BY.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BEEF UP --
OUR PROGRAM STATE WIDE TO
ADDRESS.
NOT JUST -- WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
IN.
SORT OF RURAL AREAS BUT ALSO IN
THAT WHILE THE INTERNMENT
INTERFACE.
SO WE NEED PROPER TRAINING TO
GET A PIPELINE OF TALENT.
READY TO TAKE ON THE CHALLENGES
OF THIS NEW.
AND VERY DANGEROUS FUTURE WE WE
LIVE IN HERE SO I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR IT TOO MUCH BUT I IT
JUST UP FRONT WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT -- BOTH UC AND
CSU ARE GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT PARTNERS BUT I I ALSO
TRULY APPRECIATE -- THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ACADEMIC
SENATE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE -- THE
BACKBONE OF BRINGING FOLKS INTO
THE JOBS OF THIS NEW ABNORMAL
AND WE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
FEEDBACK AND WANT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THEM HERE TODAY SO --
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER --
TO ARE EXCELLENT WITNESSES WHO
HAVE BEEN HERE -- AND AND
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES FOR MANY
YEARS I THINK WE HAVE -- BOTH
YOU SEE EXTENSION AND THE FIRE
RESTORATION GROUP OF MAYBE
NATURE CONSERVANCY STILL HERE.
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE --
BUT YOU CAN START OFF.
WHERE'S MY ON ITS ON ITS COMES
OPPOSITE ON OKAY SORRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SENATOR STERN. FOR
REALLY TAKING THE NEXT STEP FROM --
LAST YEAR'S WORK THAT WE DID
TOGETHER IN THIS COMMITTEE WHICH
FOR THE SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY
WERE SENATOR JACKSON INTRODUCED
A REALLY COMPREHENSIVE FIRE BILL.
AND THAT STONE WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
IN SEPTEMBER AND SENATE BILL.
FOR SIXTY TWO TAKES A PIECE OF
THAT SECTION ABOUT ONE WHICH
TALKED ABOUT WERE RESTORATION
WORK FORCE AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH --
ACADEMICS AND OTHER PARTIES FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS TO REALLY IN STILL
RESILIENCE AND CALIFORNIA'S
LANDSCAPES IN A PROFESSIONAL WAY.
AND THIS THIS.
IS WHAT THIS LANGUAGE INTENDS TO
DO I'M SPEAKING TOWARDS THE
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
AND THAT WAY WE HAVE EXISTING
CURRICULUM THERE THAT TALKS
ABOUT FIVE YEARS IT IS CALLED
FIRE TECHNOLOGY IT'S FOCUSED ON
FIRE SUPPRESSION WE HAVE
FORESTRY THERE THAT.
TENDS TO TRACK INTO -- FORCE
MANAGEMENT AND TIMBER MANAGEMENT.
AND WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THE
THOSE CURRICULUM HAVE.
COMPONENTS IN THEM THAT WE CAN
USE TO RETOOL BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- ADOPTING A NEW PROGRAM
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE
WHERE THERE'S EXISTING CORPSE
WORK AND SOME OF THAT THAT NEEDS
TO BE RE TUNE SUCH AS
UNDERSTANDING AND LEARNING THE
TECHNIQUES OF APPLYING
PRESCRIBED FIRE WHICH IS.
CRITICAL TO RESTORING RESILIENCE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE HAVE DEDICATED WORK FORCE
THE RESTORATION WORK FORCE IS
NEEDED TO BUILD AND MAINTAIN
FIRE RESILIENCE IN CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE RECITATION WITH A VERY
FIRE PROMOTING.
CLIMATE AND A VERY -- FIRES
STRONGLY FIRE ASSOCIATED SWEET
VEGETATION TYPES.
THE IMPORTANCE OF ALL OF THE
MONEY IS THE FUNDING THAT'S
COMING THROUGH THE WHETHER IT'S
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
INITIATIVE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
MONEY.
OR ANOTHER PARTNERSHIPS AND
OTHER -- FUNDING SOURCES IS TO
TRY TO REGAIN THAT RESILIENCE
THAT'S BEEN AT RISK AND OUT OF
WHACK FOR OVER A CENTURY.
WE NEED AS WE HEARD.
FROM THE GENTLEMAN THAT SPOKE ON
SENATOR DODD'S BILL.
THE YOU TO THE GENTLEMAN FROM
THE UTILITY COALITION I COULDN'T
OF DONE A BETTER JOB TALKING
ABOUT HOW.
INAPPROPRIATE IT IS SU HAVE
UNTRAINED PEOPLE WORKING IN
THESE LANDSCAPES AS SAYS IT'S
NOT WHAT CALIFORNIA DESERVES.
IT'S GOING TO JUST KEEP
INCREASING THE DISASTER MùT
THAT WERE IN.
AND SO IT TO HAVE A TWO YEAR
CURRICULUM IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT YOU DON'T NEED TO BE A
PHD TO DO THIS WORK BUT YOU DO
NEED TO BE EDUCATED.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW AND POLICY YOU
NEED TO KNOW HOW TO COLLABORATE.
YOU NEED TO TYPICALLY IMPORTANT
AND COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE IN THE WE WE AND IN
MORE URBANIZED AREAS TO BE ABLE.
TO TRAIN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS
INDEFENSIBLE SPACE --
REQUIREMENTS UNDER CALIFORNIA
EXISTING LAW TO BE ABLE TO
HARDEN THOSE HOMES AND PROTECT
THEM FROM FIRES BUT ALSO BE ABLE
TO DO THE LANDSCAPERS ALLEGIANCE
WORK.
SO JUST AT THE FINAL THING I'LL
SAY IS THAT.
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED AN
EMERGENCY PROCULUS PROCLAMATION
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS SIGNED A
NEW FIRE WHILE FIRE RELATED
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION.
THAT BASICALLY EXEMPTS
CALIFORNIA FROM ITS PREMIERE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION STATUTE.
CALLS OUT THE NATIONAL GUARD. TO
DO THE WORK.
IF I COULD DEFINE DESPERATE SOME
OTHER WAY I WOULD BET THAT IS
SOUNDING PRETTY DESPERATE TO ME.
AND SO THIS RESTORATION WORK
FORCE WERE HELP US GAIN THAT
RESILIENCY BUT HAVE THE
PROFESSIONAL SKILL TO BE ABLE TO
DO THE WORK AND DO IT RIGHT. TO
UNDERSTAND THE ECOLOGY OF THE
ECOSYSTEMS.
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES?
AND TO I MEAN MOVES ON TO THE
NEXT YEAR.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WITNESSES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU -- GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY
NAME IS LINDA QUINN DAVIDSON AND
I'M UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
ONLY FIRED VISOR.
IN THE STATE -- BASED IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND AYE AYE SIR
FOR COUNTIES UP IN THE NORTH
COAST -- AND WE ALL KNOW WE'RE
AT A CRITICAL TIME FOR FIRE
WE'VE HEARD I THIS MORNING
QUITE A BIT.
AND WE HAVE A REALLY URGENT NEED
TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND TO
MAKE OUR LANDSCAPES MORE
RESILIENT -- IN THE LAST YEARS
OF REALLY HIT THAT HARD AND
SHOWN US THAT NO PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA'S A MUTUAL WILD FIRE --
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT REALLY
AFFECT ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE IN A REALLY UNIQUE
POSITION BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
OF FUNDING RIGHT NOW FOR FIRE
MITIGATION AND SHE WAS REDUCTION
WORK.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF PUBLIC
SUPPORT AND SOCIAL LICENSE AND I
THINK WE HAVEN'T HAD -- TO THIS
EXTENT FOR A LONG TIME BUT WE
REALLY DON'T HAVE THE THE
TRAINED WORK FORCE TO DO THE
WORK.
AND SO MANY OF US WHO WORK ON
THE SHOES ON THESE ISSUES REALLY
SEE OF BUILDING CAPACITY AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS A TOP
PRIORITY.
AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
CALIFORNIA REALLY NEEDS A
COORDINATED EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
AROUND FIRE -- WE WE NEED THIS
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND OUR FORESTS AND WATERSHEDS
AND SO WITHIN SB FOUR SIXTY TWO
IS A PLAN TO DEVELOP A NETWORK
OF FIRE ADVISERS LIKE MYSELF.
AND OTHER EXPERTS -- TO WORK
DIRECTLY ON ON FIRE SO I'M HERE
TO SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE AND
MAYBE HELP YOU ALL SEE WHAT THAT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE -- I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU KNOW BUT YOU SEE
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION IS IN
EVERY COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA BOTH
RURAL AND URBAN.
AND WE HAVE A ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SIX YEAR PARTNERSHIP --
BETWEEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTIES AND
SO WE LINKED TOGETHER TO BRING --
SCIENCE BASED INFORMATION TO THE
COUNTIES AND ON AND ON A VARIETY
OF TOPICS AND FOCUSED ON
ECOLOGICAL AND ECONOMIC
RESILIENCY.
AND WE ALSO HAVE EXTENSIVE
NETWORK THE VOLUNTEERS THAT ARE
PART OF OUR PROGRAMS AND YOU'VE
PROBABLY HEARD OF FOR H. A
MASTER GARDENERS AS OUR PROGRAMS
TO COME OUT OF OUR OFFICES -- SO
AS AN EXTENSION FIRE ADVISER I
HOST A LOT OF WORKSHOPS AND
TRAININGS I DO RESEARCH -- I
ALSO WORK ON POLICY BARRIERS FOR
LANDOWNERS AND LAND MANAGERS
HE'S OF THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
THAT WE DO AS ADVISORS.
AND SO JUST FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS AND IN THIS JOB
I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT THREE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS OF GRANT
FUNDING TO THE COUNTIES THAT I
WORK IN.
OPPOSED TO DOZENS OF WORKSHOPS
AND TRAIN HUNDRED PEOPLE AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND FUELS
REDUCTION SO JUST IMAGINE WHAT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF WE HAD A
NETWORK OF FOLKS LIKE ME
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I ACTUALLY
TRAVEL A LOT TO OTHER PARTS THE
STATE TO FILL THOSE NEEDS
BECAUSE WE JUST.
DON'T HAVE IT WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY -- AND THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST EXAMPLE OF LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS LIKE THIS THAT WOULD
THAT COULD -- FUND PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
OTHER -- OVER A COUPLE OF OTHERS
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS THAT
WERE HUGELY SUCCESSFUL AND AND
TIME LEAVE TO ADDRESS REALLY
IMPORTANT PROBLEMS SO.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
BEING IN YOUR NAME AND US
ASSOCIATION PLEASE GREAT LIFT
FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THERE'S A HUGE NEED
FOR SKILLED WORK FORCE -- FOR
FOR FRUSTRATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE FACE OF UNPRECEDENTED MAJOR
FIRES.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE
ASK YOU WE'VE HAD ABOUT EIGHT
MINUTES OF PRESERVATION FROM
THAT WOULD BE GREAT ONE AT A
COLLECTION OF A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU DON'T KNOW YOUR CZ
HEATING RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MORNING AFFIRMATIVE ON THE ON
BEHALF F THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR SINGLE BEGIN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF ON BEHALF OF
HUMBLE MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TECHIES
TO REPRESENT SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE WERE ALSO SPORTS.
YEAH I MISTER MEMBERS BRIAN
WHITE HERE FOR CALIFORNIA
LICENSE FOR ASSOCIATION
ENFORCEMENT OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT. ONE OF THEM WE DON'T
KNOW WITHOUT ONE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS ROBERT
SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MISSION.
MORNING -- JUST AN OLD FIELD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MR STERN THAT'S AN INTERESTING
COALITION OF VOTERS IN CITY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ONE
CALIFORNIA ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO TO
SENATORS TERMS BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEING -- NINE QUESTIONS FROM
THE DíAS MR BOARD.
I JUST WANT TO DO -- THANK THE
OF THE AUTHOR OF THIS FOR BRING
YOUR FORD -- I THINK WHEN YOU
HAVE A A GLARING NEED. FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TALENT.
AND THE FORESEEABLE RELIANCE ON
THAT TOWN MOVING FORWARD I MEAN.
NO BRAINER.
SO.
I'M PREPARED TO MOVE ON THIS
THANK YOU CENTER.
MOTION ON THE BILL ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS SEEING
NONE MISTER STEARNS LIKE TO
CLOSE YOU'VE HEARD VERY
EXTENSIVE TESTIMONY URGENT.
NEED -- HOPEFULLY THIS PROVIDE
SOME SUPPLY FROM MUCH NEEDED
WORKERS TO TACKLE THE NEW NORMAL --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I THINK MRS
TURN CLOSE -- DO PASS AS AMENDED
YOU'RE TAKING IN MINUTES RIGHT
YOU SAID THAT AND THEN WE HAVE
SIR TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR STERN AYE STERN I'D
JONES JONES I ALLEN.
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS ICON BUREAU
HERTZBERG HUESO.
SO I JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY HI.
THIS BILL.
CALL YOUR FIVE VOTES WILL KEEP
IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS I THINK WE'RE ALL OVER
THE PLACE TODAY SO I KNOW I'M IN
THREE DIFFERENT PLACES.
AT THE SAME TIME AS A MATTER OF
FACT SO PHYSICALLY SEEMINGLY
IMPOSSIBLE LEGAL -- FIVE I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER -- SENATORS HERE
TO PRESENT THE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MOVE ON YEAH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON
VETERAN YEAH WE'RE GOOD OKAY
LET'S DO IT.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU OKAY
[inaudible]
AND OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR OUR OKAY -- SO I'M
PRESENTING SENATE BILL FOR
SEVENTY FOUR BEFORE I BEGIN I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE WORK
WE WERE DOING ON THE WATER LAW
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED IN
THE INTRODUCED VERSION OF THIS
BILL.
WILL CONTINUE LED BY ARE
INCREDIBLY ABLE STAFF -- DENNIS
O'CONNOR -- WHO'S BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I'M COMMITTED
TO SEEING THIS WORK CONTINUE.
THROUGHOUT THE OFFSEASON AND
DURING THE IN SEASON --
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS TO RESOLVE
ON ON GOING AMBIGUITY ROUND
WATER RATES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT I WANTED TO JUMP
ON THE CHANCE TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET.
ON THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
WHICH WE SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW TO
EXPIRE -- BOND ISSUANCES COME
AND GO BUT THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND HAS BEEN A
STEADY SOURCE OF MONEY -- AN
IMPORTANT GRANT FUNDING FOR
CONSERVATION FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS -- AND THIS BILL EXTENDED
FOR ANOTHER THIRTY IF YOU LOOK
AT WHERE THE MONEY IS GONE YOU
SEE IT BENEFITS EVERY AREA.
RED AND BLUE RURAL URBAN --
THERE'S BENEFITS ACROSS -- ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE NEED
IS STILL HUGE -- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RAPIDLY DISAPPEARING
WILDLIFE HABITATS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE
VOTERS OF RECOGNIZE THE NEED --
FOR BUT THE NEED IS GROWN AT IN
LIGHT OF THAT PRESSURE THE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND POPULATION
GROWTH.
THIS FUND HAS PROTECTED MORE
THAN MILLION ACRES -- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING HABITAT FOR DEER
MOUNTAIN LIONS THREATENED
SPECIES WETLANDS AQUATIC AND
RIPARIAN HABITAT IN CORRIDORS.
THE EXPENDITURES ARE EVENLY
DIVIDED AS WELL BETWEEN NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN SO I DON'T THINK
THERE'S SOME REGIONAL DIVIDE
HERE -- BUT WE'VE INCREDIBLE
<c.green>OALITION TO SUPPORT THEM I'M</c>
TRULY GRATEFUL FOR EVERYONE --
SNAPPING UP THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
EXTEND WHAT'S BEEN ADDED A TRULY
LANDMARK CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
WITH THAT ASPECT YES FOR AYE
VOTE -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TWO
MINUTES EACH [inaudible]
I AM.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS FRED HOLES STAFF COUNSEL
FROM HOMELAND FOUNDATION.
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK -- IN
SUPPORT OF EXTENDING HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND.
THE MODELING FOUNDATION WAS
ORGANIZED TO SPONSOR THE
WILDLIFE PROTECTION ACT OF
NINETEEN NINE THIS PROP ONE
SEVENTEEN TO PROTECT MOUNTAIN
LIONS FOR SUPPORT TRAINING.
AND JUST ESTABLISH THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND.
WE CLOSELY FOLLOW THE IMPACT
THAT POPULATION INCREASES IN
DEVELOPMENT OF HAD ON MOUNTAIN
LIONS FISH WILDLIFE AND HABITAT
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS OF
PROP ONE SEVENTEEN ARE AS
RELEVANT TODAY AS THEY ARE WHEN
THEY'RE PROVE ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS AGO.
SELECT IT BRIEFLY STATE.
PROTECTION ENHANCEMENT AND
RESTORATION OF WILDLIFE HABITAT
AND FISHERIES ARE VITAL TO
MAINTAINING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THE STATE'S HUMAN
POPULATION INCREASES THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO PROTECT THE
RAPIDLY DISAPPEARING WILDLIFE
HABITATS THE SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE AND VERY
WILDLIFE RESOURCES.
AND THAT WAS THIRTY YEARS AGO.
IF WE ARE TO GROW.
AND PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE SHARE WE MUST CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS ANNUAL EXPENDITURE OF
THIRTY MILLION IS SPLIT EQUALLY
BETWEEN NORTH AND SOUTH OF THE
STATE.
AND WORKS OUT TO JUST SEVENTY
FIVE CENTS PER CALIFORNIA AND
PER YEAR.
THE GENERATION AGO VOTERS
CREATED HABITAT CONSERVATION
CONSERVATION FUND TO INVEST IN
THE FUTURE.
THEY ALSO GAVE US THE OP
RESPONSIBILITY TO REVIEW WHAT IS
ACCOMPLISHED AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO USE THE FUND TO
PROTECT AND RESTORE WILDLIFE
HABITAT.
AND FISHERIES IN CALIFORNIA
GOING FORWARD.
ON JUST ONE RECENT EXAMPLE OF
SUCCESS.
IS -- JUST LAST FALL.
THERE WERE -- THE MOUNTAINS
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY WAS ABLE TO ACQUIRE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ACRES OF
TRIANGLE RANCH.
IN THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS.
AND THIS ACQUISITION PROTECTED
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS AND HABITAT.
AS WELL AS PROVIDING A PUBLIC
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE FUND IS PROVEN TO BE
ADAPTABLE AND VITAL SOURCE OF
FUNDS FOR PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AND IT'S BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
WILDLIFE AND HABITAT.
MADELINE FOUNDATION THERE FOR
JUST A YES VOTE ON THIS BEFORE.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS EMILY SERVER
OWN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR I WANTED TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE AMAZING
BREATH OF WHAT'S BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND.
WITHIN THE DISTRICTS REPRESENTED
BY THIS COMMITTEE ALONE OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN SPENT NEARLY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
HAVE BEEN CONSERVE SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY EXAMPLES OF SUCH
EXPENDITURES INCLUDE PROJECTS
LIKE THE SAN FELIPE WILDLIFE
AREA ACQUISITION AND RESTORATION
PROJECT IN CENTER JONES IS
DISTRICT.
A CRITICAL LINKAGES THAT
SUPPORTS MOUNTAIN LION BOBCAT
GRAY FOX GOLDEN EAGLE MOUNTING
STAKE MIGRATORY BIRDS AND UPLAND
GAME BIRDS SUCH AS DOVE AND
QUAIL.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE AND CENTER A
COUPLE YEARS DISTRICT IS THE LOS
BONOS WILDLIFE ISLAND WETLAND
ENHANCEMENT PROJECT WHICH
INVOLVED A COLLABORATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY JOINT HABITAT VENTURE TO
ENHANCE SEASONAL WETLANDS AND
IMPROVE WATER.
DELIVERY INFRASTRUCTURE.
THROW ALL OF CALIFORNIA THE AGE
THAT HAS INVESTED INVESTED MORE
THAN ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE PAST THIRTY YEARS IN
PROTECTING MORE THAN MILLION
ACRES WITH THOUSANDS OF
COMPLETED PROJECTS.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS THE H. C.
F. HAS LED TO THE ACQUISITION OF
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES OF
DEAR AMOUNT LAND HABITAT TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE THOUSAND
ACRES OF ENDANGERED SPECIES
HABITAT. TWO HUNDRED NINETY ONE
THOUSAND ACRES OF WETLANDS
HABITAT THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND ACRES AQUATIC
RIPARIAN HABITAT.
AND SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES
OF WHILE THE QUARTERS AND TRAILS.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE FOR
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE WE'RE OF
COURSE VERY INTERESTED IN
PROTECTING HABITAT FOR WILDLIFE
HOWEVER I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THESE DOLLARS
HAVE GONE TOWARDS PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT PEOPLE.
TO SUCH AS WELL IN WATERSHED
RESTORATION PROJECTS WITH WATER
QUALITY BENEFITS ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND IMPROVED
OUTDOOR ACCESS AND TRAIL
RESTORATION PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY AS ALREADY
MENTIONED EIGHT SEVEN VESTMENTS
ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE OF
PROJECTS RANGING FROM FISHERIES
AND FOR US RESTORATION RURAL
PARTS OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
REFUGE RECIRCULATION IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TRAIL RESTORATION
URBAN AREAS SUCH AS THE
NEIGHBORHOOD GRAMMAR SEE PARK IN
SOUTH LA.
TIDAL MARSH RESTORATION ALONG
THE COAST AND HOBBY -- DESERT
LAND PROTECTION.
AS YOU CAN SEE THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND HAS BEEN
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE PAY AS WE GO
PROGRAM FOR IMPLEMENTING A WIDE
RANGE OF VITAL CONSERVATION
EFFORTS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE.
THANK YOU INNER DRIVE OUT.
THE VERY LAST.
GOOD ON BOTH A WITNESSES TIMING
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
DONNA WITH AUDUBON CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER FRANK PLEASE REPRESENT
BOTH THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
YOU CAN FAX SOME HALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
I'M FEDERAL NOT BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN SIDE HE AND
CALIFORNIA RELIEF AND SUPPORT.
MARK FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
THE LEAGUE TO SAVE LAKE TAHOE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
THIRTY AND THE BIG CERTAINLY
INTEREST ON SPORTS.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
WEARING CONTINUE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORDS IN THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
BUT THE REVENUE MINISTER OF
CIVIL RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
AND ANIMAL RIGHTS.
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENDA WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT.
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THING OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ONE PERSON COMING FOR
PROPOSITION IF WE CAN -- PROVIDE
A SEAT FOR PLEASE THANK YOU.
MORNING NO -- CREAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
HAVING A LETTER IN -- TO TRUST
MY POSITION BUT THIS BILL JUST
WAS IN PRINT YESTERDAY -- SO.
OUR CONCERN LIES SOLELY WITH THE
FUNDING FOR ACQUISITION -- AND
WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
CONTINUING FUNDING FOR
RESTORATION AND ENHANCEMENT --
BUT THE CHALLENGES THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS A SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLAR BACKLOG IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TWENTY BILLION OF
THAT IS FOR NON TRANSPORTATION
RELATED PROJECTS.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE STATE IS --
GRANTED EITHER THROUGH A FUN
LIKE TO HAVE THAT.
FUND OR THROUGH BONDS MONEY TO
ACQUIRE LAND BUT THERE IS NO
MONEY TO MANAGE THAT LAND AFTER
IT'S ACQUIRED AND SO ONCE THE
GOVERNMENT OWNS THAT LAND
OFTENTIMES THOSE VALUES FOR
WHICH THE PROPERTY WAS ACQUIRED --
DISAPPEAR BECAUSE OF THE POOR
MANAGEMENT GOING FORWARD SO.
WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND INSTEAD
AND WOULD ALLOW US TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION IS I'M ADJUSTING THE
FUNDS SO THAT?
ALLOWED FOR ACQUISITION THROUGH
THE USE OF CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS RATHER THAN FEE TITLE
ACQUISITION I'M AND THEN ALSO
FUNDING FOR THE RESTORATION HAND
SMIT.
I'M IF IF IT WAS POSSIBLE TO
MAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ALLOW US.
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO CENTER SERVES
BILL.
SO YOU COULD YOU COULD DO THAT
WITH -- QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
CENTER STERN WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
TO THE OPPOSITION IN AND LET US
KNOW WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON
THAT YET.
SHE TO THE FEEDBACK AND AND THIS
IS -- RELATIVELY RECENT SO --
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO DIGEST
IT BUT I THINK I'VE NO VERSION.
TO WORKING ON THE ELIGIBILITY OF
SOME OF MANAGEMENT AND MAKING
SURE THAT THESE ACQUISITIONS ARE
ACTUALLY PROPERLY ACHIEVING THE
BENEFITS THAT THEIR THEIR THEIR
INTENDED TO ACHIEVE SO.
EL ALL CONTINUE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ARE MAKE THAT
COMMITMENT TODAY AND CERTAINLY
FIFTIES MOVES ON TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT I'D LOVE TO
CHAT MORE WITH THE FARM BUREAU
JUST DRILL DOWN WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING IN THAT.
A LITTLE MORE ON THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG TO THAT IS
GOING TO BE WHAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE YET.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TWENTY
BILLION.
IS IN REFERENCE TO IS THAT AS
THE IT'S A STATEWIDE SORT OF
OVERALL STARTED TO CALL YOU BACK
UP I JUST WANT.
TO SET.
I'M OUTLINED FOUNDATION
QUESTIONS OF HE OKAY COME BACK
UP TO THAT DEGREE.
THAT WAS IN THE LA OWES REPORT
TIME THAT THEY DID FOR THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IT WENT OVER SO
SEVENTY BILLION TOTAL. TWENTY
BILLION OF THAT IS NON
TRANSPORTATION RELATED FUNDS.
YEAH.
OKAY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU GREAT LET'S DRAW DOWN SOME
MORE THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
DANCE BEFORE I MAKE MY COMES.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION FOR THE
MELLON FOUNDATION ACTUALLY IS
UNRELATED TO THE TO THE BILL BUT
IT CAME UP IN THE AND IT AS WAS
MENTIONED IT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE
IN MY DISTRICT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY NUMBERS ON THE
NUMBER OF MOUNTAIN LIONS --
PRIOR TO NINETEEN NINETY THAT
WERE HUNTED ANNUALLY VERSES THE
NUMBER OF MOUNT LANES TODAY THAT
ARE TAKEN BY TRADITION PERMITS --
I CANNOT SPEAK AT THE EXAM.
ACTUAL SPORT HUNTING OF MOUNTAIN
LIONS WAS MADE PERMANENT TO
PROPOSITION -- ONE SEVENTEEN IT
HAD BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW BY
RONALD REAGAN EARLIER.
SO THAT WAS QUITE A PERIOD OF
TIME.
THAT THE NINETY WOULD HAVE BEEN --
GOVERNOR WILSON ONE OF THE RIGHT
BUT I'M THE SPORT HUNTING WAS
OUTLAWED MUCH EARLIER AND THERE
WAS MOVEMENT TO BRING IT BACK
AND SO THAT WAS PART OF THE
REASON FOR THE INITIATIVE WAS TO
MAKE THE BAND PERMANENTLY --
OKAY AND AND REALLY THE THE THE
POINT OF MY PURSES I ASSUME
CONSTITUENTS AND BRING THIS UP.
AND OFTEN TO MEAN I HAVE TO
ADDRESS IN MY DISTRICT AND THEN
THE NUMBER THAT I'VE BEEN QUOTED
IS PRIOR TO THE OUTLAW OF MOUNT
LINE HUNTING THERE WAS ABOUT.
FORTY FIVE MOUNTAIN LIONS HUNTED
ANNUALLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AFTER THE PROHIBITION ONE IN A
PLACE THERE'S ABOUT FORTY FIVE
MOUNTAIN LANDS THAT ARE KILLED
EACH YEAR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY LICENSED PETITION.
PERMIT HOLDERS DOES THAT NUMBER
TO THOSE NUMBERS SOUND THERE ARE
ACCURATELY -- THINK IT'S SEVERAL
HUNDRED PER YEAR SEVERAL HUNDRED
FOR YOUR ARE TAKEN BY TRADITION --
UNDER DEPOSITION PERMITS I CAN
GET YOU THAT DEPOSITION I'M
SORRY I'M TAKEN I'M USING THE
WRONG TERM BECAUSE THAT
PARTITION YOU'RE RIGHT WAS QUITE
A FEW TO SEPARATION PERMITS AS
WELL AS ON TRAFFIC.
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE IMPACT
AREAS OKAY.
AND I I APOLOGIZE.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE YOUR BILL IF
YOU COULD SEND MY OFFICE SOME
INFORMATION THAT AND WE
CERTAINLY DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT WAY I CAN JUST ADDRESS IT
TO MY CONSTITUENTS THAT BRING IT
UP QUITE A BIT -- MY CONCERN WAS
ALSO THE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE IN OUR STATE
PARKS AND YOU KNOW OTHER.
IT'S IT' A RELATED BUT I'M
RELATED TO THIS YOU KNOW I I GET
THAT I THINK THE FARM BUREAU
ACCURATELY -- ADDRESS MY
CONCERNS AS THE ONLY OFF TODAY --
BUT BECAUSE OF YOUR COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH THE FARMING OMINOUS
SUPPORT TO BUILD THANK YOU --
AND OBVIOUS ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME THING
THANK A WITH DOWN AYE.
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
PREVIEW THE FEEDBACK ONE IRON
THIS OUT -- AS BEST WE CAN
BEFORE HOPEFULLY THE FLOOR --
WILL NEED ALL YOUR SUPPORT GOING
FORWARD I THINK THIS EXTENSION
THIS IS A IMPORTANT YOUR TO DO
IT.
THE DILIGENCE HAS BEEN DONE --
NOT TRYING TO MINIMIZE THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG I
DON'T THINK WE CAN TACKLE IT ALL
HERE TODAY BUT IT'S A HUGE ISSUE --
AND SO FOR ALL NOT JUST THE
SPECIES IN THE HABITAT FOR THE
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO STILL
LOVE WILDNESS IN THEIR LIVES
SAID RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
PRIVATE.
THIS MONEY YOU'RE MOTIONS TO DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES I JONES I ALLEN FORGES
CABALLERO.
HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY NINE THAT'S ON CALL.
FOR MR STERN YOUR OF BILLS ON
CALL FOR AYE VOTES I SEE.
IN A RUBIO IN THE HOUSE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO HAVE FOR PRISON NEXT.
FOR MORE BUILT FOR THE CLOSEST.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT?
WHAT WHAT COMMITTEES I MIGHT
HAVE A BILL UP THERE TO ELECTION?
YEAH.
SB.
SIX SIX EIGHT THAT ONE MORE TIME
FILE AND FOURTEEN SENATOR RUBIO
SB.
SIX SIX EIGHT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SB SIX SIX EIGHT
A BILL RELATING TO DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND WATER SYSTEMS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE SOME PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WHICH I WILL GLADLY
ACCEPT THAT WOULD REQUIRE ALL
URBAN WATER SUPPLIERS TO CREATE
AN UPDATE -- DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS PLANS CALIFORNIA
WATER CODE. ONE ZERO SIX ONE
SEVEN DEFINES AN URBAN WATER
SUPPLIER AS A SUPPLIER EITHER
PUBLICLY OR PRIVATELY A
PRIVATELY OWNED PROVIDING WATER
FOR MUNICIPAL PURPOSES.
EITHER DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY TO
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS FOR SUPPLYING MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
WATER.
ANNUALLY MORE SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WOULD DO THE FOLLOWING TWO
THINGS FIRST IT WOULD REQUIRE
URBAN WATER SUPPLIERS TO UPDATE
THEIR DISASTER PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
NO LESS THAN ONCE EVERY FIVE
YEARS.
SECOND IT WOULD CHANGE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WATER AGENCIES
MUST COMPLY WITH THE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
FROM PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS WITH
TEN THOUSAND FOR MORE SERVICE
CONNECTIONS TO URBAN WATER
SUPPLIERS.
FURTHER THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES MUST CREATE ITS OWN
EMERGENCY PLAN IN COORDINATION
WITH THE SAME PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEM SB SIX SIX EIGHT HELPS
PREPARE THE STATE FOR DISASTERS.
BY EQUIRING.
I'M SORRY BY REQUIRING ALL URBAN
WATER SUPPLIERS TO KEEP THEIR
SYSTEMS PREPARED FOR THE WORST --
HERE WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE JACK
HAWKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS JENNIFER COMPETE TO LOW
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA WATER
SERVICE COMPANY HERE TO TESTIFY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- MY
NAME IS JACK WALKS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION -- SB SIX SIX EIGHT
WAS PROMPTED BY.
MANY THE WILD FIRES THE LAST
THREE YEARS IN A DEVASTATING
IMPACT THEY HAD ON A NUMBER OF
OUR MEMBER UTILITIES AND THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
AND THEY HAVE HAD -- TO ACTIVATE
THEIR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER IS MUCH MORE OFTEN THAN
ANY WHAT HE WOULD LIKE -- TO
HAVE TO DO AND THAT IS PROMPTED
TO CONSIDERABLE DISCUSSION ON
THE THESE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANS.
AND WHAT THIS BILL SO THAT WE
THINK THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP
FORWARD AND AND WILD FIRE
MITIGATION AND IMPROVING THE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PROCESS.
THIS BILL WILL DO TWO THINGS
FIRST IT WILL -- PUT.
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE ON A PAR.
WITH THE OTHER FOUR MAJOR
REQUIREMENTS OF URBAN WATER
SUPPLIERS -- RIGHT NOW -- ONE OF
THEM IS THE NEW CONSERVATION
REGULATIONS -- THAT WERE PASSED
LAST YEAR ANOTHER ONE IS THE
URBAN WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN SAID
URBAN WATER SUPPLIERS HAVE TO
SUBMIT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
THE THIRD ONE IS THE WATER
SHORTAGE CONTINGENCY PLANS THAT
HAVE TO BE PREPARED.
AND THE LAST ONE IS THE METERING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE COMING DUE
ALL OF THOSE -- APPLY TO URBAN
WATER SUPPLIERS THIS WILL NOW TO
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS IT SHOULD
BE RIGHT THERE WITH THE OTHERS
THE OTHER THING THIS IS BILL'S
GOING TO DO IS TO HELP
INSTITUTIONALIZE.
A GROWING -- PROGRAM CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA.
WHY -- WATER WASTEWATER AGENCY
RESPONSE NETWORK CAL WORN.
AND A NUMBER OF WATER SUPPLIERS
ESPECIALLY SMALLER ONES AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THIS.
PROGRAM -- IT'S A MUTUAL AID
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AMONGST
REGIONAL WATER.
SUPPLIERS ALL OVER THE STATE.
AND BY HAVING -- THIS BILL IN
STATUTE IT WILL ENABLE THESE
WATER SUPPLIERS TO INCORPORATE
CAL WORN INTO THEIR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLANS THAT CAN ONLY
BE GOOD SO -- WITH ALL OF THAT I
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
JENNIFER COMPETE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE COMPANY
THE SECOND LARGEST PUBLIC UNDER
FIRE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SERVING A LITTLE OVER TWO
MILLION -- THANKS -- WATER WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY A LOT
OF THE FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS FIRST BY
THE SKIN FIRING KERN COUNTY --
THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE IN
LAKE COUNTY THE CAMPFIRE AND
PARADISE AND THE WALLS THE FIRE
AND THOUSAND OAKS -- AND AT THE-HEIGHT OF THE WILL THE FIRE THE
FIRE FIGHTERS WILL TOTALING FIVE
TIMES MORE THAN THE AVERAGE
DAILY USE OF WATER -- FOR FIRE
FIGHTING CAPABILITIES THERE --
FORTUNATELY CAO WATER WAS ABLE
TO WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE WHOLESALE
WATER PROVIDER TO GET.
THERE WATER FACILITIES REFILLED
AND THAT WAS REALLY BECAUSE THEY
HAD A SOLID DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS PLAN IN PLACE THEY
KNEW HOW WHO TO CONTACT.
AND THEY WORKED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT INDIVIDUALS TO BRING
A MERGING SEE EQUIPMENT AND
PORTABLE GENERATORS OVER FIFTY
MILES -- TWO THOUSAND OAKS TO
HELP GET.
THE TANK BACK UP IN FULL AND GET
WATER PUMPING THROUGH THAT
SYSTEM AGAIN FOR FIRE FIGHTING
EFFORTS SO.
THEY FEEL LIKE THIS IS LIKE JACK
SAID THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP.
AND RECOGNIZING THE ROLE BETWEEN
WATER SUPPLIERS AND FIRE
FIGHTING CAPABILITIES AND JUST
REALLY DEALING WITH ANY OTHER
DISASTERS THAT COULD COME A LONG
WAY AS WELL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS THANK YOU.
FOR IN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED CORRECT.
RIGHT TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU.
SENATORS STERN JONES HI JONES I
ALLEN FORGES CABALLERO HERTZBERG
HUESO. FIVE HUESO AYE JACKSON
MONNING.
MONEY HI THE BILL IS ON CALL
THREE VOTES.
YOU HAVE THREE AYE VOTES IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE SUPPORT
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE DíAS
HERE SO.
WE'LL KEEP ON CALL FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS TO COME OUT ON THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD DAY.
I WAS LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR TO
PRESENT NEXT WILL THAT WILL TAKE
SENATOR MINING.
SB TWO HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER
.
TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- IN
MEMBER -- I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE AND
NOW SUS WANT TO THANK THE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
AS MANY OF YOU ARE NOW WELL
AWARE THEY'RE CLOSE TO ONE
MILLION OF OUR NEIGHBORS AND
CONSTITUENTS WHO LIVE EACH DAY
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO DRINK THE
WATER.
COMING OUT OF THEIR TAPS.
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY WHERE WE BOASTS THRIVING
TECH INDUSTRIES HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND PROGRESSIVE
SOCIAL PROGRAMS WE STILL HAVE
FAMILIES AND OVER THREE HUNDRED
COMMUNITIES.
FROM THE OREGON BORDER TO THE
MEXICAN BORDER FOR FORCED TO BUY
BOTTLED WATER TO DRINK BAYS AND
TO COOK WITH.
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS LONG
CALLED FOR THE CREATION OF A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE TO
ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING GAPS IN
FUNDING FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER
NEEDS.
THAT CANNOT BE FUNDED THROUGH
EXISTING BOND FUNDS.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED TAKES AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
IN REACHING THAT GOAL BY
CREATING THIS SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
STATE WATER BOARD.
OF THE LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU
TODAY DOES NOT IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
FUNDING SOURCE THAT WILL SOLVE
THE DRINKING WATER CRISIS IT
DOES CREATED NEEDED FRAMEWORK
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
RECEIVE IT MINISTER.
AND DISTRIBUTE FUTURE REVENUES
AND RESPONSIBLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER THAT WILL
PRIORITIZE SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY UNSAFE IN ON
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
ALL DISCUSSIONS ON HOW TO
ESTABLISH A LONG TERM AND
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
SAFE DRINKING WATER OUR ON GOING.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED IS A
CRITICAL PART IN ESTABLISHING
THE STRUCTURE AND FRAMEWORK AND
NEEDED TO GET THE FUNDS TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE
GREATEST NEED.
SPECTER THE ASKS THAT YOU JOIN
ME IN THIS IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD FINALLY REALIZING THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
IN CALIFORNIA WITH YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER
CHAIR WITH PERMISSION OF THE
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT OUR
TWO WITNESSES JENNIFER CLARY
WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION.
AND MELISSA ROMERO LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH.
HI MY NAME'S JENNIFER CLARION
THE WATER PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
CLEAN WATER ACTION FOR THE PAST
SIXTEEN YEARS I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO FIND SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR SMALL
COMMUNITIES.
I'VE TRACKED IT CLEAN WATER AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER FUNDS I'VE
TRACKED PROP FIFTY EIGHTY FOUR
ONE IN.
SIXTY EIGHT AND I DO WE'VE DONE
A LOT WE'VE ACTUALLY.
YEAH YOU NO LONGER HAVE TO PAY
BACK A PLANNING LOAN IF YOU'RE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY I MEAN IT
USED TO BE REALLY BAD.
BUT YOU SEE WE STILL HAVE THESE
PROBLEMS THAT SEEM INSOLVABLE SO
EMERGENCY FUNDING YEAH HE'S
PORTERFIELD WAS LUCKY BECAUSE WE
HAD A DROUGHT AND SO THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
WAS ABLE TO COME IN AND PROVIDE
INTERIM DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES
TO THAT COMMUNITY WHEN THEY RAN
OUT OF WATER -- LONG TERM
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE SO
OFTEN WE GET FUNDING TO SOLVE A
COMMUNITY PROBLEM WITHIN THEIR
WATER BILLS AND THAT BEING
BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
WHICH A COMMUNITY WITH AN INCOME
OF THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS HERE
CAN'T AFFORD AND THEN.
THE OTHER IDEA IS HOW DO WE TAKE
CARE PEOPLE ARE SERVED BY PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEM THAT'S BETWEEN A
MILLION AND A HALF IN TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS WE DON'T EVEN COUNT
THEM AND WE HAVE HOPE
COMMUNITIES.
IN THE CHOI LIKE BASS AND THEY
DID A SURVEY.
ALMOST 30% OF THE HOME CLUSTERS
THEY FOUND THEIR OF AT LEAST
FIFTEEN HOMES THE DEFINITION OF
A PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
BUT THEY WERE SERVED BY PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS YET CAN TO
COMMUNITY SIDE BY SIDE ONE
QUALIFIES FOR ASSISTANCE AND THE
OTHER DOESN'T EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAVE SIMILAR WATER NEEDS.
SO THE THIS.
THAT PROGRAM DEVELOPED --
OUTLINED IN SB TWO HUNDRED
REALLY IS LOOKING TO SOLVE THOSE
PROBLEMS AS THEY COME UP AND
PROVIDE THE FLEXIBILITY SO WE
CAN SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
KNOW ABOUT TODAY THE ONES THAT
ARE GOING TO COME UP TOMORROW
BECAUSE THOSE.
THOSE PROBLEMS CHANGE ALL THE
TIME SO THERE'S ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE RIGHT NOW WELL
THERE SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE. TWENTY NINE HUNDRED OF
THEM A COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
THAT SERVE DRINKING WATER TO
RESIDENTS AND SO.
WE THINK THREE HUNDRED TWENTY IS
A LOT BUT THERE'S A BIG
RESERVOIR SYSTEMS OUT THERE THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT UNDERSTAND
EVALUATE AND TRY TO FIX IF
NEEDED.
AND SO WHAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING.
FOR IF YOU HAVE A FLEXIBLE
PROGRAM YOU ALSO NEED ONE THAT
HAS A LOT OF OVERSIGHT.
I THINK THIS THIS LEGISLATION
DOES THAT IT REQUIRES AT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE A PUBLIC
ADVISORY COMMITTEE DIVERSE TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
AND THINKS THE AMENDMENTS FROM
YOUR YOUR COMMUNITY IT ALSO
REQUIRES -- IT ALSO REQUIRES
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT ANNUALLY
THANK YOU SO MUCH I HOPE WE GET
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS CALIFORNIA
HAS A DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT HAS
GONE TOO FAR FOR TOO LONG IN
THIS GREAT STATE.
BUT THIS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IS ASTOR HAS SOLUTION AND THAT'S
THE CREATION OF A SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND.
EXPOSURE TO UNSAFE LEVELS OF
DRINKING WATER CONTAMINATES
CONTAMINANTS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WHO DESERVE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER JUST AS MANY OF
US HERE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
HAVING WE GO HOME TONIGHT.
IT'S UNIMAGINABLE THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN FAMILIES AND DEVELOPING
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA STILL DO
NOT HAVE CLEAN DRINKING WATER AT
HOME OR AT SCHOOL.
THE COMMUNITY MEMBER SUFFERING
FROM CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER
HAVE COME HERE TO THE STATE
CAPITOL YEAR AFTER YEAR ASKING
FOR A SOLUTION.
AND THEY CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE BECAME
THE FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
RECOGNIZE THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER.
IN ORDER TO DELIVER ON THAT
PROMISE THE STATE NEEDS A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE THAT
WILL PROVIDE COMMUNITIES WITH
THOSE MUCH NEEDED DOLLARS FOR
OPERATION MAINTENANCE AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WHICH IS WHY WERE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND THE
COMPLEMENTARY LEGISLATION MOVING
TO THE ASEMBLY.
WHICH INCLUDES A NECESSARY
POLLUTER PAYS FEE INTO A FUN TO
GO TOWARDS CLEANING UP THESE
CONTAMINATED WATER SYSTEMS.
SB TWO HUNDRED OUTLINES THIS
BILL HOW THE FUND WILL OPERATE
INCLUDING A NEEDS ASSESSMENT
FULLY IDENTIFY THE EXTENT OF
CALIFORNIANS DRINKING WATER
CRISIS PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY TO
TAILOR SOLUTIONS ACCORDING TO
COMMUNITY NEED.
AND CIRCUMSTANCES AND IDENTIFIES
HIGH RISK AREAS AND INSURANCE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT TRANSPARENCY
AND OVERSIGHT.
PLEASE JOIN US AND SUPPORTING A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITNESSES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF
RURAL COUNTIES WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AND APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR AND DRIVING
THIS TO A SOLUTION THIS YEAR
THANK YOU.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HE'LL TELL HIM WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS DILIGENCE OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS THIS BE THREE
YEARS I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR FIVE YEARS -- AND WE SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY WE ASK YOU TO
MOVE FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION AGAIN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS DILIGENCE AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE INTENT OF THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THREE SEPARATE
VERGE ON BEHALF OF CERES THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS.
THE CALIFORNIA ADMINISTRATORS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
TURN MEMBERS JONATHAN NELSON ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER AND PLANNING CONSERVATION
LEAGUE AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
AND THINK THAT SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU -- THAT MC ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS CHIEF LINE STRONG SUPPORT --
BRIAN HISSED ALSO PART OF TO
LEARN THEM IN FULL SUPPORT.
CAN SHOULD NEVER HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING OUT
WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TIM VALDERRAMA WITH
THE VITAMIN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA NICE YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI JULIE JORDAN LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO ON BEHALF OF
POLICY LINK AND WESTERN CENTER
FOR LAW AND POVERTY -- AND STRT
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER RUNNING
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
GOOD MORNING TERRON MEMBERS FOR
SICK AND HER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB TWO HUNDRED AND THANK.
CENTER MINING FOR BEING A TRUE
CHAMPION ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
A MARTIN COUNTY WITH BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION FUNDS AND
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR RIVER MINISTER.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL CALIFORNIA
NEEDS CLEAN WATER FOR
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU.
HI TIFFANY IN REGISTER IN
SUPPORT FOR THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK.
HI JASMINE JOHNSON -- ON BEHALF
OF PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES AND
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THE END OF US IS
THAT CALIFORNIA ROOM TO TO
SCIENCE OF STRONG SUPPORT IT HAS
BEEN A PARTY FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KAREN BOOKIE WITH
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER WE ARE SO VERY
PROUD TO BE IN A STATE.
OF THE FIRST STATE TO RECOGNIZE
THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER THANK YOU
SENATOR MINING FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP OVER THESE PAST YEARS
AND PRIOR TYSON THIS ISSUE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE ARE AMERICA'S ON THE HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I'LL PUT IT ON THE ON BEHALF OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
AS WELL AS ON ONE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
LUCAS FOR ERICSSON HAVE THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTER MONNING
FOR YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
VETERAN JASON BRYANT'S
WESTERNIZED JERRY MEN THANKS
UNDERMINE AND NOW WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- IN THE COMMENTS
FROM THE DíAS -- MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
I APOLOGIZE.
MISTER RACES AGAIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE THAT COVERAGE I
MEAN FINISHES ITEM ROOM.
QUESTION AFTER YOU SIR OKAY GOOD
WILL WANT TO GO TO YOU THAN
TALKING HONORED DIFFERENT TO
DIFFER THANKS.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE THEME TODAY.
MISTER MONEY COUPLE CONCERNS --
AS IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED BY YOUR
WITNESSES THE FUNDING MECHANISM --
I RECEIVED A A PRETTY.
STRONG LETTER OPPOSITION FROM A
COALITION OF WATER AGENCIES IN
MY DISTRICT NOT JUST MY DISTRICT
BUT THAT REPRESENT -- EVERY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY RESIDENT AS A
MATTER OF FACT -- BUT I WANT YOU
KNOW I AGREE THAT A MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA DON'T HAVE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER THAT'S JUST
UNACCEPTABLE -- THE COULD YOU
SPEAK TO THE FUNDING -- SORES
AND AND MAYBE -- COMPARED IF YOU
CAN IF YOU KNOW THE THE DETAILS --
CENTER CABALLERO HAS A BILL SB
SIX SIX NINE THAT KIND OF DOES
THE SAME.
THING -- AND CAN SPEAK TO THAT
GREAT IF YOU CAN HEAR THEM AND I
DON'T I'M GLAD.
TO SO THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY AS MENTIONED DOES NOT
INCLUDE A SPECIFIC FUNDING
MECHANISM.
HOWEVER THE TRAILER BILL
REFERRED -- TO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
BY THE GOVERNOR THE ARCHITECTURE
THAT IS BASED ON A PRIOR BILL TO
SB TWO HUNDRED I THINK THAT'S
THE FOCUS OF SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION.
IN THAT ITERATION INCLUDES A
RATE PAYER COMPONENT IN AN
AGRICULTURAL FENIAN SOME
DIFFERENT -- POLLUTANT SOURCES --
THAT SIMEON -- THE UNIVERSE OF
LOOKING AT A FUNDING MECHANISM.
WHAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY DOES NOT
INCLUDE THAT FUNDING MECHANISM
BECAUSE THE DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES.
SIR REAL ENDEAVOR IN FRONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY.
IS ANTICIPATING.
AN ULTIMATE SOLUTION ON THE
FUNDING SOURCE TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE ARCHITECTURE WITH STATE
WATER BOARD WITH -- CITIZEN
OVERSIGHT AND ENGAGEMENT IN THE
MECHANICS AND AGAIN WITH THE
CHAIR PRESS AND I ALSO JUST WANT
TO THANK.
YOU IN IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE WORK IN TIGHTENING UP
SOME OF THESE MECHANISM SO I
THINK THE PROGRESS IN FRONT F
YOU TODAY -- IS REALLY ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE FUND MAKING
SURE THERE'S OVERSIGHT IN
IMPLEMENTATION THAT CAN BE DONE
IN A MANNER THAT WOULD RETAIN
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK MS
CLEAR SHE WITH PERMISSION OF THE
CHAIR SHE MIGHT ALSO LIKE TO
JUST ADDRESS THAT QUESTION.
SO -- THE THERE ARE SEVERAL
FUNDING MECHANISMS PROPOSED THE
OTHER ONE IN THE SENATE IS SB --
SIX SIX NINE OUR ORGANIZATION
HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
MISSION FOR BECAUSE FOR TWO
REASONS ONE BECAUSE WE DON'T
THINK THE FUNDING MECHANISM.
IS REASONABLE BECAUSE WOULD TAKE
ABOUT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
FUND TO ESTABLISH A TRUST FUND
AT THE LEVEL THAT WE THINK IS
NEEDED THAT WE'VE DONE RESEARCH
ON AND THEN THE OTHER PIECES IT
EXCLUDES.
DOMESTIC WELLS IN THE STATE'S
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND WE KNOW.
YEAH WE'RE NOT PLANNING TO GIVE
EVERYONE FREE WATER WE'RE
PLANNING TO LOOK AT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES DEPENDENT ON PRIVATE
WELLS AND SEEING HOW WE CAN HELP
THEM GET SAFE DRINKING WATER --
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I WILL SAY I
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOU.
BRING POLICY TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE AND LET THE BUDGET
WORK AT THE BUDGET STUFF I THINK
THAT'S IT I'VE GOT A BILL IN
ANOTHER COMMUNITY THAT'S TRYING
TO DO THE SAME THING -- ALTHOUGH
MY CONSTITUENTS WANT ME TO
OPPOSE THE BILL I'M JUST GONNA
LAY OFF TODAY I THINK.
AGAIN I AGREE WITH YOU A MILLION
PEOPLE WITHOUT WATER IS
ACCEPTABLE.
SHE THAT AGAIN.
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AGAIN
WITH THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
FOR TIGHTENING IT UP IN I'M.
WE WILL BE COMMUNICATING WITH
EVERYBODY AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE A SPECIAL
THANK YOU.
TO COMMITTEE CONSULTANT.
I THINK IT'S SAME INTENT.
LOT OF THE SAME MECHANICS BUT
JUST IT IT IT IT.
READS CLEAR I THINK YEAH I I
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF AND
YOU ALL WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS
I DID WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE SO I
I KNOW WE DIDN'T DRILL DOWN.
DEEPLY ON SOME OF THESE -- THESE
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION ISSUES BUT
AND I AND I KNOW WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT CAN YOU KIND OF
UPDATE US OR IN IN TERMS OF YOUR
THINKING.
I'LL JUST FLAG A FEW BUT THE THE
REGIONAL EQUITY QUESTION.
SERVICE HAS THINKING O ALL OF
THEIR THERE'S A MENTION ABOUT
THESE COMPLIANT BUT REALLY
EXPENSIVE SYSTEMS TRYING TO
THINK UP A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
AND THEN THIS.
THIS -- THERE THERE'S A FEW
OTHERS BUT LOW INCOME WATER
USERS.
I I'VE BEEN WRESTLING WITH HOW.
TO TRY TO TACKLE THE THE RATE
SIDE OF THINGS -- AND WHAT WHERE
THEY FIT SO YESTERDAY SO LET ME
TAKE A PERSON BACK AND THEN
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO INVITE OUR
WITNESSES IF THEY WANT TO WEIGH
IN ON IT -- AND I DO APPRECIATE.
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE ISSUES
SO THE GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY -- WE
THINK IS BUILT IN BECAUSE THE
PRIVATIZATION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND YOU'RE GONNA
FIND THOSE FROM THE OREGON
BORDER TO THE MEXICO BORDER.
YOU SOME PEOPLE THINK THIS IS
JUST A CENTRAL VALLEY PROBLEM
IT'S NOT THE COMMON DENOMINATOR
OF THESE THREE HUNDRED PLUS
WATER SYSTEMS.
IS BY DEFINITION.
THEY ARE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE INCOME ISN'T
ENOUGH. TO REMEDIATE OR PROVIDE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
BASED ON THE STRUCTURE OF THEIR
WATER RATES SO.
YOU COULD PUT WATER RATES UP TO
A THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH IN THOSE WATER BILLS
WOULDN'T GET PAID.
AND THOSE REPAIRS WOULD BE IN
DEFAULT WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS A
FALL CALIFORNIANS JOIN HANDS.
PITCH IN A DE MINIMUS AMOUNT.
WE CAN ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS.
PRIORITIZING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS DEFINED IN THE
BILL -- IN IS UNDERSTOOD.
BY THE WILL OF THE WATER BOARD --
SO THE GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY IS
GOING TO BE ROUTED IN THE
ECONOMIC EQUITY AND I THINK
YOU'LL FIND WELL WON'T BE.
IDENTICAL DISTRIBUTION AROUND
THE STATE IT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTION AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
LOW INCOME WATER USERS -- WE
EXEMPTS THEM.
GETTING INTO OUR FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT'S NOT BEFORE YOU
TODAY BUT JUST HOW WE TRY.
TO BRING SOCIAL EQUITY IN
ECONOMIC EQUITY.
OUR PRIOR VERSIONS HAVE PROVIDED
AN EXEMPTION FOR RATE EARS UP
22100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE -- COST STOPS THERE -- WE
IN THE FUND IT ALLOWS OBVIOUSLY
FOR STATE FUNDING FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING IT COULD IT COULD
ATTRACT NONPROFIT --
CONTRIBUTIONS PHILANTHROPIC
CONTRIBUTIONS WE WANT TO CREATE
A CATCH ALL.
THEN THE DISTRIBUTION MECHANISM
IS DEMOCRATIC HAS OVERSIGHT.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT WE
GO FOR WHAT WE CALL THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT FIRST WE THINK
WITH EARLY INVESTMENT IN.
CONNECTING SOME SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CLOSE TO A CLEAN WATER SYSTEM
THAT WOULD BE THE BEST
INVESTMENT OF THOSE DOLLARS AND
THE QUICKEST REMEDY FOR THOSE
WITHOUT CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
AS YOU GO UP THE LADDER YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOME MORE THE
INNER CORE MORE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT.
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION SAYS WHY
SHOULD THIS FUND TO BE USED FOR
CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
THIS FUND WE WANTED TO BE USED
TO GET PEOPLE CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER THE BIG GAP HAS
BEEN OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
BUT IN ONE COMMUNITY THERE MIGHT
BE PART OF THAT SOLUTION MIGHT
INCLUDE SOME CAPITAL INVESTMENT
OUR BILL DOESN'T PRECLUDE THAT
BUT LET ME SEE IF MS CURRIE
WANTS TO ADD TO ANY OF THAT --
WARMEST ROMERO FROM.
CO CV THANKS I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EXPENSIVE SYSTEMS HERE TALK
ABOUT WATER SYSTEMS.
HAVING A LARGE EXPENSE IN
DELIVERING WATER AND TYPICALLY
WHAT WE WOULD THINK IS THAT THE
WATER BOARD USUALLY GIVES OUT
CONTRACTS TO ENGINEERS IN THIS
CASE OPERATORS TO DO THAT RATHER
THAN THE WATER SYSTEM DIRECTLY
PAYING FOR IT.
YOU ALSO AT THE ANNOUNCES ALSO
ASKED ABOUT LOW INCOME RATE
PAYERS WHICH ARE FOUND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE BOARD UNDER LEGISLATION
AUTHORED BY SET BY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DODD -- IN WHAT WAS THAT --
TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN REQUIRES
THE STATE TO DEVELOP A LOW
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO WHAT ENERGY CUSTOMERS
ALREADY HAVE AND THAT WOULD COST
BETWEEN SIX AND SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THE
ESTIMATE SO -- WE'RE HAVING A
REALLY HARD TIME GETTING THIS
AMOUNT SO I THINK WE WANT A
LITTLE EXTRA TIME AND THOUGHT
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO FIND.
THE INDIVIDUAL RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT'S CONTINUES TO BE
RESEARCHED [inaudible]
MY MY MY INTEREST IN THAT LOW
INCOME RATE ISSUE IS.
BABY SOMEONE ABOUT THE STATE
WATER BOARD ACTION PENDING BUT
ALSO DEPENDING ON THE FUNDING
MECHANISM AND HOW THE FINAL VOTE.
IS ASSESSED TRYING TO MAXIMIZE
THE ABILITY EMPOWER SOME THESE
LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO SOLVE.
EQUITY CHALLENGES THAT THEY'VE
GOT THAT WON'T NECESSARILY ADD
COSTS TO THE LEGISLATION OR
REQUIRE AN APPROPRIATION OR EVEN
A STATE FEE BUT TRYING.
TO FIND DEAL WITH THIS SORT OF
BROADER RATE PRESSURE ISSUE THAT
WE HEAR FROM MACH ONE SOME OF
THE AGENCIES AND SO.
WE WE CAN KEEP SORT OF THAT KEEP
THAT ONE ON SIMMER AND AND AND
SEE OF THIS THING INVOLVES BUT I
I'M I'M I'M C<c.cyan> INTERESTED IN</c>
THAT AND THEN.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE ON THIS LOW
HANGING FRUIT A HOW DO WE SCOPE
THAT THEN THE SENATOR PUT IT
WELL BUT LIKE MORE GRANULARITY
ABOUT.
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE WHAT WHAT WE
COULD ANTICIPATE COMING WITH A
MECHANISM WE'VE GOT IN PLACE
HERE LIKE WHAT WHAT COULD WE SEE
IN THE FIRST?
COUPLE YEARS THE PROGRAM WHERE
ARE THE SUPER HIGH PRIORITIES
OUT THERE WHAT WHAT WHAT DOES
KIND OF EMERGES THE AS HE SAID
THE LOW HANGING FRUIT FOR NOW I
THINK YOU LOOK AT PLACES WHERE
YOU ALREADY HAVE INFORMATION SO
TWO THINGS ONE IS YOU START
GATHERING INFORMATION FOR
INSTANCE.
ON PRIVATE WELLS SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND AREAS THAT MIGHT NEED
A WARNING.
LETTER TO GO OUT NEXT YOU WANT
TO LOOK AT WHAT THE SENATOR
REFER TO WHICH IS CONSOLIDATION.
AND THERE ARE IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE WAY CALIFORNIA GROWS IT'S
GROWN AROUND THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES FOR DECADES SO THERE
ARE SOME CITIES.
THAT ARE SURROUNDED BY A SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS OUT OF COMPLIANCE
AND THOSE COULD BE EASILY HOOKED
UP SOME.
AS SIMPLE AS JUST TURNING AT
PIPE THE TURNING ON A THINK IT
AND OTHERS A SMALL PIPE OTHERS
IT'S A LTTLE MORE EXPENSIVE YOU
HAVE.
TO BUILD A LONGER PIPELINE.
BUT I THINK THAT IDEAS SOME OF
THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS WHERE
IT'S POSSIBLE INAPPROPRIATE
SHOULD PROBABLY NO LONGER EXIST
AND THE STATE BOARD THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE YOU GAVE THEM.
THE AUTHORITY TO MANDATE
CONSOLIDATION AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY'VE ONLY MANDATED A HANDFUL
OF CONSOLIDATIONS THAT THREAT
HAS LED TO A HUNDRED
CONSOLIDATIONS OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS.
SO IT IS HAPPENING NOW AND
HAVING MORE MONEY TO HELP PAY
FOR THE COST OF CONNECTION WILL
HELP SPUR MORE I THINK OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
AND WHILE I'VE GOT YOU HERE
THOUGHTS ON THE THE COMMENTS AND
ADDITIONAL LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
OPEN THIS THERE AND THEN ON THE
NONPROFIT DEFINITION.
I I DON'T NEED TO HOLD YOU TO IT
TODAY I JUST WANT TO GET SOME
FEEDBACK ON THE RECORD LOW WE
GOT WHAT WE GOT SOME EXPERTS IN
THERE SO WHAT WAS THE FIRST
QUESTION SIR -- FIRST ON THE
SORT OF LONG TERM SOLUTIONS AND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT.
YOU ARE THINK OUGHT TO BE
ELIGIBLE IN IN THERE.
I THINK IT'S ALL DRINKING WATER
A NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES IN IN
THIS ELECTION ON LONG TERM
DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS BUT THE
ANALYSIS MENTIONS.
WASTE WATER TREATMENT OTHERS OR
TO IMPACTS.
I JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE OF
HOW I THINK I THINK WHAT WE WANT
IS TO BE EXPANSIVE AND FLEXIBLE
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND IT'S TRUE
THAT -- FAILING WASTE WATER AND
SEPTIC SYSTEMS DO CONTAMINATE
WATER SUPPLIES IN SOME AREAS SO
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING I THINK
THAT IT'S ALREADY PERMITTED BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE AGAIN. TO MAKE IT MORE --
HERE AND THE SAME WITH THE
DEFINITION OF NONPROFIT WHAT WE
WANTED PEOPLE TO KNOW HOW TO DO
THE JOB AND ARE IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN DO IT.
AND HAVE THE HAVE THE FISCAL --
CAPACITY TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
PARTNERS -- WITH.
I THINK WE'VE WAITED ALL OUT
HERE PRETTY WELL I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR JUST DILIGENCE
ON THIS THE FEEDBACK WE'RE GONNA
STAFF SO LET'S KEEP WORKING ON
THIS I THINK WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING THIS YEAR.
THIS IS YEAH WE WE WE DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF SAID WELL.
MAYBE I'LL JUST MAKE THIS MY
CLOTHES IF YOU SEE THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE TIME -- THERE'S A
LOT OF FORCES PUSHING IN THE
SAME DIRECTION RIGHT NOW WE'RE
ENCOURAGED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
SUPPORT FOR SOLUTION.
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES -- AND
WE'RE GONNA KEEP PUSHING AND
MANY OF SAID THIS IS THE YEAR TO
GET IT DONE SO WE SEE THIS AS A
VEHICLE TO KEEP THAT MOMENTUM
GOING.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE MANY ORGANIZATIONS TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT TODAY THERE'S BEEN.
A GROWING COALITION FROM. TO
RURAL FROM ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
TO AGRICULTURE -- THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE PUSHING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION AND I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE -- THEIR CONTINUED
COMMITMENT AND PERSEVERANCE AND
WITH THAT WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M SORRY SENATE ALLEN YOU WANT
TO I JUST WANT TO COMMEND AND
CENTER MINE FOR THIS BILL AND I
THINK YOU KNOW I THINK YOU'RE.
TAKING THE RIGHT APPROACH HERE
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES INVOLVE
COMPREHENSIVE.
ADDRESSING OF THE OF THIS
ENORMOUS NEED AND IT'S IT'S
APPALLING THAT WE HAVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE IS -- AS PROGRESSIVE AS WE
ARE IN AND SO -- I JUST COMMEND
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ANDERSON IS CAN BE A LOT OF
NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
BUT I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW OF ALL THE IDEAS OUT
HERE I'M I'M MOST ON TRACK WITH
YOU.
THANK YOU AND THE RIGHT WAS THAT
A MOTION YES I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL.
GOOD -- HAD A CLOSE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK CENTER MINE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
STERN HI STERN AYE JONES ALLEN.
HI ELLEN AYE FORGES KIRBY EURO
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON I'D
MONEY.
MONEY HI IT HAS FIVE IT IS FIVE
IS REALLY THAT MEASURE A CALL
THANK CENTER THANK YOU.
WE GOT TO EUROPE.
ALLEN ALLEN JACKSON JACKSON
ALLEN [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT JUMP UP SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
I SENSE SOME [inaudible]
COMITY.
SHE'S TECHNICALLY I'M
[inaudible]
FOR THINK ABOUT [inaudible]
YEAH.
RIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT IN ORDER FOR
FATHER EVER TWELVE CORRECT SB
FIVE FIVE ONE THAT IS CORRECT
SHOULD STILL MOURNING FEELS LIKE
AFTERNOON BUT GOOD GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS - THIS
IS A SB.
FIVE FIFTY ONE A MEASURE THAT
DIRECTS THE DIVISION OF OIL GAS
AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES DARKER.
TO DEVELOP AN ACCOUNTING
MECHANISM FOR ASSESSING THE FULL
COSTS.
OF DECOMMISSIONING CLEANING UP.
AND REMOVING REMEDIATING OIL AND
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR STATE.
IN SHORT THIS BILL DIRECTS
DOCTOR TO GET IN FRONT OF A
PROBLEM THAT WITH NO QUESTION.
WILL RESULT IN ILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF LIABILITIES TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
UNLESS WE DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
FIRST [inaudible]
NOW.
MEMBERS THE PROBLEM OF
UNACCOUNTED FOR OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT A
HYPOTHETICAL.
INDEED THERE ARE SEVERAL
INDUSTRY TRENDS CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY.
THAT ARE RESULTING IN STRANDED
AND ABANDONED INFRASTRUCTURE.
OR IMPROPERLY CLEANED UP IN
REMEDIATED OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION SITES.
THESE TRENDS NOT ONLY INCLUDE
INCREASINGLY AGGRESSIVE AN
ACCELERATED PRODUCTION METHODS.
THAT ARE LEAVING SEVERAL WESTERN
STATE GOVERNMENT'S HOLDING THE
BILL.
REGARDLESS OR IF THEY'RE IN
COLORADO OR WYOMING THESE.
AND ARE RIGHT HERE IN OUR OWN
STATE.
AND THESE TRENDS ALSO INCLUDE
AND FACTOR IN OUR OWN AMBITIONS
CLIMATE GOALS.
WHICH CALL FOR A SWITCH.
FROM A OF FOSSIL FUEL BASED
ECONOMY TO A FOSSIL FREE.
BASED ECONOMY IN A MATTER OF
MERE DECADES.
AND IT BEARS REPEATING THIS
PROBLEM IS NOT HYPOTHETICAL.
WITH HAVING TO ASSUME THE
LIABILITY OF JUST TWO PIECES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BOTH IN MY DISTRICT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY ON THE HOOK TODAY. FOR
OVER ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IS LIKELY ON THE HOOK FOR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF MORE.
BY THE TIME THE DECOMMISSIONING
OF THESE TWO PROJECTS ONE IS
PLATFORM HOLLY.
IN THE SANTA BARBARA CHANNEL OFF
OF KALITA.
AND THE OTHER IS ON RING CONN
ISLAND A MAN MADE ISLAND -- THAT
IS -- IN VENTURA COUNTY.
THESE PRODUCT THESE BOTH THESE
ITEMS BOTH THESE.
HUGE INFRASTRUCTURES HAVE
DECLARED BANKRUPTCY.
AND THE STATE HAS BEEN HANDED
BACK THE DEED AND THE
LIABILITIES FOR CLEANING UP THE
MESS THAT THESE OIL COMPANIES
HAVE MADE OVER THE COURSE OF
TIME.
FROM WHICH THEY HAVE RECEIVED
PROFIT IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BUT I'VE LITERALLY.
NOW HELD AND PUT THE TAXPAYERS
OF CALIFORNIA RESPONSIBLE FOR
CLEANING UP THEIR MESS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS FRUSTRATING.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
NOW GRANTED NOT EVERY PIECE OF
OIL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE IS A
LARGE OFFSHORE FACILITY.
BUT WITH THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN THE COST SALINAS
INVOLVED WITH REMOVING
INDUSTRIAL INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S
NOT HARD TO IMAGINE.
THE SIZEABLE LIABILITIES THAT WE
WILL BE FACING IN THE COMING
DECADES.
BUT I DON'T WANT US TO JUST HAVE
TO IMAGINE THOSE ON PLAN
LIABILITIES AND BEYOND READY FOR
THEM.-WHEN THEY UNEXPECTEDLY HIT OUR
GENERAL FUND LIKE A MACK TRUCK?
WHAT I INSTEAD ASK IS I BELIEVE
EMINENTLY REASONABLE?
IT IS FOR OUR PRIMARY REGULATOR
OF OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION IN THE
STATE. TO DEVELOP A FUNCTIONAL
MECHANISM. TO ASSESS.
THESE EXPECTED COSTS SO THAT IT
CAN BEGIN TO COMPREHENSIVELY
MAKE ASSESSMENTS THE GUIDE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER
FINANCIALLY PLAN AND PREPARE.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE STRIDES TO DARKER HAS MADE
OVER THE YEARS THE RECENT YEARS.
IN ISSUING MORE COMPLETE PERMITS
THAT ACCOUNT FOR TAIL AND
LIABILITIES IN REQUIRING
OPERATORS TO BONTA LIMITS
ALLOWED BY STATE LAW AND IN
ADVOCATING FOR AND ADMINISTERING
STATE FUNDS TO DEAL WITH LONG
TERM PROBLEMS.
LIKE ABANDONED AND HAZARDOUS
WELLS AS WAS SEEN IN THE
LEGISLATION.
THAT WE DID A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THAT IS NOW PROVIDING SOME
RESOURCES TO REMEDIATE INTO CAP
ABANDONED WELL SPECIFICALLY.
THE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT OF THEM THAT CONTINUE TO
LEGAL OIL IN MY DISTRICT.
BUT THESE ARE STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT THEY ARE SMALL
STEPS PARTICULARLY GIVEN.
THE FOOT RACE WE ARE IN TO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS.
THE FUTURE CLEANUP COST THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS LIKELY TO
BE REQUIRED OR AT LEAST ASKED TO
BEAR [inaudible]
SO.
THE BILL MAY SEEM SMALL INTEREST
SET UP THAT INITIAL -- STRUCTURE
BUT IT LAYS AN IMPORTANT
FOUNDATION TO DEALING
RESPONSIBLY AND PROACTIVELY
WITHIN INEVITABLE CHALLENGE TO
OUR STATE.
AS FORMER STATE LANDS
COMMISSIONER GAVIN NEWSOM NOTED
IN RESPONSE DEPENDING
LIABILITIES TRUST IN SANTA
BARBARA.
HE SAID OUR EYES WERE NOT WIDE
OPEN IN TERMS OF ASSESSING THE
TRUE COST OF SHUTTING THESE
THINGS DOWN.
WHEN WE ORIGINALLY BONDED THESE
LEASES AND AS A CONSEQUENCE
THESE COSTS ARE ASTRONOMICAL?
THEY'RE ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
SO WITH ME TODAY.
I HAVE HEALTH ALFREDO DANDO WITH
THOSE TOOL AND BRIAN THE WIKI
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY TO PRESENT TESTIMONY.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHO HAS THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- SENATOR
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ON FOR A LITTLE KNOWN HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF US SOON.
AN ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
DEVELOPING LEVINE A LEADERSHIP
AND PERSPECTIVES ON OCEAN
CONSERVATION COASTAL PROTECTION
COASTAL ACCESS. TO WAS VERY
HAPPY TO PROVIDE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SENATOR JACKSON'S SB FIVE
FIVE ONE TODAY -- SENATOR
JACKSON'S ALREADY PROVIDED A
GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE RECENT
EVENTS -- THAT HAVE LED TO THE
STATE HAVING TO FOOT THE BILL
OVER OVER A HUNDRED EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. TO THE
COMMISSION PLAN FROM HOLLY IN
THE WELLS AT RINCON ISLAND IN
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTIES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE COSTS WILL ONLY COVER THE
PLUGGING INTO COMMISSIONING OF
THESE WELLS AND DO NOT YET
ACCOUNT FOR THE REMOVAL PLATFORM
HOLLY ITSELF.
WHICH HAS REFERENCE IS GOING TO
COST AN ADDITIONAL TENS OF
MILLIONS IN. TWO HUNDRED OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE -- I
WAS ORIGINALLY PLANNED TO SPEND
SOME TIME TALKING ABOUT THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN INVESTED IN -- YOU KNOW
WITH THAT HUNDRED MILLION --
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE CLIMATE
RESILIENT -- CLIMATE SMART
PROJECTS ALONG THE COAST -- BUT
INSTEAD -- I I WANTED TO SHARE
SOMETHING THAT I JUST SHARED
WITH COMMUNITY -- WHAT WAS YOUR
SHARED WITH THE COMMITTEE
HOPEFULLY ADDS TO THE FLAVOR
THIS DISCUSSION AND I THINK IN A
WAY THAT WILL LEAVE A VERY BAD
TASTE IN ONE'S MOUTH -- THE
BUDGET CHANGE POLLS OF THAT AND
THAT'S BEFORE YOU -- AND IT'S
GONNA BE DISCUSSED -- THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
SUBCOMMITTEE TO IS FROM THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION THAT
REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ON TOP OF THE
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION THAT WAS
GOT.
RECEIVED LAST YEAR -- FOR
ONGOING IN ENFORCING LITIGATION
COSTS RESULTING FROM MEDICAL SEE
WANTING THE STATE TO PAY IT
MONEY IN ORDER FOR THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO SAFELY PLUG INTO
COMMISSION PLATFORM HOLLY --
THERE'S ALSO A PORTION OF THE
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE USED TO
ATTEMPT SOME COST RECOVERY FROM
THESE COMPANIES -- BUT AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE THAT THAT'LL BE A
PRETTY TALL ORDER -- FOR THEM TO
TO SEE A PENNY COMING BACK TO
THE STATE.
AS A RESPONSE. TO REALLY TO PUT
A FINE POINT ON THIS ALLOW ME TO
PUT THIS DEVELOPING MY OWN WORDS
ANOTHER COMPANY THAT HAS HAD TO
FOLD WHEN THE GOING GOT TOUGH.
CITED A PICK UP SOME OF ITS TOYS
AND GO HOME.
LEAVING SOMEONE ELSE IN THIS
CASE THE STATE TO CLEAN UP AFTER
THEM AT A VERY HIGH COST AND IS
NOW ASKING THOSE THAT WILL DO
THE CLEAN UP. TO PAY THEM FOR
THE PRIVILEGE TO DO SO.
AS TO BELIEVE THAT THE EVENTS
SURROUNDING PLAN FROM HARLEY
VERY CLEARLY ARTICULATE AND MAKE
THE CASE AS TO WHY SB FIVE FIVE
ONE IS NEEDED.
AND WILL HELP ADDRESS SIMILAR
PROBLEMS IN THE FUTURE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE JUST OCCURRING OFF
SHORE BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT -- AS
AS POINT ON THE ANALYSIS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- WILL ALSO
HAPPEN ON SHORE -- WITH VERY
SERIOUS FISCAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
THESE REASONS -- WE THANK
SENATOR JACKSON FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND JR
AYE VOTE ON SB FIVE FIVE ONE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN A WEEK YOU
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY -- ALSO.
WANNA GET OFFERED THANKS TO
CENTER JACKSON FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR
THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR AND I
KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THIS --
THIS COMMITTEE HAS SPENT A GOOD
AMOUNT OF TIME -- INCREASING THE
OVERSIGHT OF AND I APPRECIATE
THAT -- AS CENTER JACKSON
ALREADY LAID OUT THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY HAS A LEGACY OF IMPACTS
TO THE AIR WATER LANDSCAPING
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE LEGACY CONTINUES TO THIS
DAY -- IN IN MANY CASES AS WE
JUST HEARD OIL COMPANIES HAVE
NOT.
TAKEN RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
FULL COSTS OF ALL OF THAT DAMAGE
LEAVING ABANDONED WELLS OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ITS WAKE --
THAT CAN.
CONTINUE AND I'M GOING BASIS TO
POLLUTE GROUND WATER SERVICE
WATER AND THE AIR -- UNDER
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS A SINGLE
WELL CAN BE COVERED BY A BLANKET
BOND THAT APPLIES TO AN ENTIRE
WELL FIELD IN THAT CASE STATE
LAW WOULD REQUIRE A BOND OF TEN
TO TWENTY MILLION. TO COVER
FIELDS WITH HUNDREDS OF WELLS
EVEN THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
PERMITTED FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
WELL MAY NOT BE ENOUGH.
IN EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THERE ARE MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND OIL AND
GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE ALL OF
THE ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE
THE PIPES IN AND OUT IN
DIFFERENT FACILITIES ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE SO QUARTER OF A
MILLION.
OVER THE PAST DECADE AND A HALF
DUGGAR HAS HAD TO PLUG SOME SIX
HUNDRED ABANDONED WELLS AT AN
AVERAGE COST OF AT LEAST THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER WELL.
NEITHER THE UPDATED INDIVIDUAL
THEIR BLANKET FEES PROVIDE.
THAT HAVE RECENTLY BEEN UPDATED
BY DUGGAR PROVIDE EVEN HALF THE
COST FOR REQUIRED TO PLUG
TYPICAL WELL IN THAT IS JUST
PLUGGING THE WELL NOT REMOVING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REMEDIATING
THE SITE.
SB FIVE FIVE ONE WOULD REQUIRE
DUGGAR TO DEVELOP A MECHANISM
FOR ASSESSING THE FULL COST OF
DECOMMISSIONING AND REMOVING
INFRASTRUCTURE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THE LOCATION OF
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND OTHER RELEVANT FACTORS THAT
MAKE INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIFIC
COST ESTIMATES THERE IS GREAT
NEED.
IN OUR OPINION FOR STRONGER
OVERSIGHT GUIDANCE IN PLANNING
AND WELL REMEDIATION BUT THE
BARE MINIMUM MUST BE TO MAKE
SURE THAT COSTS.
OF REMOVAL AND REMEDIATION ARE
UNDERSTOOD BY THE STATE AHEAD OF
TIME SB FIVE FIVE ONE IS A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP TOWARD
PROTECTING AGAINST IN RECOVERING
FROM THE DAMAGES OF OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND ASKS YOU TO
DO SO AS WELL.
THANK YOU. ONE OF THE MADE ON A
WITHOUT A ONE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS HERE CUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OKAY.
WE HAVE A FULL TIME POSITION TO
THE BILL.
I WANT TO COME UP HERE AND
PRESENT.
THE MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- ANTHONY THOMAS.
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION.
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. FIVE FIVE
ONE MEMBERS -- THE GOALS OF THE
BILL HAVE BEEN STATED FOR THE
MOST PART BUT IF I CAN TAKE YOU
TO SECTION.
ONE OF LINE THREE EIGHT INCLUDES.
A PLAN FOR DOGGETT MUST DEVELOP
A MECHANISM THE TERM MECHANISM
HAS BEEN USED.
THIS MORNING TO ASSESS THE
FOOLED.
CASA DE COMMISSIONING CLEAN OF
REMEDIATION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
RELATED TO THE INDUSTRY --
EXCEPT TRUTH HOWEVER THE BILL
LOOK FAILS TO SPELL OUT WHAT THE
MECHANISM WILL BE.
THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE AND I
WILL GET BACK TO THAT IN A
SECOND.
IT FAILS TO SPELL OUT WHAT THE
MECHANISM WILL BE.
I'M SAYING THAT MY MEMBERS DO
POLLS BONDS CURRENTLY FOR THINGS
SUCH A SPILL CLEAN UP.
CITY FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS IDA
WELLS ANOTHER REQUIREMENTS
BONDING FOR THIS FOR FOR
MEDIATION IS ESTIMATED BY DOGGER.
IS LIKELY IN A REALISTIC ALSO A
PESSIMISTIC STANCE.
IT ALSO OCCURS THE INDUSTRY THAT
SOME LOCAL AGENCIES DO SEEK TO
RETIRE FOR PRODUCTION THROUGH
AMBER'S A TATIAN.
THEY DEEM EXISTING OPERATIONS AS
NON LEGAL CONFORMING THE CLEAR
OF VALUE TO THE NON CONFORMING
ELEMENTS THEN LIMIT THE
MUNICIPALITIES LIABILITY. TO THE
DECLARED VALUE.
THE BILL READS LIKE A PRECURSOR
TO LIMITING LOCAL LIABILITY
AGENCIES AGENCIES LOCAL
LIABILITY.
GOOD FOR BILL ON ORDINANCE WERE
ADOPTED THEN LATER CHALLENGED BY
THE INDUSTRY COURTS COULD COURTS
COULD POINT TO DOGS ESTIMATED.
ESTIMATED DECOMMISSIONING COSTS
AS ONE DATA POINT UPON WHICH TO
LIMIT THOSE DAMAGES.
THE BILL WE SEE IS ROCKED WITH
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS HOW WILL THEY
ARRIVE AT THE FULL COSTS WILL
LAY ARRIVED AT THE FULL WHEN
WHEN THEY ARRIVE AT THE COLORFUL
COSTS.
HOW DO YOU READ OR DRESS ITEMS
AT IS DATA SERVICE ON WE WANT
TO KEEP IT ROLLED PAT STORAGE
AREAS OR WELLS?
WHAT IS MEANT BY REMEDIATION
AGAIN THERE'S NO DEFINITION HERE
IN THE BILL?
WHAT ABOUT DUPLICATION OF
FEDERAL LEASES?
WHO AT DOG HAS THE ABILITY OR
THE KNOWLEDGE TO IDENTIFY COST
TO REMEDIATE WE COULD GO ON --
BUT THE BILL LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ANOTHER SEATING OF AUTHORITY TO
AN APPOINTED BODY WHOSE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE VOTING
PUBLIC.
IS NONEXISTENT FOR POLICY ACCESS.
THIS PATH OVER TIME DOES THE
MINISTER CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY OF AN ELECTED BODY.
AS I CLOSE IF THE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS STATES THAT THE BILL IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS.
THAT'S WHAT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SAYS IN A MAKE SEVERAL
SUGGESTIONS TO MAKE THE BILL
WORKABLE.
IF A BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
MEMBERS IT SHOULD NOT PASSED OUT
OF ANY POLICY COMMITTEE FOR THAT
STATED REASON ALONE A WORK.
IN PROGRESS WHEN THE BILL IS NOT
READY IT'S AN INCENTIVE FOR BOTH
PROPONENTS ANY OPPOSITION TO
WORK ON IT TO MOVE IT OUT OF THE
POLICY COMMITTEE ITSELF.
OTHERWISE THE PROPONENTS HAVE
LITTLE INCENTIVE TO HEAR THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS DUE TO NO
ONE AT THE BILL WILL MOVE IN ANY
WAY.
IT IS OBVIOUS THAT SB FIVE FIVE
ONE IS NOT READY AND SHOULD BE
HELD IN COMMITTEE UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS IT IS FIT TO MOVE.
WE WOULD OR TO KNOW.
FOR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HEALY
GARCIA FOR THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
WE SHARE A LOT OF THE SAME
CONCERNS AS MY COLLEAGUE HERE
FROM -- FROM SUPER.
CLEARLY THE BILL I A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
OF RAISING THE ANALYSIS IN TERMS
OF THE A LACK OF DEFINITION --
FOR MECHANISMS -- WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT WHAT WE ARE.
DEVELOPING IS POTENTIALLY A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
PROVIDING -- SUFFICIENT
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES AND THAT
MAY BE A PROBLEM -- IT WILL BE
PROBLEMATIC IF WE ARE NOT CLEAR
IN TERMS OF THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN.
THIS MECHANISM -- AND EXISTING
FINANCIAL SERVICE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE IN PLACE IMPOSE
SOMETIMES BY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
SITE SPECIFIC.
PROJECT SPECIFIC AND IN ADDITION
TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTION --
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE REQUIREMENTS
OUR MEMBERS MAINTAIN THEIR OWN
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS -- THAT
THEY MAINTAIN -- WHETHER THEY BE
FUNDING LETTERS OF CREDIT --
GUARANTEES AND THEY ALSO THAT
DISTILLING IMPOSE SOME OF THOSE
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES AS PART OF
THEIR TRANSACTIONS WHEN THEY
CELL PRODUCTION ASSETS. TO A
SUBSEQUENT PARTY.
SO THERE'S A LOT -- THAT.
NEEDS TO BE WORKED THROUGH.
WHAT IS THIS MECHANISM AS
IDENTIFIED IN THIS COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS LOTS OF QUESTIONS HERE?
BUT ALSO.
WE HOPE SOME.
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF THE
EXISTING FINANCIAL ASSURANCES --
BOTH HELD BY THE STATE AND IN
PRIVATE HANDS -- SOME OF THE THE
PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPED
AND FLESHED OUT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS -- AS A COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES NOTES THERE'S BEEN.
A LOT OF ADDITIONS TO THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT OUR MEMBERS
ARE WISSMANN MEMBERS OF WORK
CONSTRUCTIVELY WITH.
THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH
REGULATORS -- TO ENHANCE.
SO AGAIN AT THIS POINT WE WE
HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL IT IS
FAR FROM BEING FLUSHED OUT.
WE UNDERSTAND -- I THINK THE THE
ISSUES THAT SENATOR JACKSON'S
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT --
THE STATE BUDGET HAD TO JUMP IN
LAST YEAR.
AND THEN AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
SET OF FACTS BUT SOMETIMES BAD
FAX.
CAN LEAD US TO MAKE BAD LAW
WHICH ONE BE CAREFUL ABOUT HOW
WE RESPOND.
TO A NARROW SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES --
THE PANIC OF SITUATION AND
OTHERS -- BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE EXISTING FINANCIAL
CHURCHES ARE IN PLACE -- IMPOSED
BY STATE LOCAL AND BY OPERATORS.
SO AGAIN AT THIS TIME WE WE HAVE
TO OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO RAISE OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
OKAY THE MEASURE FOR THE
COMMITTEE I WILL SAY ON HIM MY
MY GOOD FRIEND ANTHONY.
IF IF THE LEGISLATURE.
REFUSED TO PASS BILLS OUT OF
COMMITTEE THAT WERE WORKS IN
PROGRESS -- WE PROBABLY HAVE
ABOUT A TEN TO THE BILL'S MAKE
THEIR WAY OUT OF COMMITTEE -- SO
MAYBE THAT BIG THING WHO KNOWS
BUT I'M.
YEAH BUT EVEN AROUND THE BILL HE
WANTED US TO KNOW THAT A WORK IN
PROGRESS IS NOT A FACTORY WORKER
IS NOT A SCENE IS A AS A REASON
NOT TO TO PASSA BILL OUT BUT I
I GET I GET THE CONCERNS THAT.
AXING SENATOR THE TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU I HAVE BEEN AROUND
AWHILE AND AND AND IF I COULD
JUST GO BACK TO THE YEARS OF A
GENTLEMAN NAMED JOHN VSCONCELOS.
AND I WILL MAKE THIS VERY QUICK
I WAS HE WAS THE CHAIR OF WHAT
IS CALLED THE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE WHICH IS NOT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SOUL MR VASCONCELOS WAS CHAIRING
HIS COMMITTEE ONE OF HIS CAUCUS
MEMBERS CAME IN AND SAID.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I HAVE A BILL
THAT IS NOT QUITE READY HE CUT
THE MEMBER OFTEN SAID YOU HAVE
TWO OPTIONS TO LEAVE THE
BUILDING COMMITTEE OR TO TAKE IT
WITH YOU.
MY POINT IS WHEN YOU PASS A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
FROM THIS POLICY COMMITTEE
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT IS NOT
READY IT TOOK HIM TO SENDING A
CHILD TO SCHOOL WITH THE SMALL
COAL.
HERE SHE IS NOT READY THE BILL
IS NOT READY ANY POLICY
ENVIRONMENT SENATOR THAT'S ARE
YOU SUPPOSED TO TALK ABOUT IN
DISCUSS CAN WORK ON A POLICY
ISSUE.
YOU DON'T SEND IT THROUGH AGAIN
IT DISINCENTIVE VICES.
THE AUTHOR FOR THE PROPONENTS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WORKING
THROUGH THE PROCESS NOW IT MAY
BE THAT WAY NOW BUT IF YOU IF
TIMELINE HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE.
I WOULD LEAN ON THAT PERSPECTIVE
ONE GOOD POLICY I I I I I DON'T
I MEAN I I A YES SIR I DON'T
HAVE AN INTERN WITH ME BUT I
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTING TO SEE
IF THE TWO OF YOU IT MAY BE OF
SUPPORTING THE BILL ONCE.
IN THE PAST IT WASN'T IT WASN'T
FULLY COOKED -- AT ANOTHER
COMMITTEE ABOUT IT BUT I I NEVER
HAPPENED BY THE WAY ALRIGHT I
FIVE YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I I
I I I I GET YOUR POINT I WILL
SAY THAT YOU KNOW -- IT IS
INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW I'M HERE WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT THAT YOU KNOW I THINK
HAS A VERY IF ANYTHING
DEPARTMENTS OFTENTIMES
CRITICIZED FOR BEING. TOO CLOSE
TO THE INDUSTRY -- I MEAN YOU
EAT.
BUT I I DID THESE ARE FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND AND GET THE WORK DO
YOU DO AND I DON'T I I MEAN I I
UNDERSTAND YOU MAY BE CONCERNED
ABOUT VARIOUS.
ASPECTS OF THE BILL BECAUSE IT'S
IT IS A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT BUT
IT'S PRECISELY UP AT A
DEPARTMENT LIKE THIS THAT IS SO
WELL INFORMED AND UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS UNDERSTANDS.
THE OIL EXTRACTION BUSINESS --
THAT YOU WANT THEM TO BE MAKING
THESE KINDS OF ASSESSMENTS AS
OPPOSED TO THE LEGISLATURE WHICH
IS YEAH A BUNCH OF FOLKS WORKING
WITH THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR HEADS
CUT OFF TRYING TO WORK ON A
HUNDRED DIFFERENT ISSUE AREAS IT
EVERY DAY.
SO -- YOU KNOW THAT IS PRECISELY
WHY WE HAVE.
DEPARTMENTS LIKE DOCTOR OUT
THERE -- TO YOU KNOW TO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN THE KNOWLEDGE -- TO
TO IT TO HIM OF THESE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT'S WHY I'M I'M IN A
PARTIAL TO TO THE TO THE BILL
BUT I UNDERSTAND IT'S A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE WITH THE AUTHOR WANTS TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS.
YES THE THAT THERE CERTAINLY IS
WORK TO BE DONE I KNOW THE
OPPOSITION CAME IN AND TENS JUST
BEFORE WE WENT ON OUR BREAK THE
BILL'S BEEN IN PRINT SINCE
FEBRUARY SO -- CLEARLY THERE IS --
AND AND AS WAS POINTED OUT MOST
BILLS WE THEY ARE WORKS IN
PROGRESS -- THERE'S A TACTICS
SOMETIMES OPPOSITION USES WHICH
IS THE DELAY IN HOPE THAT A BILL
CAN'T GET OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
THEN IT'S DEAD FOR THE YEAR SO.
MOVING THE BILL WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE.
IN THE PROCESS WE GOT SOME GOOD
SUGGESTIONS AND OBSERVATIONS IN
THE ANALYSIS WE ARE.
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH DR --
AND TO DEVELOP A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT IS THERE
IS A CURRENTLY A PROGRAM CALLED
CAMP T..
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THE
ACRONYM IS BUT IT BASICALLY
ALLOWS FOR THE ASSESSMENT.
OF MINES ABANDONED MINES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT MIGHT BE.
AN APPROACH METHODOLOGY THAT
WILL WANT TO USE HERE -- AND AND
CERTAINLY ONE THAT -- I THINK
HAS SOME MERIT TO IT AND IS THE
BILL PROCEEDS I THINK BASICALLY
THE FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
THIS BILL.
ARE ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
WHEN I HEAR THAT THE?
INDUSTRY THE ORAL INDUSTRY SAYS
THAT THEY OF THEY HAVE MADE
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES.
CLEARLY THE FACT THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY HAD TO
PUT DOWN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND HAS BEEN ASKED TO
PUT DOWN FOR MILLION MORE. FOR
LITIGATION -- BECAUSE THE
COMPANIES SAID OF ABANDONED
THESE WELLS WANT THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO PAY. TO MAINTAIN
THEM WHILE THEY ARE BEING DE.
I'M I FIND IT ACTUALLY KIND OF
AN OUTRAGE TO THE STATE THAT
WOULD THAT THOSE THAT THE
TAXPAYERS ARE HAVING TO PAY.
THE OIL INDUSTRY EXPENSES AFTER
THEY HAVE.
TAKEN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PROFIT INTERESTS LITERALLY
WALKED AWAY IT'S LIKE THE CHILD
WHO.
DOESN'T WANT TO CLEAN UP THE
ROOM AND SAYS YOU DO IT FOR ME.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'VE
GOT HERE SO THE PRINCIPLE I
BELIEVE IS AN APPROPRIATE -- ONE
WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH IT -- THIS ISSUE WE
HAVE HAD LEGISLATION I WOULD
LIKE.
TO WE KNOW THAT THE CENTER
HERTZBERG IS DONE WITH SOME
LEGISLATION TO INCREASE THE
BONDING COSTS TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE EXPANSIONS OF OIL
DRILLING BUT THAT ISN'T ENOUGH
THAT ISN'T GOING.
TO COVER THE COSTS OF
DECOMMISSIONING IT'S A
MAINTAINING THEM SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL -- TRIES TO SET UP
THAT METHODOLOGY SO THE GOING
FORWARD PERHAPS THE STATE CAN
RECOUP SOME OF THOSE COSTS
RATHER THAN.
HAVE THE OIL INDUSTRY CONTINUE
JUST TO WALK AWAY AND LEAVE THE
THE TAX PAYERS CALIFORNIA
HOLDING THE BACK HE SAID I WILL
PUT IT IS THIS IS THIS IS YOUR
FIRST COMMITTEE RIGHT THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THAT.
STILL A LONG WAY TO GO AND A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOR
EVERYONE AWAY AND CENTER
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON WIENER
STAND IS HOW ALL THIS WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
SOLVES THIS PET PLATFORM HOLLY
PROBLEMA AB.
APOLOGIES AND FOCUS OF ATTENTION
EARLIER BUT WHEN I WAS HERE THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAD THE HORRIBLE
SITUATION PLATFORM HOLLY.
AND WHAT WE LEARN WE LEARN THE
COMPANY FILED BANKRUPTCY UNDER
BANKRUPTCY LAWS NO MATTER HOW
OLD THEY ARE WHAT THEY ARE.
THERE WERE STOCK FOR STOCK RIGHT
BECAUSE IF THEY POLLUTE THE
ENVIRONMENT SOMEBODY GOES
BANKRUPT THERE'S NO WAY TO GO UP
THE LIABILITY CHAIN WERE IN
TROUBLE.
SO THE NEXT YEAR AS A RESULT OF
THE VARIOUS MEETINGS THAT WE HAD
WE CREATED A PROCESS TO CREATE
AN ASSESSMENT TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF THE BOND BECAUSE WE'RE
FINDING IS THAT THE BIG WEALTHY
OIL COMPANIES WERE SELLING OFF
THESE.
THESE FACILITIES WHEN THEY'RE ON
THE TAIL END THE COMPANY'S A
DIDN'T HAVE SIGNIFICANT BALANCE
SHEETS SIGNIFICANT THOSE
COMPANIES WOULD GRAB WITH THE
GRAB FILE BE QUE.
AND WE WERE LEFT EXPOSED HENCE
WHY WERE IN THE SITUATION FOR
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PLUS
MILLION DOLLARS AND PLATFORM ALI.
AND HENCE WHY WE DID LEGISLATION
WITH THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
TO BE ABLE TO TO DEAL WITH THAT
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET TO IS
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN
TERMS OF THE UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE THE FINANCIAL RISK.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW
HAVING A PLAN DOES ANYTHING
BECAUSE THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS WHEN YOU SEE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE GONNA GET HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THEY'RE GONNA GET
ACCOUNT IS GOING TO HELL LIKE
WE'RE SEEING IN THAT THEIR
BANKRUPTCIES WITH OTHER.
PUBLICLY RELATED ENTITIES HOW TO
HAVING A PLAN WHAT YOU NEED IS
MORE COVERAGE MORE PROTECTION
LESS THOUGHT MORE THORNY IT
SEEMS TO ME TO MAKE SURE THAT
BEFORE YOU APPROVE A TRANSFER.
YOU MAKE SURE SOMEBODY HAS A
BALANCE SHEET THAT IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM YOU CAN PAY FOR IT RIGHT
AND WHO CARES IF A IF A BOND IS
TEN X. OVER ABOVE WITH THE
ACTUAL LIABILITY IS.
SPENDING MONEY TO DO THIS SEEMS
TO ME -- THE IDEA IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THE TWENTY SEVEN WELLS
IS NO QUESTION THAT WE SOUGHT
HAPPENED WE BOTH WERE INVOLVED
WITH IT.
BUT I'M TRYING TO GET TO HOW
HAVING ANOTHER STUDY IN ANOTHER
ASSESSMENT GETS THIS I'D RATHER
HAVE AN APPROVAL PROCESS BEFORE
WE ALLOWED THESE PHONY TRANSFERS
TO HAVE.
THAT WE MADE SURE WHOEVER THE
NEW ENTITY WAS HAD SUFFICIENT
CAPITAL RESERVES AND OR BOTH BE
INSURANCE OR BONDS OR WHATEVER
THAT.
THEY GET A CLEAN UP TO THE
STANDARDS THAT THE BIG STORY FOR
QUITE A I KNEW YOU WERE GOING TO
HIT THAT ONE IT IS LIKE THAT --
BUT BUT THAT'S ANOTHER BILL
THAT'S ANOTHER BILL WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS BE ABLE TO ASSESS.
THE VARIOUS ON SHORE AS WELL AS
OFFSHORE WELLS ARE OUT THERE --
TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE FULL SCOPE
OF POTENTIAL LIABILITY ARE
WORKING IN CONJUNCTION THIRD
THEY'RE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
WORKING IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
NOTION THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
START SEEING TRANSFERS OR FOR
GOING TO SEE EXPANSION.
OF OIL DRILLING THAT WE TRY.
TO ANTICIPATE POTENTIAL FUTURE
LIABILITY SO THAT WE CAN EITHER
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL BONDING OR WE
CAN TAKE OTHER MECHANISMS THAT
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW -- THE BONDING DOESN'T
NECESSARILY ADDRESS ALL THE
ASPECTS WHEN THEY'RE DE
COMMISSIONED.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT DATA IN THIS SET UP THAT
METHODOLOGY SO THAT AT LEAST WE
HAVE THE INFORMATION THEY WILL
BE FOLLOWING TO A STEP
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT I HOPE.
THAT WILL BE TAKEN BUT THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP TO AT LEAST BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
POTENTIAL LIABILITIES ARE AND I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE I'D
LIKE TO SEE.
WHEN THE NOTION THAT WE'RE STUCK
WITH PLATFORM HOLLY AND THAT THE
STATE IS PAYING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS?
BECAUSE THE COMPANY THAT NOW ON
TO DECLARE BANKRUPTCY IN THE
BONDING WASN'T LARGE ENOUGH IS
IT CHOSE CORALS.
THE HAIR ON MY BACK I CHOSE
STUFF.
I I JUST FIND IT SO OFFENSIVE --
BUT THAT IS AS YOU SAY THEY'VE
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY BUT GOING
FORWARD PERHAPS WE CAN BE BETTER
PREPARED THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IT'S ONE OF THE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG. FOR THE THOUGHTS OKAY
I OKAY I JUST HAVE YES CENTER
WEST OF THIS GENERALLY -- WE'VE
GOT A HAVE YOU KNOW.
WE'VE WE'VE ADDRESSED --
CONTAMINATION IN OUR STATE
THROUGH FEDERAL SUPERFUND SITES
[inaudible]
WHERE REGARDLESS OF WHO OWNS THE
PROPERTY CURRENTLY THAT YOU
COULD GO BACK AND TITLE?
AND INVESTIGATE WHO USED TO BE
THE OWNER AND WHO ACTUALLY
BECAUSE THE CONTAMINATION AND
ACTUALLY.
TAKE SPECIFICALLY GALACTION
GOING TO CONSERVE PEOPLE MY
SUSPICION IS THAT IN AND IN THE
CASE OF OF HOLLY.
THAT THE PREVIOUS OWNERS SOLD
MADE A TON OF MONEY.
SOLD TO A SHELL CORPORATION THAT
DIDN'T HAVE ASSETS [inaudible]
AND WHAT THE WHAT THE SIMPLE --
A STRATEGY TO BASICALLY.
REMOVE THEMSELVES OF A LIABILITY.
AND OF A RESPONSIBILITY.
SO CAN WE USE THE SUPERFUND
MECHANISM TO KIND OF SU.
THE OWNERS OF THE PREVIOUS
OWNERS OF HOLLY AND HAVE THEM
CLEAN IT UP WELL THAT'S
SOMETHING IS WE LOOK IN A SENSE
WHAT THE COSTS ARE IS IT THE
PROBABLY A GOOD QUESTION
UNFORTUNATELY IS /
KNOW -- THE SUPER FUND -- SYSTEM
IS NOT BEING FUNDED BY THE FED
SO WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF THE
SUPERFUND SITES CONTINUING. TO
MAINTAIN THE LEVELS OF TOXICITY
IN DANGER TO OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THAT -- THAT WE'RE SEEING THAT'S
A THE SUBSET OF LAWS THAT ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO SEEK DAMAGES YES.
YES AND AND I YOU KNOW I I
SUPPORT THIS WORK AND I JUST
THINK THAT THE THE INDUSTRY'S
BRINGING THIS UPON THEMSELVES.
BUT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO
TRY OUR STATE AND AND I I I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH THE
COMMENTS OF OF CENTER HERTZBERG
AND AND HOW HE CHARACTERIZED THE
NATURE OF THE PROBLEM AND I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU. TO
LOOK AT DIFFERENT WAYS ON HOW WE
CAN -- PURSUE THIS INCLUDING.
OPENING UP THE ABILITY TO GO
AFTER PREVIOUS OWNERS.
WELL I KNOW HAT THAT IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING AND THAT IN FACT THE
ORIGINAL OWNER DID HAVE A A BOND
THE RICH ALONE I BELIEVE THIS
ONE OF THE LARGE.
OIL COMPANIES AND AS YOU SAID
THEY KEEP SELLING THEM DOWN THE
ROAD FOR SOMEWHERE IN THERE
SOMEBODY MADE AN ENORMOUS PROFIT --
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT CAN BE
THROUGH A KIND OF AN EVENT ENTRY
PROCESS THE PROBLEM IS SAID THE
CURRENT OWNER IT IS -- DECLARED
BANKRUPTCY THE PRIOR OWNER THAT
WE DISCOVERED THAT THE BONDING
WHICH WAS DONE PROBABLY FORTY
YEARS AGO WAS WHOLLY INADEQUATE
TO COVER THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT TODAY -- AND I'M SURE
THERE'S LITIGATION GOING.
ON THAT ISSUE BUT THIS IS
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AS
WE TRY TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
YES THIS INDUSTRY IS NOTORIOUS
FOR ITS UNWILLINGNESS TO TAKE.
RESPONSIBILITY WHETHER
ENVIRONMENTALLY OR FINANCIALLY I
SEE THE TEARS ON HERE BUT I I
DON'T KNOW THE STATE OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE --
BUT SEEING THAT IT IT IS A
MENTALLY WORK IN PROGRESS I CAN
HEAR YOU.
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ABSOLUTELY TO MAKE SURE WE FLUSH
OUT SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT AND
RAISED AND YOU KNOW I KNOW I
UNDERSTAND YOU NEVER GONNA COME
TO A COMBINED A MOMENT WITH THE
OPPOSITION BUT COULD YOU GIVE US
YOUR READ ON THE STATE OF PLAY
WITH.
NEGOTIATIONS AND AND YOUR WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE MOVING
FORWARD ON THE STRETCHER WELL WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL -- IT'S IT IS A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
NICE IF WE COULD IDENTIFY.
WHERE THE THE THE MONEY?
HAS GONE IN BE ABLE TO CLOCK
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE TAXPAYERS
A CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE RIGHT NOW THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT IS JUST TRYING TO
LOOK AT ALL THE BIGGER PICTURE I
THERE WAS MENTION THEIR TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
WELLS.
THIS OIL AND GAS WELLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BOTH ONSHORE
AND OFFSHORE AND I THINK THIS
THIS IS A MEASURE WHERE WERE
TRUST TRYING.
TO IDENTIFY.
WHAT THE -- WHAT THE POTENTIAL
COSTS ARE YOU IN IN FACT I AM
VERY INTERESTED IN THE CAMP T. --
MODEL WHICH IS USED NOW FOR
ABANDONED MINES I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD VERY
POSSIBLY ADOPT.
OR ADAPT TO THE SITUATION WITH
THE OIL AND GAS AND I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT THAT
BUT THE CONFINES OF FOUR CORNERS
OF THE BILL ARE BASICALLY WHAT
WE ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND
I'M VERY VERY HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE WORKING THE STAFF
THE STAFF AND MYSELF AS WELL --
TO TO WITH THE CHAIR AND IN
OTHERS TO TO COME UP WITH A A
WAY TO DO THIS IN AN ACCURATE
AND EFFECTIVE FASHION.
ON THAT WILL BE MY CLOTHES AND
OKAY THANK YOU SO AND I KNOW THE
STAFF IS FAIR AND I I'M SURE
THEY'RE GONNA ALSO WANT TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY THAT SOME THE CONCERNS
THE OPPOSITION -- WHILE HELPING
THE AUTHOR I GET TO A PLACE
WHERE.
WE CAN ADDRESS THE THE BIG
CONCERNS THAT ARE THAT ARE OUT
THERE IN THE SPACE SO -- WITH
THAT WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
SO MOVES SO MOVED IN AND THAT'S
YOUR CLOTHES -- THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING
CENTERPIECE COLOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS STERN JONES ALLEN HI
ALLEN AYE FORGES CABALLERO
HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON I
AM MONEY.
MONEY BY THE BILL'S ON CALL FOR
GAVEL TO ITS IN A MINING AND I
PRESENT MY SB.
SIX EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
WELL SENATOR ALLEN'S GETTING
SITUATED THERE.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE
BILLS AFTER SENATOR ALLEN WE
WILL RECESS. FOR CAUCUS IN.
WILL BE.
TOM SURE WE HAVE A MOTION -- AND
I'M SECRETARY IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BY MISTER HUESO.
THE FIRE OF CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS COMPRISED OF FILE ITEM SIX SB
FOUR FOUR TWO FILE ITEM TEN SB
FIVE OH SEVEN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
SB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE AND FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE OKAY
SENATORS STERN JONES ALLEN.
HI ALLEN AYE BRIDGES CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO HUESO AYE
JACKSON.
MONNING HI MONEY NINE THEY'LL BE
ON CALL OKAY THANK YOU CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL REMAIN ON CALL --
SENATOR.%
ALLEN PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
HAVE THE REAL CHAIR BACK MEMBERS
I KNOW WE'RE IN A TIME
CONSTRAINTS IN THIS BILL DOES
NOT HAVE FRAZIER OPPOSITION --
BUT BUT EFFECTIVELY THIS GIVES
THE AIRPORT A NEW TOOL TO
ADDRESS -- A VERY SERIOUS ISSUES
AS WITH GLOBAL WARMING IT'S NOT
JUST THE QUESTION OF OF CARBON
AND AND POLLUTANTS IT ALSO HAS
TO DO.
WITH -- WITH WITH HEAT.
AND WITH RADIO FORCING OUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO GET INTO MORE DETAIL IF
YOU LIKE BUT IT'S A IT'S AN
IMPORTANT NEW TOOL TO GIVE THE
AIR -- AND VERY MUCH HOPE THAT
YOU'LL I SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
WHEN WITH ME I HAVE JOE CASE IN
THE CONSERVATION [inaudible]
RAINY.
AT THE INTERNATIONAL IN THE BY.
SIR JOH CAVES CONSERVATION
STRATEGY GROUP THIS IS A SMALL
VERY TECHNICAL BUT VERY
IMPORTANT BILL IT'LL HELP BRING.
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE PROGRAM
INTO ALIGNMENT WITH THE LATEST
GLOBAL CLIMATE SCIENCE.
IT'LL HELP GUIDE OUR PARTICULAR
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
PROGRAM AND THE PROVIDE SOME
TOOLS SO THAT WE CAN BE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN DEALING WITH THE
HEAT BUILD UP.
AND RADIATIVE FORCING THAT'S
CURRENTLY OCCURRING -- IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE REST
THE QUOTE WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CASE.
IS THIS GOING YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE
ON AUTOMATICALLY ON A THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING FIRST OF ALL AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK BEFORE THIS DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR ALLEN FOR AUTHORING THIS
LEGISLATION AND WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR. FOR HIS
SUPPORT AND CO AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
MY NAM IS TODD DELANEY I CHAIR.
THE INTERNATIONAL CLIMATE CHANGE
COORDINATING COMMITTEE
ESTABLISHED BY AYSO.
AYSO IS THE INTERNATIONAL
STANDARD ORGANIZATION FOR
STANDARDIZATION AT A GENEVA
SWITZERLAND.
WE PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON CLIMATE
RELATED STANDARDS.
AND HELP TO ENSURE THAT AN
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS SUPPORT
A ROBUST AND OUR RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
DESPITE INTERNATIONAL EFFORTS TO
DATE CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUES TO
ACCELERATE.
CALIFORNIA OFFERING OWN SHARE OF
CON CLIMATE RELATED IMPACT BROKE
DROUGHT FLOODS MUD SLIDES IN
FIRES.
WHICH HAVE IMPACTED MANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS.
BUT THERE IS MORE TO BE DONE A
CRITICAL NEXT STEP IS THE
ADOPTION OF A RADIATIVE FORCING.
BASED CLIMATE PROTOCOL TO
COMPLEMENT CURRENT CLIMATE
ACCOUNTING EFFORTS.
HI SO RELIES ON THE IPCC.
REPORTS IS NORMATIVE REFERENCES
TO ENSURE THE INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS ARE BASED ON THE MOST
UP TO DATE SCIENCE.
I AM CONVENING THE ICE -- EFFORT
TO STANDARDIZE THE RADIATIVE
FORCING ACCOUNTING PROTOCOL.
DERIVED FROM THE I. P. C.'S
FIFTH ASSESSMENT REPORT.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO HOW DO YOU W.
P.. ONE HUNDRED ACCOUNTING
PROTOCOL WAS DEVELOPED FROM THE
I PC SECOND ASSESSMENT REPORT IN
THE MID NINETIES.
THE PROTOCOL HAS ALREADY BEEN
REVIEWED BY LEADING U. S.
CLIMATE SCIENTISTS.
AND CLIMATE AND CLEAN AIR
COALITION SCIENTIFIC ADVISORY
PANEL IS PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL REVIEW.
ADOPTING A RADIATIVE FORCING
BASED PROTOCOL THROUGH SB SIX
EIGHTY TWO WILL REINFORCE
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AS AN
INTERNATIONAL LEADER.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
SETTING THE STAGE TO HELP THE
WORD OF THE WORLD AVOID
OVERSHOOTING GLOBAL.
TYRANT TEMPERATURE TARGETS THIS
PROTOCOL BRINGS GREATER
TRANSPARENCY TO THE FACTORS IN
INFLUENCING OUR CLIENT.
IMPROVE METRICS IN NEW INSIGHTS
TO PRIORITIZE MITIGATION ACTIONS
THAT MOST EFFICIENTLY AND COST
EFFECTIVELY COULD STABILIZE
CLIMATE.
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN NOW AND
TWENTY THIRTY THE WORLD IS
RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
HI SO FOR SIX EIGHTY TWO PASSED
INTO LAW THIS YEAR.
IT WILL ALLOW CARB TO EVALUATE
AND IMPLEMENT THE PROTOCOL
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
THIS WOULD REINFORCE THE
ADOPTION OF THIS PROTOCOL BY
OTHER COUNTRIES.
WHO ARE LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERTISE AND LEADERSHIP FOR
GUIDANCE?
KNOWING HOW LONG IMPLEMENTATION
OF ANY AGENCY REGULATORY CHANGE
CAN TAKE I BELIEVE SB SIX EIGHTY
TWO COULD SPEED UP GLOBAL
ADOPTION.
BY AS MUCH AS FIVE YEARS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS TIMING
COULD NOT BE OVERSTATED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I HEARD
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT NOW
OR AT ANYTIME IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
THANK.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN NONE OF ANY OPPOSITION.
BEING NINE BRING BACK TO THE
DíAS COMMENTS QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
ENTERTAIN.
PARDON ME A MOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THE MOTION FOR CENTER MINING.
YOU KNOW I'M ALREADY ON BOARD --
SORT OF GET THROUGH THAT DIVIDE
BETWEEN.
THE SHORT LIVED POLLUTANTS
ZACHARY.
ALL THE METRICS IN THE SYSTEM.
I I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE THE
POINT ABOUT ADVANCING SCIENCE IN
A MORE XCELERATED MANNERS WELL
IN IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE WE
HAVE NO TIME TO WAIT.
YEAH.
THANKSGIVING IS FOR CENTER ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE AN EXTRAORDINARY AT
VERY DISTINGUISHED GROUP OF
SCIENTISTS WHO ARE ABOARD THIS
AND WORKING WITH US I JUST WANT
TO GIVE THEM MY PERSONAL THINGS
AND APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT THAT
YOU'RE IN THE COMMITTEE AND
RESPECT FAST FROM HAVE A VERY
GOOD.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THEN PLEASE HOLD
WHILE ANOTHER STERN AYE STERN
AYE JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORTUS CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO.
JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY I HAS THREE IS ON CALL
OKAY.
HEY WE'RE ONLY THE MEASURE ON
CALL
. ONE IS JUST.
JUST FOR THE HECK OF IT WILL
LIFT THE CALL ON ONE MEASURE --
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT'S SB
FOUR ZERO TWO BORE JUST OTHER
CARVERS THREE ZERO THE MOTIONS
DO PAST APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIRS VOTING HI.
SO THERE'S ALLEN CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY NINE FOUR ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE MEASURE ON CALL [inaudible]
AND ONE SECOND.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A RECESS FOR
LUNCH AND WE WILL RECONVENE HERE
AT ONE THIRTY I'M SORRY NOT HERE
I ONE THIRTY IN ROOM -- ONE
THIRTEEN THANK YOU [inaudible]
RECESSED
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. FOR WHICH WOULD HELP
ENSURE ON NATIONAL FAIRNESS.
CALIFORNIA'S WATER RIGHT HOLDERS
OF PROTECTING THEM FROM THEIR
FINANCE ARM IN THE FORM OF THE
THE LAST YEAR WHILE IN IS.
I WAS IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
AUTHORED AB.
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH SOUGHT
TO RESTORE DUE PROCESS AN OBJECT
THE CALIFORNIA WATER RIGHT.
THE BILL CREATED IN
ADMINISTRATIVE.
ADMINISTRATIVE DURING OFFICE
UNDER THE STATE WATER BOARD IN
NEUTRAL FORUM TO ADJUDICATE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT COMPLEX
MODERATE MATTER.
ONLY BE A REPRESENTATIVE SURE
DOES THAT WATER RIGHT THE HERE'S
WHAT ONLY PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE
FOR THE NEW OFFICE.
WHICH WOULD BE FUNDED.
BY WATER RIGHT HOLDERS.
NEW CANNABIS BLIGHT.
AND THE GENERAL FUND.
HOWEVER THE RECENTLY ADMITTED
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL CAME IN
NEARLY 30% HIGHER THAN THE
ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENS
CURRENT REPAIR.
THIS HAS REAL CONSEQUENCE.
CALIFORNIA WATER PROVIDER.
THE NEW HEARINGS OFFICE MAYBE
SUPPORTED BY THE GENERAL FUND
AND THE WATER RIGHT.
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC AS THE WATER
RIGHT FIND IT.
EARLY BY FEES.
AND WATER RIGHT HOLDERS.
THESE WHICH ARE ARE ALREADY
SIGNIFICANTLY ON THE RISE
HOUSING.
FINANCE.
NO MORE INCREASES ARE NOT.
NOT ONLY THAT AS THE LAWS.
CURRENTLY.
PARTY'S UTILIZING THE HEARING
OFFICE MAY NOT BE THE FINANCE
BELIEVE.
OFFICE AND BY.
SB FOUR BY OR READ DOORS BALLOT.
THE BILL ENSURES THAT THE NEW
HEARING OFFICE WILL REACH IF THE
NECESSARY FUNDS.
MANDATED DUTIES.
WITHOUT UNFAIRLY IMPACTING WATER
RIGHT HOLDERS READING A NEW
WATER RIGHT.
OFF FIND THAT WOULD BE USED --
SIMPLY.
HEARING OFFICE. ONE WOULD BE
SUPPORTED BY THE FILING FEES AND
FINES IMPOSED BY THE OFFICE.
WHICH MUST BE USED DIRECT.
DIRECTLY REDUCE THE HEARING
OFFICE.
OFFICES PINEAPPLE DEPENDENT ON
THE WATER RIGHT.
WHILE YOU ARE IDENTICAL THAT
THOSE IMPOSED.
ENSURING PARTIES UTILIZED IN THE
OFFICE PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF SUPPORT WITHOUT BEING.
PARTIES TO UTILIZE THE HEARING
OFFICE.
AND ARE FOUND IN VIOLATION A LOT
AND FIND OLDER A LARGER PORTION
FINANCE.
IN A THIS STRUCTURE -- MECHANISM
SELECT AND AND IF THE MACINNES.
MECHANISM THAT DOESN'T CURRENTLY.
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY.
THE BELL IS.
HIS.
RECORD YOUR MORE FROM BYRON
BETHANY.
AND I DON'T HAVE ANY YES MY OF
THE FACT THAT THE HELLO WHAT WE
WERE.
MENTAL [inaudible]
ONE THE I'M I'M A MEMBER NUMBER
ZERO ON OUR PREVIOUS BILL.
WE'VE ANY OTHERS IN FORT.
BEING NINE WITH ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WBG I'M
A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE US
BEFORE FIFTY FOUR WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A NEED TO INSURE
THAT PROCESS CANNABIS GROWERS DO
NOT PAY INTO THE WATER RATES
FUND.
UP UNDER THIS HEARING OFFICE.
BUT THE WAY THAT THE BILL HAS
BEEN AMENDED IN COMMITTEE AND AS
INITIALLY DRAFTED.
WOULD IMPOSE FEES ON EVERYONE
WHO PARTICIPATES IN ONE OF THESE
WATER RIGHTS PROCEEDING.
ACCORDING TO THE BOARDS
REGULATIONS.
IN TITLE.
TWENTY THREE PARTIES ARE DEFINED
VERY BROADLY TO INCLUDE THOSE
WHO FILE A PROTEST OF WATER
RIGHT.
WHICH COULD INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
IT INCLUDES.
FISHING GROUPS AND CONSERVATION
GROUPS LIKE OURSELVES.
AND THUS SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR IS
CREATING A BARRIER FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
HEARINGS THAT DOES NOT EXIST
TODAY.
AND IS MAKING IT HARDER FOR US
TO ENFORCE AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
YOU KNOW E HAD SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRIOR BILL
THE SET UP THIS ADMINISTRATING
THE MEASURE OF HEARING OFFICE WE
FELT IT WAS UNNECESSARY.
THE SUPREME COURT HAD UP HELD
THE BOARD HEARING PROCESSES AS
COMPLYING WITH DUE PROCESS.
BUT WE WENT ALONG AND WE
ACCEPTED THAT.
THIS HEARING ADMISSION HEARING
OFFICE WOULD GO FORWARD.
NOW HOWEVER WERE IMPOSING FEES
THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHTS AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE.
TO OPPOSE THE BILL AND VOTE NO
TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND ALSO SEE A COUPLE CALIFORNIA
WE WOULD LIKE TO A LINER.
SB WE JUST BELIEVE THIS IS A
CRIMINAL TO SOME OF THE PUBLIC
AND OTHER GROUPS THAT WOULD BE
BRINGING WATER RIGHTS ISSUES
BEFORE THE BOARD THANK YOU.
GOOD THANK YOU AND IS IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
MEMBER.
YEAH JUST THE TWO OF US IS A
SONG ABOUT THAT.
CAN I JUMP IN -- COMMENTS EIGHTY
FEET.
REACTIONS TO SOME OF THAT
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT I MEAN
IS YOUR INTENT TO COVER PULIC
AGENCIES AND NON PROFITS IN WHEN
IT WHEN IT SAYS ANY PARTY.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A SENSE YOUR
TO REACT [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
WAIVERS.
INCLUDING PUBLIC AID THE AND FEE
WAIVERS FOR PARTIES WHO CANNOT
AFFORD -- TO PAY THOSE FILING
FEES.
AND SO THE THE FILING FEE IS
CURLY STATE ARE TIED TO THE FEES
FOR SACRAMENTO.
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT.
I IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE TO ADD
SOME CLARIFICATIONS IN THERE.
TOO PRESS OR TO INCORPORATE THE
SAME WAY BIRTH THAT EXIST IN --
THE LAWS THAT APPLY TO SUPERIOR
COURT AND YOU SAID A IS BASED ON
ABILITY THAT YOU CAN AFFORD IT.
IT BASED ON A FORTY IF YOU FILE
IN SUPERIOR COURT NORMALLY YOU
HAVE TO PAY A FEE AND THE FEES
THAT WE PROPOSED HERE ARE WOULD
BE TIED EXACTLY TO THIS.
COURT FEES.
IN SUPERIOR COURT IF YOU CANNOT
AFFORD.
THAT AND THERE'S A WHOLE PROCESS
FOR THIS ALSO -- YOU CAN HAVE
THOSE FEES WAIVED.
THERE IS THERE A FEE WAIVER
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW.
BUT UNLESS YOU QUALIFY FOR THE
FEW A PROVISIONS IN THEORY THIS
BILL WOULD STILL REQUIRE THE
GOVERNMENT TO PAY A FEE AND
NONPROFIT TO PAY A FEE -- THE
MAFIA FEE.
FOR THEY'RE NOT ANY PUBLIC
AGENCIES ARE NOT THE STATE NOT
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
NOT BE W. R. K. I'M NOT ANY
OTHER PUBLIC AGENCY OF POLITICAL
SUBDIVISION -- ENDED NONPROFIT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A POLITICAL
SUBDIVISION IT WOULD NEED TO
PROVE THAT IT WAS FINANCIALLY
UNABLE TO PAY I SAID THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT THE NONPROFITS THAT.
IS IT DOESN'T THE D. W. R. POINT
SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE NOT AS MUCH OF
AN ISSUE OR IF SOMEONE LIKE BUT
IT'S ABOUT THE NONPROFIT WELL
ACTUALLY CAN I GET YOUR SENSE
SENATOR JUST.
AN OPENNESS TO WORKING THROUGH
THAT ISSUE GOING FORWARD
ABSOLUTELY I JUST NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT WHAT WE WERE TRYING
TO DO IS.
TO RELIEVE THE BURDEN ON THE ON
THE ON THE FUND RIGHT FOR PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE ANY ANY ISSUES
BEFORE THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE AND TO REQUIRE THEM TO BE
PAYING.
CONSTRUED CONSISTENTLY INTO A
FIND WHERE THERE'S THERE'S NO
BENEFIT TO THEM.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT A JUDICATA
ANYTHING DIDN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE.
IT'S A BURDEN THAT SO YEAH WE
CAN WE MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT THAT WOULD BE GREAT
BECAUSE I I I I TOTALLY.
EMPATH I'MTHERE WITH YOU ON THE
THE FREE RIDER CONCEPT OF YOU
KNOW LEGAL CANNABIS GROWS AND
ALL THESE OTHER SORT OF
BENEFITING FROM THESE REGULATION
NOT.
ITCHING IN AN AND ALL THE THE
WATER DISTRICTS AND ALL THE
OTHER FOLKS -- BEARING LINE
SHARE IT IS WORRY ABOUT IMPACTS
ON THE NONPROFIT THAT I'D HAVE A
LEGITIMATE STAKE IN IT I FEEL --
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN
MEET THE THRESHOLD THAT SO MAYBE
WE IF IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
TODAY MAY WE CAN.
WORK THAT THROUGH BEFORE
PROHIBITION SEE WE CAN DO --
OKAY -- RAISE YOUR DID YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NO NO WHAT WE'RE OKAY WITH IT
THE ONE OTHER THE ONLY OTHER
QUESTION I HAD WAS JUST HOW HOW
DOES THIS.
HOW DOES THIS DIFFER A WAR IN
YOUR VIEW IMPROVE ON THE BCP WE
ALREADY PASSED THAT CAN BE --
FOR YOUR SPONSORS OR WHOMEVER
BUT WE ACTED IN BUDGET SUB TO I
THINK WE MADE A RUEFUL HOW WOULD
THE IMPLEMENTATION WORK.
WITH THIS SO WHAT COULD WE WITH
THIS SORT OF WITH THIS REQUIRES.
TO REVISE THAT B. CPD DO SOME
NEW ACT.
MY ANALYSIS IS THAT THE IS.
IT THIS IS A BILL -- THE BEASTIE
P. IS IS IS IS THE FORMAT FOR
MAKING SURE THERE'S MONEY. FOR
THE HEARING.
OFFICE TO BE ABLE TO BE TO
BECOME OPERATIONAL AT SOME POINT
HOW WE CHANGE THE FUNDING FOR IT --
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND?
IT.
HAD A DIGGING DEEP HERE YEAH
YEAH BECAUSE I NEVER DID SHARE A
BUDGET COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH I SAT
ON HIM.
IT'S MY BELIEF THAT WHAT HAPPENS
IS THE MECHANICS THEN GET
CHANGED -- BOB BY OPERATION OF
LAW WITH THE WITH THE A BILL IF
IT'S SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND AND THEN IT IT SENSE IT'S
FOR NEXT YEAR WOULD KICK IN THE
NEXT YEAR AND THE NEXT YEAR WE
WOULD HAVE WHATEVER BCP FOR THIS
YEAR FOR THE CURRENT WATER BOARD
FILMING MEDIC IF THE FUNDING.
FOR THAT NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET.
IT STARTS IN JUNE AND JULY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL -- BUT THAT.
LATE CLOSED.
I APPRECIATE THAT THE THE
OPPONENT'S RAISING AN ISSUE AND
I I PLEDGE TO WILL WILL WORK ON
IT.
HE LOOKED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THANK YOU I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
OKAY SO MOVED BY THE VICE CHAIR
OF THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MINISTER AYE AYE JONES JONES
I ALLEN PORGES OF EURO.
CARILLO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONEY [inaudible]
OR JUST.
WE'RE JUST -- FIVE I'D.
OR I WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON
PAUL WE HAVE THAT AS FOR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT YOUR MORRELL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO -- FILING WHAT ELEVEN SENATOR.
IS THE FIVE FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS SB FIVE FIFTEEN IS A
NARROWLY FOCUSED BILL THAT WOULD
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF HIGH
HAZARD FUEL FOR BIOMASS
FACILITIES WITH BIRAM CONTRACTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN ISSUED AN
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION CALLING
FOR THE CPUC TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF EXPIRING BIOMASS
CONTRACTS AS PART OF THE CONCERN
THAT CALIFORNIA HAD AN ESTIMATED.
A HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION DEAD
AND DYING TREES.
HELLFIRE PUT TOGETHER A MAP
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS HIGH
HAZARD JONES IDENTIFYING AREAS
THAT COULD BE IMPACTED AS A
RESULT OF A DEAD TREE HITTING A
POWER LINE OR BLOCKING THE ROAD.
THE CPUC RESPONDED BY REQUIRING
THE UTILITIES TO PROCURE FIVE
FIFTY MEGAWATTS OF BIOMASS
ENERGY.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO ACTED IN
PASSED SB EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH
REQUIRED ANOTHER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MEG OF MEGAWATTS OF
BIOMASS ENERGY TO BE.
PROCURED.
IN ALL THERE ARE SEVEN CONTRACTS
SIGNED AS A RESULT OF THESE TWO
MANDATES AND THEY ARE REFER
REFER TO IS BIRAM CONTRACTS.
ALL OF THESE CONTRACTS ARE
REQUIRED TO GET A SPECIFIED
AMOUNT OF FUEL FROM FROM THESE
HIGH HAZARD ZONES HOWEVER THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
REQUIREMENT.
IS THAT FOREST WASTE.
THAT IS FROM HIGH HAZARD ZONE
NOW COSTS MORE THAN FOREST WASTE
THAT COULD START THEY COULD
ACTUALLY START A WILDFIRE.
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES PAY A
PENALTY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MEET
THE REQUIREMENT OF HIGH HAZARD
ZONE FUEL WHICH HAS A RANDOM
TARGET THAT WHICH WAS A RANDOM
TARGET SAID ON THE LAST NIGHT OF
SESSION.
WE NO LONGER HAVE A HUNDRED AND
TWO MILLION DEAD TREES IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN ESTIMATED
A HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DEAD TREES AND WE HAVE
AN UNHEALTHY AND OVERSTOCKED
FOREST WITH EXCESS FUEL AND A
CAT.
CATASTROPHE IN WAITING WITH
REGARDS TO WILDFIRES.
THE NAPA COUNTY WILDFIRE DID NOT
OCCUR IN THESE HIGH HAZARD ZONE
AND NEITHER WAS THE PARADISE
FIRE.
RATHER THAN WAIT AND TELL A
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE DESTROYS A
COMMUNITY -- BEFORE EMOVING THE
FUEL WE WOULD LIKE TO GET OUT IN
FRONT OF THE EASIER ISSUES AND
TRY TO PREVENT THE NEXT WHILE
FIRE.
SB FIVE ONE FIVE EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF HIGH HAZARD ZONE
FUEL TO INCLUDE AREAS WITHIN A
WILDFIRE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT CAL FIRE ANNOUNCED EARLIER
IN THE YEAR.
AS WELL AS EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
CAL FIRES MAP WHICH SHOWS
MODERATE HI IN VERY HIGH IN
HAZARD ZONES.
THE BILL IS SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
STEP TO IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS
IN OUR FOREST AND HELP PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRES WHERE
THERE IS EXCESS FEEL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- SIX SEVEN ZERO
DOESN'T SUPPORT WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I'M JEFF OLSON A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
WITH CASCADE RESOURCE
CONSULTANTS AND I HANDLE FUEL
PROCUREMENT FOR BERNIE OR POWER.
BIOMASS ENERGY FACILITY IN
EASTERN SHASTA COUNTY.
AS MY TEST MY FOCUS ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION ALSO MENTION I
SERVICE THE VOLUNTEER FIRE KEEP
MY TOWN AND ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH I
ALONG WITH HUNDREDS OF OTHERS
ENGAGED IN EFFORTS TO HELP SAVE
PARADISE FROM THE CAMPFIRE.
AN EXPERIENCE WHICH IS
DRAMATICALLY HEIGHTENED MY SENSE
OF URGENCY FOR REDUCING VIRUS IN
OUR FORESTS.
LIKE MANY BY MASS FACILITIES IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BERNIE
FORCE POWER NEARLY CLOSED ITS
DOORS UNTIL IT WAS SAVED BY THE
BYRON PROGRAM.
WHICH ALLOWED PLANS TO CONTINUE
OPERATING WHILE DIRECTING THEM
TO SOURCE MATERIAL FROM HIGH
HAZARD ZONES ARE ACCESS TREE
MORTALITY HAD OCCURRED.
AT THE TIME THIS MADE SENSE A
HUNDRED MILLION TREES ARE DEAD
STATEWIDE.
OVER IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE STATE WAS RUDELY AWAKENED TO
THE FACT THAT THE GREATEST
THREAT TO OUR FORESTS AND OUR
CITIZENS HAD SHIFTED FROM DEAD
TREES TO CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
CAPABLE OF WIPING ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES OFF THE MAP IN MERE
HOURS.
CASE IN POINT WHEN CAL FIRE MADE
ITS HIGH HAZARD MAPS MULTIPLE
WATERSHEDS COVERING PORTIONS OF
PARADISE AND CON CAL TO NOT HAVE
THE REQUISITE TREE MORTALITY TO
WARRANT DESIGNATION AS HIGH
HAZARD.
FURTHERMORE NOT ONE OF THE
EVACUATION ROUTES OUT OF
PARADISE WAS DESIGNATED AS A
HIGHER PARTY TEAR ONE'S OWN
NEITHER WAS THE TRANSMISSION
LINE WHICH ALLEGEDLY STARTED THE
WORST FIRE IN STATE HISTORY.
WITHOUT SUCH DESIGNATION BOMBERS
FACILITIES SUCH AS BERNIE FIND
THEIR HANDS TIED FROM HELPING
FILL REDUCTION EFFORTS IN THESE
AREAS.
I BELIEVE THESE FACTS ALONE IN
LIGHT OF THE CAMPFIRE ILLUSTRATE
THAT THE THREAT HAS SHIFTED
SINCE INCEPTION OF BYRON PROGRAM.
IN CLOSING I WOULD OFFER THAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO BIOMASS FOR
TREATING OVERSTOCKED FORESTS.
THE COMBAT THIS CRISIS I URGE
YOU TO RECOGNIZE HAT THE
PRIORITIES FOR THE BYRON PROGRAM
MUST ALSO INCLUDE REDUCING THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE IN
THE STATE WITH SB FIVE ONE FIVE
BEING A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU.
YOU.
WELCOME BACK IF YOU.
LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS BILL
IN IN HERE'S WHAT IT DOES NOT.
TO THIS BILL DOES NOT ALTER ANY
RULES FOR TIMBER HARVEST OR
CHANGE ANY ENVIRONMENTAL RULES.
THIS BILL DOESN'T ALTER ANY
EXISTING UTILITY PURCHASE
CONTRACTS.
AND IT DOESN'T IMPACT CONSUMER
COST.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT ALLOWS FOR
WASTE?
FROM FIRE PREVENTION FORCE
PROJECTS TO BE EFFICIENTLY
UTILIZED.
AND IT RECOGNIZES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FOREST MANAGEMENT
GOALS ARE EVOLVING.
WHEN SB EIGHT FIFTY NINE WAS
ENACTED?
ARE FORCED ISSUES WERE DEAD AND
DYING TREES IN THIS YEAR'S.
SO THE BIRAM CONTRATS CALLED
FOR DEALING WITH THOSE DEAD
TREES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR CAL FIRE
EXPANDED THE CRITERIA TO INCLUDE
DEAD TREES FROM AREAS WERE
FORCED FIRE OCCURRED.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
MIRROR THE MATERIAL THAT CAN BE
USED IN BIRAM CONTRACTS FROM THE
DEAD TREES.
AND THE BURN TREES.
THE DOCTOR THOSE TREES THAT ARE
AT RISK.
THE VERY FORCED FUELS THAT NEED
TO BE REMOVED TO MEET OUR FIRE
PREVENTION GOALS.
HOW FAR HAS DEVELOPED A MAP OF
AREAS AT RISK FOR FIRE?
THE BILL IS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN.
ALLOWED BY A MASTERY BE REMOVED
FOR FIRE PREVENTION PURPOSES IN
AREAS THAT WERE VERY HIGH.
HI AND MODERATE RISK.
AS ALLOWEDFOR FOR IN THE BIRAM
CONTRACTS.
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE ENERGY COMMITTEE.
THE NARROW THAT DEFINITION TO
JUST THE VERY HIGH RISK AREAS.
WELL ARE AN ORIGINAL INTENT WAS
TO PROTECT A BROADER RANGE OF
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT
AMENDMENT -- AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL.
AS IT MOVES IN THE DIRECTION OF
PROTECTING MORE COMMUNITIES WELL
MEETING OUR FIRE PREVENTION
GOALS.
SB FIVE FIFTEEN IS ACTUALLY
SIMPLE BILL.
WITHOUT IMPACTING EXISTING
CONTRACTS ARE CONSUMER COSTS.
IT ALLOWS CALIFORNIA.
NEED IS FIRE PREVENTION GOALS BY
FISSION LEE UTILIZING FORCED
WASTE FROM THE AREA'S MOST AT
RISK FOR FIRE.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
OTHERS SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY WITH
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
STATE'SFORCED PLAN AND HAVE
SEEN WAY TOO MANY OF THE RECENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES SO WERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF ANY
EFFORTS TO NOT ONLY IMPROVE FOR
SELF BUT ESPECIALLY TO REDUCE
WILD VIRUS.
WE SEE THESE BY MASS
DISABILITIES AS A CRUCIAL TOOL
TO HELP US GET THERE TO SAVE
LIVES AND THIS BILL PROVIDES A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
KEEP THOSE.
PLANS AN OPERATION THANK YOU.
AFTER MR ERA MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HAPPY THE FOREST
PRODUCTS INDUSTRY NATIONAL LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE.
ABOUT TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS SIR.
JULIE MILLINOCKET ON THE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT MASS ENERGY
LINES SUPPORT THANKS.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS CHRIS MAKAYLA
ON BEHALF OFHUMBLE AND
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROBERT
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
OR IN THERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE
OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE I'M BRIAN A WEEK YOU
AT THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY -- ME START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR AND FOR THE
FOR THE AMENDMENTS MADE AFTER
THE ENERGY -- COMMITTEE -- THAT
DID HELP TO ADDRESS ONE OF THE
LARGEST PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL
WHICH IS THAT.
IT SET THE NEXT SO BROADLY THAT
IT ESSENTIALLY WASHED OUT ANY
ABILITY OF THIS PROJECT PROGRAM.
TO FOCUS -- TO FOCUS ATTENTION
AND RESOURCE.
I'M COMMUNITY AND THE HIGHEST
RISK AREAS BY JANE TAKING OUT
THE TIER.
TWO WE DID GET RID OF THE
MILLIONS OF ACRES WERE
ESSENTIALLY DIRECTION FROM
FOCUSING ON THE HIGHEST --
HIGHEST PRIORITY WHICH IN OUR
OPINION IS.
HOMES -- COMMUNITIES IN THE
AREAS DIRECTLY INTO THAT.
THAT IT IMPROVED IT WE STILL
HAVE THAT EFFECT WITH THE TIER
THREE I FEEL LIKE THOSE THOSE
AREAS DEFINITELY FOCUS MORE ON
THE AREAS THAT WE WOULD ALL WANT
TO SEE -- PRIORITIZED BUT I
DEFINITELY ENCOURAGE EVERYONE.
I'M ON THE COMMITTEE AND AS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS THE
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THOSE MAPS --
THOSE MAPS STILL FAIL. TO
PROVIDE US COMMUNITY PROTECTION
ON THEIR OWN AND WHAT WE
ESSENTIALLY HAVE [inaudible]
IS.
A PRIOR THE ABILITY NOW.
FOR PROJECTS TO PRIORITIZE EXT.
EXTRACTION OF WOOD IN THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE MOST.
THAT ARE CLOSEST TO AND MOST.
THAT'S A BALL FOR BIOMASS PLANTS
ALL WE'RE DOING HERE IS
EXPANDING HOW EASILY.
DOM THOSE BOUNOUS PLANTS CAN
PULL FROM THE AREAS THAT ARE
CLOSEST TO THEM THAT DOES NOT
PROVIDE US ON THE PHONE.
HOME PROTECTION BUT DOES NOT
PROVIDE US COMMUNITY DEFENSIBLE
SPACES.
AND AGAIN I FEEL LIKE THIS TEN
CHILE -- ON A PROJECT THE
PROJECT LEVEL MAY ACTUALLY BE
DISTRACTING US FROM THE WORK OF
ON HOME PROTECTION.
THAT SAID THOUGH THE LAST THING
TO MENTION FOR ME IS THAT --
RATHER THAN CATEGORICALLY
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF
ELIGIBLE BIOMASS FEEDSTOCK.
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
IS BEST SITUATED TO MAKE THESE
INTENSELY FACT SPECIFIC
DETERMINATION.
AND ALREADY HAS A SYSTEM IN
PLACE TO DO -- RECENT CPUC
RESOLUTION -- INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES HAVE THE POWER TO
AMEND BIRAM CONTRACTS TO ALLOW
FACILITIES TO HELP SALVAGE
BIOMASS FROM THESE.
AREAS I'M TOWARD THEIR STOCK
REQUIREMENT AFTER A WILD FIRE
EVENT -- AND AND ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY IN RESPONSE -- TO BY
REDUCTION PROJECTS COMMISSION
RULED THAT THESE AMENDMENTS
SHOULD BE EVALUATED ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS -- AND AS ASSIST. FOR
DOING THAT.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE OVERRIDE THAT KIND
OF SITE SPECIFIC ANALYSIS.
THAT SAID -- BUT THAT WAS
INITIALLY PUT IN PLACE WAS
SPECIFICALLY.
IN RESPECT WITH RESPECT -- TO
BOTH BUYER OUTRAGE THEY WOULD
HAVE TO CHANGE THEIR YOU KNOW.
AND WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT AN
ART.
WITH THAT WE DO -- YOU SEE MORE
READ.
OR THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
I'M SEEN NO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE MOTION FROM CENTER BOARD YES --
ONE QUESTION I JUST HAD FOR YOUR
EXPERTS WHILE THEY'RE HERE.
WE TALK A LOT OF FORESTRY.
TODAY BUT THE FEEDSTOCK ITSELF
IS NOT LIMITED I I KEEP THINKING
BACK.
TO THE CHAPARRAL AND SMALLER
DIAMETER.
YOU KNOW -- FUELS THAT ARE AT
VERY PREVALENT IGNITION SOURCE
IN. SEVEN EVEN PARTS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY NOT THE BIG TREE STUFF
WE'RE TALK ABOUT WITH SOME THIS
DIFFERENT SENSITIVITIES.
HIS BIO ENERGY THE ONLY POSSIBLE
SO SOLUTION.
OUT THERE FOR THOSE KINDS OF THE
STOCKS ARE THERE ANY ALTERNATIVE
MARKETS THAT ARE STARTING TO
SHAPE UP WHERE WE HAVE.
EITHER I MEAN I THINK WE HEARD
FROM OF THE FOREST PRODUCTS
COUNCIL.
WORKING COMMITTEE BUT JUST TO
GET A SENSE I MEAN I I KNOW THIS
IS ONE PART OF THIS THE SOLUTION
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE BY
JUST.
I DON'T KNOW AND I'M TRYING TO
GET A A BETTER MY HEAD AROUND
ESPECIALLY WHAT'S GOING TO COME
OUT OF HIS HAZ STUDY FROM THE UC
I KNOW IT'S SORT OF OUTSIDE.
BUT YU'RE THANK YOU CENTER YEAH
THE FIRST OF ALL OF YOU.
WE DO NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VERY DIFFERENT
VEGETATION TYPES.
WOULD BE THE CHAPARRAL IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OAK WOODLANDS AND AND THE NAPA
VALLEY AREA OR ARE A KIND OF FOR
FOREST -- IN EACH OF THOSE.
SEVEN PRODUCTS FROM A RUB
RESOURCES IN THOSE AREAS HAVE
DIFFERENT USES THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF USE FOR CHAPARRAL.
NOT MUCH RIGHT -- OKAY IS IT HAS
SOME LIMITATIONS -- GIVEN ITS
SIZE -- ALL ALTHOUGH I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE IT WAS OAK
THAT WAS IN THE M..
IF THE DRAW IN PARIS.
MAYBE THEY WANT IN THE WORLD I
DON'T KNOW.
BUT I THINK THAT IT THE IN THE
IN THE SHORT TERM -- PROBABLY
BIMASS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
BIO ENERGY OF LONGER TERM.
THERE ARE SOME NEW WOOD PRODUCTS
COMING -- THEN WE'RE NOT THERE
YET CALIFORNIA BUT CROSS
LAMINATED TIMBER SOME OF THE
MASTER BURKE -- DOES IT HAVE
SOME USE FOR SMALLER MATERIAL --
THE KIND OF WASTE MATERIAL THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT CAN
OTHERWISE BE PRODUCTIVELY USED --
SO -- YOU KNOW THE CONTRACTS
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST -- FOR BIO
RAM A CONTINUE TO BE SHORT TERM
CONTRACTS ARE NOT A AND THOSE.
OF WE'RE JUST MAKING IT.
THIS BILL EASIER TO USE THAT
MATERIAL BUT CAL FIRE HAS
SPECIFICALLY DENTIFIED AS
COMING FROM AREAS OF VERY HIGH
RISK.
OF FOR FIRE [inaudible]
INSTEAD -- BUT I RECOGNIZE THIS
IS ONE PART OF THE SOLUTION I I
IT'S BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THIS
MEASURE BUT I'M.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT A
SOLUTION SET LOOKS LIKE BESIDES
JUST PRESCRIBE FIRE EVERYWHERE
THROUGH THE CHAPARRAL AND I
THESE MAY NOT BE THE THE RIGHT
PLACE TO DO IT BUT I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE OPEN TO ALL
SUGGESTIONS. TO COMPLICATE
THINGS IS DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE WITH THE
BILL BUT I'M HEARING MORE AND
MORE FROM THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
WASTE -- THAT HERE TOO FOR COULD
COULD HAVE BEEN -- USED A NOW
WHAT IT'S OPEN BURNING IF YOU
JUST PILE IT UP AND YOU YOU
LIGHT A MATCH AND YOU GET NO
ENERGY -- FROM IT BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S JUST IT.
IT COSTS TOO MUCH TO TRANSPORT.
AND ANY TO WASTE PRODUCT IN THE
SOONER YOU GET RID OF IT.
THE BETTER OFF YOU ARE INTEL THE
WE WE HAVE THESE CHALLENGES WITH
WITH WASTE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT SOME OF THE
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS AND IT'S
IT'S FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT AND TO
MAKE IT EVEN MORE COMPLICATED.
ALL THE PLASTIC THAT THEY USED
TO GET SHIPPED TO CHINA OFF OF
OF THE AG IS RIGHT NOW READING
THIS -- BUILD UP AND SO.
MORE TO COME ON THAT.
OKAY WITH THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SHE THE OPPOSITION CONCERN ALSO
THEY RECKON IT NO THE NARROWING
IT GO WORKING WITH US.
THEIR MONEY AROUND ANYWHERE HERE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FOR MOVE
CENTER BOARD JUST AS A MOTION --
THERE ALLEN YOU'RE RIGHT.
VERSE SO I'M WHERE I WORKED ON
IT.
IT WILL BIO AND GAS STANDARD AND
RAN INTO SOME OF THESE BOMB OUT
WITH A CHALLENGES BUT I DO THINK.
I FIGURE OUT A IN A SUSTAINABLE
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY WAY
OF APPROACHING THIS QUESTION I
THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HAVE I I I MEAN I I I I
CERTAINLY DO HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL STAY VERY ENGAGED
IN THIS BILL MOVIE FOR ITS
ENSURE THAT THE WORST FEARS OF
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS.
FROM OUT I MEAN YOU'RE NOT
REALIZED WITH AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S DANGER --
FROM A FROM A PERSPECTIVE.
ON THIS AT THE SAME TIME.
YEAH WE DO HAVE A LOT OF OUR
MASS OUT THERE AND IT'S GOING TO
WASTE AND YOU'RE GIVEN OUR
ENERGY CHALLENGES.
WE GOT AT YOU KNOW WE ARE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM IF WE CAN DO
SO IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T HARM
FIREMAN SO I I GUESS I MIGHT MY
REQUEST OF YOU IN THE AUTHOR.
MISTER CHAIR IS IS.
THAT -- YOU KNOW THAT THE IF YOU
SEE ME THIS BOOK ALMOST OR THE I
MEAN IT'S A VERY ENGAGED IN
DURING THAT.
WHATEVER COMES OUT OF THIS WORLD
WILL TRULY BE SEEN.
I YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON
VIGILANCE I THINK YOU EVEN HEARD
IT FROM.
ARE SOME MEMBER EMERITUS OF
MISTER GORDON HERE IN TERMS OF
WHAT WHAT THE BILL -- DOESN'T
DOESN'T DO THIS IN THE BIO RAM
PROGRAM BUT IN TERMS OF IMPACTS
ON HABITAT CONSERVATION PLAN THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLANNING PROCESS.
SEEK WERE ALL THOSE ISSUES.
I'M IF IF FOR SOME REASON
THERE'S SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE PUTTING PRESSURE
IMPACTING ON THAT YOU CAN BE
DARN SURE WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING
AT IT BUT I THINK THIS IS NARROW
ENOUGH.
MOVE ALONG TODAY WITHIN THE
CONFINES THAT EXISTING PROGRAM
SO -- ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT AND ONE OKAY.
ON WE GO LIVE CLOSE RESHAPED ALL
THE ALL THE THE COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS AND I I'M RIGHT THERE
WITH YOU I I WILL COMMIT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE CHAIR
ON THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR OUT SHE DOES
YOUR CLOTHES AND CENTER BOARD
JUST HAD A MOTION BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE JOHNNY ON THE
SPOT BOBBY ON THE SPOT.
AND THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS STERN HI.
HI JONES.
JONES I AYE ALLEN AYE AYE ALLEN
AYE BARGES.
OR JUST AYE CABBIE RO.
WE ARE AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
IT.
THE OKAY THAT MEASURE AS EIGHT
LEVELS WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ONE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU CENTER VERY MUCH -- ALREADY
SO.
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS
AND RUN THROUGH EVERYTHING RIGHT
NOW SO.
GUYS GOTTA GET READY AND GET
VIGILANT HERE BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT GOING TO COME DOWN THE PIKE.
WE'LL JUST WE'LL ASSUME SENATOR
ALLEN'S READY -- SO WE'RE JUST
GONNA GO ON FILE ORDER HERE
FOLKS -- I THINK WE'LL JUST YEAH
DO WE HAVE HUESO HERE.
WE CAN AND HE'S PRESENTING
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO RUN ONE MORE
TIME EASY IS MADE PRESENTE YEAH
OKAY WELL?
ALL RIGHT WHAT WE'LL JUST WE'LL
START WE CAN WE CAN WITH THE
BECAUSE AGAIN SO -- FIRST UP SB
ONE THIRTY GALGIANI THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATION
CURRENT FOUR TO SIX YOUR CHAIR
VOTING I'D PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THERE'S JONES [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE OKAY EIGHT ZERO WE WILL
CLOSE THAT.
THE BILL IS OUT SB TWO HUNDRED
MONNING.
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATION CURRENT
LOTUS FIVE ZERO SURE VOTING I'D
[inaudible]
CENTERS JONES [inaudible]
ORIGIN [inaudible]
YOU HAVE.
ALL RIGHT YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
BURGESS [inaudible] ZERO
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I OKAY -- THE MEASURE IS SIX
VOTES THAT IS OUT WE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE I SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
DODD MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAVERT IS
FIVE YOUR CHAIR WAITING ON
SENATORS JONES.
JONES AE ALLEN AYE AYE ALLEN
AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON JACKSON
ISLAND.
VERY GOOD THE BILLS ARE NINE
ZERO CLOSE THE ROLE FILE IN OUR
FOR SB TWO FIVE THREE DODD TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATION
GRANDFATHER'S FIZER CHAIR VOTING
I CENTERS JONES.
JONES AYE ALLEN AYE AYE ALLEN
AYE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON NINE BILLS OUTLINES THE
BILLS ARE -- NINE ZERO NEXT AS
FAR UNDER FIVE SENATE BILL FOUR
ZERO TO THE MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS BURNT VOTE IS
FORTY ZERO JR VOTING I'D.
SENATORS ALAN HI ELLEN AIKA BIRO.
BIRO I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO JACKSON
[inaudible]
JACKSON NO.
THE OF THAT IS.
WE'VE BEEN TO ONE SEVEN THE ONE
THAT MEASURE I'M SORRY HANG ON
THAT THAT'S FORTY FOUR YET OF
COURSE ZERO TWO I'M SORRY THAT
IS FOUR ZERO TWO BORDERS
VEHICLES OFF ROAD HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATION KENNY OF
INDIA -- MAN OKAY I MENTALLY OFF
BUT IF I CAN'T I'LL GO OUT AND
I'M SORRY AS A YOU ARE ALREADY
ON RECORD AS WHERE YOU CAN GO
I'D IN OUR BODIES YOU GOTTA GO
EITHER I DON'T KNOW.
OR STICK WITH IT SORRY A GUY NOW
I DON'T KNOW.
ALLEN I DIDN'T KNOW.
THE FIFTH -- I'M.
SORRY SERVICE IS SOME SOLIDARITY
I'M HEARING.
I'M I'M SORRY. SIXTY SIXTY TWO
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND SEE
WHAT IF ALLEN CAN LEAD
INSURRECTION.
ALL RIGHT -- NEVER A DULL MOMENT.
OKAY -- WE'VE GOT PROPOSED
CONSENT -- WHAT IS IT SOCIALIST
YOU ARE YEAH OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR ACTUALLY LET'S DO HIM
ALL AT ONCE OF THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARM PROPOSED CONSENT WE
HAVE FILE ITEM SIX IS BEFORE FOR
TO DODD?
FILE ITEM TEN SB FIVE OF SEVEN
ATKINS FILE ITEM SIXTEEN SB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE IT'S A
COMMITTEE BILL THIS WAS
SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
ALSO COMMITTEE BILL.
WAS THERE ANY OBJECTIONS.
MOTION THIS CALL THE ROLL AND
THERE'S STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES JONES I BARGES.
OR JUST I'D HAVE BUREAU.
HAVE YOUR AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I'D JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OUTLINES OKAY CAN [inaudible]
THE WITH.
YEAH HE WAS OKAY OKAY VERY GOOD
ALL RIGHT NINE ZERO THAT IS OUT.
NOW WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FORTY FOUR CABALLERO --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR VOTERS FOR
YOUR CHAIR VOTING ON SENATORS
ALAN.
ALLEN NO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO.
JACKSON.
JACKSON NO MONEY.
OKAY FIVE OF FIVE TO TWO WE WILL
LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBER.
SB FOUR SIXTY TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT COVERS FIVE ZERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS ALAN AYE.
ALLEN AYE SB ERRO.
CAREER HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON
[inaudible]
JACKSON I OKAY IT'S NINE ZERO
CLOSE THE ROLE THEY'RE FILING
NUMBER NINE IS BEFORE
[inaudible]
SEVENTY FOUR TURN.
CURRENT VOTE IS FORTY ZERO DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THEN THERE'S ALLEN
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ALLEN NO.
NO NO.
ORANGES.
YEAH WE'RE JUST HIGH -- HI
[inaudible]
THERE'S VERY.
AS FOR NO JACKSON JACKSON I WE
WILL ALLOW THE MEMBER NOT ALLEN
NO DICE.
ALLEN I KNOW THERE ARE A WE HAVE
[inaudible]
LIVE.
OUT NINE NINE ZERO BY THEN SKIN
OF OUR TEETH -- SENATE BILL.
FIVE FIFTEEN FILE ITEM ELEVEN
FOLKS.
Và HITS ROLAND WE ALREADY WE
DID FILE ITEM TEN THOSE ON
CONSENT.
YES.
OF A LEVIN IS FIVE FIFTEEN
CURRENT -- I'M SORRY WE'LL SKIP
THAT HUESO NOT HERE. TWELVE WILL
KEEP THAT ON CALL SB FIVE FIVE
ONE IS NEXT JACKSON -- THAT'S A
FOUR ZERO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THERE'S STONE I MEAN
STERN SORRY HI.
STERN I'D JONES.
JONES NO.
GORGEOUS OR JUST NO CABALLERO.
CABALLERO NO HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
I CANTIK.
ALL RIGHT SIXTY THREE THAT
MEASURE IS OUT WILL CLOSE ROLE
THERE WE HAVE -- NUMBER THIRTEEN
SB.
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
GENERAL DENNIS HERTZBERG.
AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE THOSE OUT OKAY BILLS
ON NINE ZERO WE FIND FOURTEEN SB
SIX SIX A RUBIO CURRENT VOTERS
THREE ZERO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR STERN HI STERN AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I BORDERS.
WE'RE JUST I'D COME BUREAU.
I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
JACKSON.
JACKSON I AN UNEVENTFUL NINE
ZERO AND THEN -- FINALLY A FILE
AND FIFTEEN SB SIX EIGHTY TWO
ALLEN -- THREE ZERO THE MOTION
IS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS.
STILL NEEDS YOUR VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IT IS JONES.
MS NO [inaudible]
OR JUST [inaudible] ZERO I
HERTZBERG.
HE GOT THEM.
YOU WANT.
TO HUESO MY BILL EARLIER TODAY.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE OKAY --
RIGHT SO THAT THE SIX TWO ZERO
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON WILL
KEEP THESE MEASURES ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBER.
YES AND I JUST HAVE A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE MISTER LEAST.
I DIFFER THERE'S HISTORY IN THIS
HOUSE.
AND THERE'S PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERVED BEARD AND GREAT
INCREDIBLE THINGS.
AND ONE OF THOSE HUMAN BEINGS A
SAID IN THIS AUDIENCE HE SERVED
AS CHAIRMAN THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE OF THIS PLACE AND IF
ANYBODY IS UPSET ABOUT ALL THE
SECURITY SYSTEMS AROUND THIS
CAPITAL YOU CAN BLAME THAT
GENTLEMAN HE WENT ON TO SERVE IN
CONGRESS. FOR MANY YEARS AND
HE'S HERE TODAY HIS NAME IS
CONGRESSMAN DENNIS CARDOZA.
HE'S IN THE FROM THE VALLEY IS
HERE TODAY.
RECOGNIZE HISTORY IN THE HOUSE.
I I ALSO HEARD SOME -- SOME
HISTORY ABOUT AT A FORMALLY
RESTRAINED BOB HERTZBERG THAT
WAS -- SOMEHOW REIGNED IN BY THE
ILLUSTRIOUS CONGRESSMEN SO I I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW.
YOU ALL CAN TAKE OFF WE'RE GONNA
WAIT FOR HUESO ONLY THOSE
MEASURES ON CALL BUT I
APPRECIATE.
YOU BEING HERE FOR THE ONE
RESOURCES.
FIESTA YEAH YES -- RIGHT EXACTLY
I'M [inaudible]
OKAY -- YEAH.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
[inaudible]
NO NO.
I SO OTHERWISE ON YEAH WELL YOU
KNOW.
I THINK THE NEXT [inaudible]
BY --
I AND WOMEN
-- YEAH
[inaudible]
RIGHT NOW
WALKING [inaudible]
AROUND
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE ON FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER ON
SOME OUTSTANDING ITEMS WE HAVE
SENATE.
BILL FOUR ZERO TWO FIVE ONE OR
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS.
SIX TO TO ENTER HUESO.
WITHOUT SIXTY TWO OKAY HERBS
TENSION THERE'S SIX TO THE BUILD
OUT A SENATE -- PHONE NUMBER.
SEVEN BEFORE CABALLERO.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO TWO
A CHAIR VOTING HI INNER HUESO.
HUESO I CLOSE THAT THAT'S AT SIX
TO FILE AND NO ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
FIFTEEN MOTION.
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE COVERS --
EIGHT ZERO HELLO THE TWENTY
SINCE THIS IS THE SYSTEM WATER
MORE FREE FIVE ONE FIVE THIS
RENEWAL ANYONE WHO'S WHO'S THE
AUTHOR HAVE A HERO.
IT'S THE COVER YOUR BIO MASS
WHEN THAT WENT TO YOUR COMMITTEE
LESS YEAH YEAH YEAH.
AND SHE ACCEPTED YOUR MEN.
SO THAT'S ALL HERE.
CENTER HUESO.
WE SO I IT'S OUTLINES ZERO EIGHT
AND THEN THE FINAL.
ONE SB SIX EIGHTY TWO ALLEN --
SIXTY ONE CURRENT VOTE PLEASE
FEDERAL UNDER WAY SO.
I THAT'S OUT SEVEN TO ONE ALL
RIGHT -- THAT BILLS THAT WE WILL
IN TURN